[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have another excellent episode for you
guys today but before we get into it I
just wanted to express a bit of
gratitude and thank everyone for the
positive response to the last episode
we've obviously had a bit of a change in
on-air Talent we were slightly
apprehensive about how that was going to
go over just to just to be totally
transparent uh but it's it's been great
the response has been great uh all of
you guys have been great so uh yeah just
just here at the top of the show I just
wanted to thank you for that
um so yeah let's let's get into it
Lindsay what's what's been on your mind
recently
what has been on my mind yeah have you
well I have a recommendation does that
count yeah yeah okay so
sturdy girl club is my recommendation
this is a BBC stand up series by a
comedian named Jessica fosticu
and I've never seen this format before
it's these short like 15 minute episodes
presented like stand-up comedy it's in
front of a live audience because there's
like laughter going on but it's kind of
a little documentary style show about
lifting and she has four episodes
um about like different types of lifting
that she has tried so the first one is
strong man that's how she got into
lifting and then there's a powerlifting
one an Olympic weightlifting one and a
bodybuilding one and for all of those
except for bodybuilding she actually
like competes in those sports like for
the little episode and she also
interviews uh athletes like Elite
athletes and all of those Sports and
just generally talks about like what
it's like to kind of be a woman in
lifting and the comments she gets and
like how her parents disapprove of it
but how it has totally transformed like
the way that she thinks about her body
and I just thought it was really fun and
I actually got this recommendation from
a newsletter that I'm also going to
recommend it's Casey Johnston's
newsletter she's a beast and I think I'm
probably going to bring Casey up a lot
on this podcast because her newsletter
is great she writes these really
excellent essays about all types of like
everything you'd want to know about
lifting a nutrition and about what's
going on
um and the media she's a journalist
but she also just really has her finger
on the pulse of recommendations for all
of those things so if you just kind of
want to know like what other blogs are
saying or what's going on on Tick Tock
or like just funny memes about lifting
Casey has all of them it's a great read
nice uh that that sounds very fun and uh
I'm I'm a little upset that you haven't
told me about this before I just found
out this morning I listened to do it
literally this morning in that case that
scans and uh our our marriage is still
on oh thank God it's still on firm
footing okay Greg what's been going on
with you uh yeah so not much interesting
has actually been going on in my life uh
so we're we're currently working on a
big micronutrient relate related uh
release and feature set for macro Factor
um so my my head has just been in the
micronutrients for about the last two
weeks or so
micronutrients and also aspartame which
is the the topic of of this episode
um so yeah not too much interesting
beyond that but I also have a bit of a
recommendation a somewhat contextual
recommendation I guess uh and that is
that I've recently started using a
pre-prepared meal company
um I'm doing uh what's it called Factor
yeah is it called factor or factor 75. I
don't know the website is Factor 75 but
all The Branding just says Factor yeah I
don't know whatever
um anyway so it's uh
we don't have like an affiliate code or
anything not sponsored yeah yeah not
sponsored not looking to get sponsored
nothing like that
um but yeah I've I started using it and
it's it's been nice
um I
previously assumed that pre-prepared
mule Company products would not be great
um mostly because like people had shared
their kind of like meal prep Service
Company food with me in the past and it
wasn't very good yeah so it very well
could just be that this class of service
isn't great but Factor itself is good
um but yeah the the stuff they said
they've sent me has has been nice
um it fits my macros pretty well
um it's good to have a bit more variety
in my diet instead of just eating
literally the same thing for every meal
for a week straight which is which is
exactly what you did yeah that that's
what I do when I meal prep
um so yeah it's it's been great it's
been great
um and and also the the the cost isn't
that bad so yeah if you're a busy person
and you don't uh you don't want to think
too much about where you're going to get
your next meal and when you're going to
have time to cook or if you don't have
food on hand like where you're going to
go out and get food or or order from
like ah there might not be uh great
restaurants in my area that have healthy
options or whatever
um if if any of that sounds like you
um yeah it might be worth looking into
going with a a pre-prepared meal service
I personally have found it to be
um
I wouldn't I wouldn't say great but I
would say pretty good I would say pretty
good yeah seems like it's been really
helpful especially during this time that
you've been super busy with
micronutrient content yeah
um so yeah let's let's get into it
before we jump into the actual content
for this episode uh we have our list of
kind of standard plugs so to start with
if you listen to the show you like the
show make sure to like rate subscribe
whoever you listen to podcasts
um it it's a small thing but it does
help the show a lot if you're interested
in some excellent high quality coaching
for either lifting or nutrition or both
uh we have a coaching program at
Stronger by science and a group of
world-class coaches ready to help you
reach your goals
um if you're looking for high quality
supplements at a good price
um check out bulksupplements.com you can
use code SBS POD at checkout for a five
percent discount if you're looking for a
food tracking app that will help you set
nutrition targets to reach your goals uh
coach you along the process update those
targets week to week check out our app
macro Factor you can get a one week free
trial or use code SBS at checkout to
extend that trial to two weeks
um get in now before all that hot
micronutrient content drops yeah yeah
absolutely
um if you would like to check out a high
quality research review to stay up to
date on the research that's relevant to
strength and physique athletes check out
Mass that's monthly applications and
strength sport
again much much like factor I get I get
nothing from this recommendation I'm no
longer affiliated with them uh it's it's
something that I used to do for a long
time recently left but guess what it
still rocks and you should check it out
it is still an excellent product and
service
um and if you want to connect to other
people who like the show or pester us
about the show or say hey you should
cover XYZ topic whatever the best place
to connect with us is probably our
Facebook group and or subreddit it's
just Stronger by science community on
Facebook and reddit.com r slash
slash stronger by science uh if you want
uh free study breakdowns uh hitting your
inbox every other week on on the podcast
off weeks basically alternating
newsletter week podcast week newsletter
week podcast week
Etc uh subscribe to the stronger by
science newsletter you can do that at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter and uh
it's it's great it's it's just content
like we're we're not going to spam you
with stuff it's uh it's very nice and
then uh finally on the last episode I
mentioned that we want to start doing
audio q and A's at the end of most
episodes we will probably not do that
this episode code as you're listening to
this I'm sure you can see how long it is
I don't yet know how long it will be but
we went wild I I do know how long our
outline is and it's very long so I
expect this to be a long episode
um so we are foregoing a question at the
end of this episode but if you'd like to
get your questions answered on the
podcast uh record an audio file UH 60
seconds Max and email it to podcast
strongerbyscience.com and if we like it
we will answer it on the podcast
um so yeah let's let's get into it yeah
this episode we're talking about
aspartame it's been in the news of late
because the World Health Organization
has uh recently uh classified it as a
possible carcinogen there was a lot of
discussion leading up to that because
the news that they were going to
classify it as a possible carcinogen
leaked uh earlier this month at the
start of July so there there was kind of
a a wave of chatter leading up to it and
then the decision dropped like two or
three days ago as of the time that we're
recording this uh probably about a week
ago as of the time that this episode
will release
um so yeah it's it's uh it's been on
people's minds and we're going to talk
about that in this episode uh so lens do
you wanna do you want to give people
just a brief outline of what they can
expect in this episode yeah let's do
that because we are going to go through
a lot so I want you to just kind of have
an idea of the journey that we're going
to take you on so that maybe if one
thing doesn't interest you you can wait
around for the next thing
um but we really are trying to tell you
everything that you need to know about
aspartame in this episode
so that's going to start with history
and early conspiracies about aspartame
what the Press coverage has looked like
over the years and then Greg has is
going to go into the president who
reports as well as all of the relevant
research about aspartame before we then
talk about what the media coverage looks
like of the who reports and give some
concluding remarks about like what the
takeaways of this are going to be
absolutely so do you want to lead us off
and just briefly tell people uh what
Aspartame is yeah just to make sure
we're all kind of on the same page I'm
just going to give you this quick
definition from examine.com what a great
website
asper tame is a low-calorie artificial
sweetener used as a sugar substitute in
foods and beverages it is 200 times
sweeter than sucrose and is commonly
found under the trade name's NutraSweet
and equal those are the ones used in
North America
canderal in Europe and pal Suite in Asia
so just as a few examples Aspartame is
used in a lot of sodas like Diet Coke
Sprite Zero Pepsi Zero sugar and
Mountain Dew zero sugar but it's also
used in just a bunch of other random
stuff so like extra chewing gum
Snapple drinks cough drops and even some
toothpastes have aspartame in them
so Greg do you want to tell us a little
bit about how artificial sweeteners work
sure yeah so you have cells on your
tongue that are primarily responsible
for taste sensations uh the the basic
taste for the most part so most of the
complex flavors you get from food that
is mostly scent based which is why
things don't taste like anything when
you're super stuffy because those
volatile scent compounds aren't getting
up uh deep into the back of your nose so
yeah you're you're not picking up on
that stuff but actual taste itself you
got you got sweetness you got sour
bitter
Umami and uh and salty those are those
are the basic tastes
um and yeah there there are different
cell types on your tongue that
um detect each of those Sensations and
the the cells that detect
um both both sweet and Umami it's it's
the same cell and it's actually uh
similar receptors on on the same cell
and there are basically little binding
regions in these receptors and when
something can latch on to uh the the
particular binding region of one of
those receptors that corresponds with a
particular taste sensation uh there are
kind of Downstream proteins that are
activated which then tickle some nerve
fibers that goes up to your brain and
you perceive something as tasting sweet
so the way artificial sweeteners work is
they bind to kind of the same regions of
the same taste receptors as sugars do
um
they often bind either quite a bit like
harder and Tighter or just through some
other mechanism they they indicate to
that receptor that like hey there's a
lot of sugar in this it's very sweet you
hey brain you should perceive this as
being very sweet
um but they are not sugar so essentially
they bind to the same receptors they
have the same effect in your brain and
in the way that that you perceive them
the the sensation they generate
um but they either don't have calories
or in the case of aspartame uh it's
actually not a no calorie sweetener but
it's a very very very low calorie
sweetener
um so yeah they they basically have the
same effect as sugar without having
nearly as much energy content
um and yeah that's that's how they work
yeah so I know that there are other
artificial sweeteners other than just
aspartame and some of the early ones
were saccharin and cyclamate Greg I knew
you did some research about like what
the process of those coming onto the
market look like and how that kind of
informs how skeptical people are about
aspartame still so do you want to get
into that yeah so so artificial
sweeteners in general have a long and
interesting history
and I think a lot of the current kind of
kind of bubbling Baseline level cultural
concern that people have about
artificial sweeteners in general and
aspartame in particular owes a lot to
the history that these substances have
had so just want to start with the
history one because I I think it's very
fun and interesting
um it's just a fun story I think and I
also think it's important for giving the
necessary context to understand kind of
that that Baseline level of anxiety that
a lot of people feel about artifact
official sweeteners and therefore why
the recent announcement from the World
Health Organization really kind of blew
up into a big thing that everyone heard
about so let's start all the way back in
year of Our Lord 1879 when there was a
chemist named Constantine fallberg who
was working with coal tar derivatives so
those are those are byproducts of coal
of the coal refining process
um and when he was working with those
coal tar derivatives he discovered uh
saccharin which was the very first
artificial sweetener
basically he'd been working with these
coal tar derivatives all day this was
back before PPE like like personal
protective equipment for working with
chemicals was was good or really existed
much in the first place so he he'd just
been working with uh with these coal tar
derivatives all day and I guess like
licked his hand or something before
before adequately watching licking her
hand on the job yeah which I gotta say a
little bit late for that I think like
1879 was late enough that people already
knew about hand washing by then
um but yeah yeah he just noticed his
hand tasted sweet after working with
these cold hard derivatives and so he
decided to to poke around a little bit
and figure out which one actually
produced The Sweet Taste and it was a
chemical called
benzosulfamide which is what we now know
as saccharin
um so
you look like you want to say something
well I mean I'm just thinking coal tar
Yes sounds disgusting yes you you and a
lot of other people
um so it seems like that would not be a
sweet thing to add to foods and
beverages yes so so this is where a lot
of the initial skepticism about
artificial sweeteners came from in the
first place
um that makes sense when people heard
about this like hey you you want me to
put this in my body and it's a cold hard
derivative like that that sounds very
bad
um but in actuality this is a fairly
common thing and it's not as scary as it
sounds so there's a a huge industry that
is a good thing of using kind of
byproducts of industrial manufacturing
to do other things with uh because
essentially like you're when you extract
coal from the ground you refine it down
to a product called coke uh not
Coca-Cola not cocaine is it spelled the
same way as Coke yeah I c-o-k-e okay uh
but yeah that's what you're trying to
get from from coal when you mine it
which is essentially just coal gas and
and like carbon itself like that's the
kind of the com the the thing that
actually combusts and burns really well
yeah
um so you you start with basically a
rock and you're trying to get it down to
this finished product and there are just
a lot of byproducts along the way and
when you have a when you have a prod
product of a byproduct of some process
of industrial refining you can either
just throw it out which just increases
waste yeah like I I don't think people
would want there to just be like vast
oceans of coal tar uh floating around
somewhere or you can essentially recycle
it like find other yeah things to do
with it
um which yeah both decreases waste and
also helps make something more
profitable so you're mining charcoal and
instead of just getting one finished
product from it that being the actual
Coke itself uh you get other useful
things from it and so like this this
General process is very common and
widespread and
um
this I think an example that most people
in the audience would be familiar with
is whey protein so whey protein is
primarily a byproduct of the cheese
making process most of the proteins in
cheese are casein proteins uh milk
itself the protein content is like 80
casein 20 whey and the casein itself
kind of is is better at forming the the
globules necessary to give cheese its
characteristic texture so yeah when when
you make cheese you you basically start
by
making Blobs of casein protein and then
yeah and then the the water and the
lactose and the Whey is mostly left over
and so you could discard it or you could
refine it a little bit further extract
the way from it and then uh you know
create the bodybuilding industry yeah
you use it as like a post-workout
protein shake so uh that's one good
example another one is uh if you take
like a collagen supplement or you use
gelatin in your cooking
um that is a byproduct of like The
Butchery industry so it makes sense you
know you you slaughter a cow or whatever
it's it's mostly from cows
um yeah you slaughter a cow you you know
cut the steaks off its body you get most
of the leftover meat grind that up
that's hamburger meat
um and then you you have the skeleton
left over and you this is getting gross
I mean no no it's gross but like I I
don't think people think that often
about where their food actually comes
from no of course but yeah this is this
is where most of the collagen and
gelatin you consume come from yeah you
you have the bones of the cow and you uh
like the the bones the tendons the
ligaments which are all collagen-rich
tissues and uh like the the nap kind of
the quote unquote natural way you would
get collagen is you would just take beef
bones and boil them for a long time and
the resulting stock is going to be very
rich in collagen uh like if you cook it
way way down and then let it cool it'll
set up exactly like jello would yeah
um but yeah like there are industrial
processes for for more efficiently
extracting collagen and not having a
bunch of other beef flavor come along
with it yeah but yeah it's it's the same
sort of deal like you you take something
that would otherwise be discarded and
find something else that's interesting
and useful to do with it
and with those two examples that might
seem quite a bit more benign because
you're starting with milk and you're
starting with with cows you're not
starting with with coal tar right yes
but there is another example of
something that you probably have in your
house and that a lot of people ingest
every day and uh it sounds like the
start of a scaremongering article no
like it's I don't like like here this
this is one of the reasons why like
scare mongering yeah like I'm sure too
some people listening what I'm talking
about sounds scary but it's like totally
normal and fine so tell us what we all
have in our house aspirin yep yeah so a
lot of people take a baby aspirin every
day to reduce their risk of heart
attacks or Strokes a lot of people take
aspirin if they have a headache or a
muscle ache or whatever
um
but yeah most of the ass I think like
all of the aspirin that would be in pill
bottles on your shelves uh is a it comes
from a byproduct of uh petrochemical
manufacturing
um and so like I think a lot of people
have this view of aspirin that it is
like somewhat quote unquote natural
because the OG aspirin uh was derived
from willow bark so there's a chemical
in willow bark called salicylic acid and
um people have known about this for a
long time so kind of like
ancient folks that lived in places with
a lot of Willow realized that if they
were running a fever or they had some
sort of ache they could chew on willow
bark and they didn't know why but it
seemed to kind of alleviate those those
bad things that they were feeling
um 1800s rolled around chemistry gets a
little bit better uh people realize that
the salicylic acid was the actual
primary chemical in the willow bark that
was having those effects and um so yeah
that's that's where a lot of the early
painkillers came from from willow bark
uh and uh another herb as well called
Meadow Suite which which is also High
very wholesome as well yeah no like that
that does sound very nice yeah yeah is
this salicylic acid they they used the
same as the salicylic acid that's used
in like skin care products now because
that is still like you still see that
name on shelves do you really yeah like
it's a very pop popular skin care
product for like acne I don't know a
goddamn thing about skin care but uh
I assume it's the same I think so yeah
so
um but yeah so that that's where kind of
the the original aspirin came from it
was salicylic acid from Meadow Sweet and
willow bark sounds very nice yeah uh and
then in 1853 a chemist named Charles
Friedrich Gerhard synthesized acetyl
salicylic acid for the first time and so
acetyl salicylic acid or is uh like that
is what aspirin is today okay which is
the same thing it's the salicylic acid
but it has an acetyl group bound to it
you don't need to know what that is
doesn't matter
um but it's it's basically just better
than the original salicylic acid because
the the OG product that you would get
from chewing on willow bark
um is effective at pain relief but it
also causes a lot of stomach irritation
and so if you wanted to use it regularly
if you had some sort sort of like
chronic pain condition or something it
could cause a lot of stomach irritation
cause a lot of digestive issues and
acetyl salicylic acid worked just as
well for pain relief but also alleviated
a lot of those gastrointestinal symptoms
nice
um so yeah it was a better product but
it was still inefficient to make at
scale uh because you still needed to
start with the salicylic acid itself
right which you still got from refining
willow bark and and predominantly by
this time Meadow Suite so you needed to
basically just pick a bunch of herbs and
extract this one chemical from them
which was very time consuming and very
expensive and then the the chemical
process of adding the acetyl group to it
like that that was quick and easy but
you know the the raw material was still
pretty tough to get your hands on and
pretty costly
um so then over time chemists chemists
just got better and they realized they
didn't actually have to extract
salicylic acid from Willow Park or
Meadow Suite they could actually just
make it themselves yeah pretty easily
and pretty efficiently from Benzene
which is
primarily a byproduct of petrochemical
production okay
um so
essentially salicylic acid is just a
Benzene ring so Benzene itself is a kind
of hexagonal ring of carbons where some
are single bonded some are double bonded
whatever
um and uh so salicylic salicylic acid is
just a Benzene ring with a hydroxyl
group bound to one of the carbons on the
ring and a carboxyl group bound to a
different carbon and that and that's it
and hydroxyl groups and carboxyl groups
there they're everywhere like they're
kind of easy to get your hands on
um and so if you're a reasonably bright
chemist and you have access to the right
chemicals and materials and whatnot
you can go through a couple pretty
straightforward chemical reactions to
make salicylic acid from Benzene so the
first is called the cumin process which
is how you kind of add the hydroxyl
group to the Benzene ring and another is
called the colbay Schmidt reaction for
adding the carboxyl group and the cumin
process itself also involves propylene
which is another byproduct of
petrochemical manufacturing
um so yeah I guess there are like two
petrochemicals kind of involved in in
manufacturing aspirin
um but yeah so uh
that's that's about it uh
it's a lot about aspirin and this
aspartame yeah episode yeah so that that
is how that is how salicylic acid is
produced in bulk today and then it's
kind of the same thing as before you
just add the acetyl group to it you have
acetyl salicylic acid you have aspirin
and it is it is the exact same product
right that you would get from refining
uh from willow bark or meadowsweet but
it is much quicker and cheaper and
easier to produce and it it also like
recycles instead of discarding benzene
uh and propylene you use them to make
something else that is good and useful
that is safe to ingest which is which is
aspirin yeah
um
so yeah just just kind of like I wanted
to give that little detour because we
start with hey saccharin came from from
coal tar and that sounds very bad yeah
but you know the the origin of a product
doesn't necessarily imply that it's good
or bad right most coal tar derivatives
would probably kill you not good stuff
uh much like most petrochemical
byproducts would probably kill you
um but
not all of them do and so you know you
you don't want to you don't want to jump
to conclusions
but anyway so that that is where most of
the initial public concern came from
with saccharin like it it kind of got
out that hey this this
people discovered this from coal tar uh
and you know much like you and much like
probably a lot of people listening to
this episode you hear that and you just
automatically assume like there's
there's no way that this is good for me
like it it has to be a poison
essentially
um and also the Arrow when this came out
in was was relevant as well
um because saccharin was able to hit the
market before it before much safety
testing had been done so the late 1800s
were like that was the era of patent
medicines or like if if you hear the
phrase snake oil salesman yeah this was
the era of snake oil yeah salesman
um so what patent medicines were were
essentially just people going around
from town to town with an Elixir that
they said like ah this is going to cure
all of your problems and make you feel
good made you feel good because most of
them were just cocaine and heroin like
and and some other [__] as well but like
the the base of a lot of medicine was
just cocaine in here cocaine and heroin
which I'm sure did make people feel very
good suited
um but yeah and you could you could like
you didn't really have to do much if
anything to put a product on the market
to sell for human consumption right
um that's so scary yeah and so that was
the era when saccharin was introduced
yeah so so one
it did hit the market before it had
safety testing done on it and two
um people were very rightly quite
skeptical about a lot of new chemical
products hitting the market because
folks who had kind of like a shred of
skepticism
even in that era understood that patent
medicine was yeah like I just kicked the
coke habit do not get me hooked on
something else yeah like a lot of people
understood that there were folks selling
chemicals that they they that they made
claims about that sounded too good to be
true in this case it tastes like sugar
but there's no energy
um and a lot of the stuff people were
selling under similar pretenses was very
dangerous and bad
um but that regulatory environment
started changing in the U.S in 1906 with
uh the passage of the Pure Food and Drug
Act of 1906.
um
so people had started advocating for a
similar law in the 1880s but the thing
that finally got it over the hump was
the publication of Upton Sinclair's book
The Jungle
um there was so just for people who
don't know what that is uh Upton
Sinclair was a journalist who
um
wrote wrote books to try to like expose
the the social ills in society and try
to Spur people to legislative action to
change things and he actually wrote The
Jungle mostly to expose the industrial
exploitation of immigrant workers in the
Meatpacking industry yeah but in doing
that he also wrote a lot about how
disgusting the meat packing industry was
in that era
um and I I should have put this in the
outline but he he had a famous quote
along the lines of uh I aimed for the
Public's heart and I hit them in their
stomach because he was hoping the jungle
would
um would lead to legislation to protect
worker safety and reduce exploitation
but instead the people read it and said
holy [__] the meat packing industry is
disgusting let's let's regulate that
instead
um so yeah that's what got the Pure Food
and Drug Act passed in 1906.
and then in 1907 the head of the Bureau
of chemistry which was the the
department that would eventually become
the FDA okay
um he started looking into saccharin uh
Pure Food and Drug Act had been passed
he had been empowered to go through a
bunch of these chemicals that had been
put on the market what a job over the
last 50 years or so he had so much to do
yeah yeah no he he had a lot on his
hands
um and and yeah so in 1907 one of the
earlier things he decided to look into
was was saccharin okay
um this guy's name was Harvey Wiley and
uh Teddy Roosevelt was the president at
the time and Teddy Roosevelt was a fan
of saccharin
um and Harvey Wiley basically told Teddy
Roosevelt like hey I'm I'm gonna look
into this stuff uh I think it might be
sketchy
um and Teddy Roosevelt was basically
just like no [__] [__] you I like
saccharin and fired him oh no so
and again we're we're still talking
about the first artificial sweetener and
we've already gone from it was
identified from from coal tar yeah
to now essentially like the head of the
FDA got fired because they wanted to not
like not just ban it but investigate
whether they might want to ban it yeah
so if you just have like the smallest
inkling for like conspiratorial thinking
you you've already it's already a
two-strike situation yeah
um
and strike three came in 1911 when the
FDA labeled foods containing saccharin
as adulterated
um but they they clarified and said that
saccharin wasn't harmful in 1912 but
they did label it as an adulterant in
1911. what does that mean okay so yeah
that that doesn't mean much to Modern
audiences but that that meant a lot in
okay in the era
um so adulteration is a matter of
substituting uh a valuable it's it's
basically when
substitutions are made from
a product that people think they're
consuming to something that you're kind
of like
kind of like tricking them into
consuming almost uh and now we often
think about it in terms of something not
not meeting label claims or kind of like
being deceptive in marketing
um so we we've actually talked about
adulteration a little bit on the podcast
before in the context of cheese actually
oh
um where a lot of things marketed as
parmesan cheese in the U.S actually
contain no like
Parmigiano-Reggiano like the the OG uh
parmesan cheese most contain either no
actual parmesan or very very little and
it's just kind of cut with other cheaper
cheeses to produce I remember there was
something like years and years ago about
there being sawdust and like the shaky
bottles of cheese yeah that's that's
another thing that's blown like way out
of proportion so okay you don't have to
do that yeah let's briefly talk about it
whatever
um but yeah so yeah they say like
sawdust is in Parmesan cheese so one
it's not just Parmesan like it's most
pre-shredded cheese that you'd buy in
the store
um and it's not sawdust it's like
refined cellulose which is the stuff
that makes up the cell walls of plants
and they they dust cheese with it as an
anti-caking agent basically because if
you just yeah so it doesn't just become
like a massive lump in the bottle or the
bag right yeah like if you just get a
block of cheddar cheese or any kind of
cheese and shred it and then put it in a
bag and put that bag in the fridge when
you get it out it's just going to be all
clunky yeah it's not really even going
to be shredded anymore
um so yeah you you dust it with with
cellulose and that helps stop it from
clumping and uh yeah it's it's a totally
fine product like it's it's most of the
fiber you consume is cellulose so yeah
they just dust cheese with it but uh you
on an industrial scale you derive
cellulose largely from byproducts of
like oh my gosh when you're like uh
I don't know if refining is the right
word but you start with a tree and you
get Boards out of it and you can make a
lot of sawdust in the process and a lot
of that sawdust either turns into paper
or kind of like industrially refined uh
cellulose and quite a few other products
as well
um but yeah so that's that's where the
claim that there's sawdust in American
parmesan cheese came from yeah it just
has cellulosis and anti-caking agent
okay well this parmesan in those bottles
are so gross uh yeah it's not great
um so another product that I bet a lot
of people listening to this have
consumed that is adulterated regularly
is is olive oil oh and uh so a lot of a
lot of products on the U.S market I
think it's regulated quite a bit more
heavily elsewhere in the world
um the Italians would Riot yes but a lot
of things labeled as olive oil in the
U.S do contain olive oil but it's kind
of cut with cheaper oils
oh so you know you you put like some
canola oil or like sunflower oil in it
as well yeah so like it still is gonna
kind of have the color of olive oil
you're still going to get like a bit of
that bitterness that you expect but it's
just way way cheaper to produce because
pure olive oil is relatively expensive
sunflower seed oil is very cheap so yeah
if you adulterate your olive oil with
sunflower oil yeah it's going to be a
cheaper product
um so is it adulterated if it's not
labeled as being cut with other things
or
is it is it still adulterated if like
your olive oil bottle lists those other
ingredients like it's not necessarily
hiding it it's just marketing it in a
slightly confusing way
um so the kind of like modern definition
of adulterated it would be
I think it's I think it's mostly if it's
misleading yeah so definitely if it
doesn't match label claims like if it
says a hundred percent pure olive oil
but yeah with other oil it's definitely
adulterated I think sometimes a product
is considered adulterated if
uh it just says like olive oil and
everything about kind of like the The
Big Easy to read parts of the packaging
would lead a consumer to believe that
it's a hundred percent olive oil but
it's actually like 40 olive oil yeah uh
even if it does List It kind of in the
ingredients list I think I think
sometimes that counts as well
um but yeah like so that's that's
essentially what what adulteration is
yeah
um but some adulterants are like
actually very dangerous
um and that was definitely the case in
the early 1900s when saccharin was
labeled an adulterant or were they
putting in there yeah so if you're
[Music]
um
if you're someone in the early 1900s and
you hear that something is an adulterant
the first place your brain probably goes
to is alcohol that makes you go blind
perfect because
um a lot of ethanol products which
ethanol is the alcohol we drink and get
[__] up from and like if you drink a
lot of it it's it's not healthy in the
long term but like it's not going to
acutely kill you unless you just drink
way way too much of it and give yourself
alcohol poisoning right but methanol
which is very similar it's it's the same
thing but it's like one carbon shorter
um that oh that's something else you can
get from sawdust actually
um but yeah it's it's often called wood
alcohol
um but a little bit of methanol is
produced
I think in pretty much any alcohol
manufacturing like if if you've ever
heard of people discarding tips and
Tails in the distilling process the the
tip is the methanol
um like as they're boiling stuff off
methanol has a lower boiling point than
ethanol so uh the the first stuff that
boils off is the methanol you just you
discard that that's the tip and then the
tail is just like other other [__] uh
whatever so yeah uh a lot of alcohol
products meant for human consumption
were adulterated with methanol back in
the early 1900s and so yeah like these
days when we talk about adulterants
we're talking about like cheaper cheeses
and Parmesan or cheaper oils and olive
oil back in the early 1900s when
saccharin was labeled as an adulterant
you hear adulterant you hear oh it might
make me go blind like drinking methanol
would or just like some some bad [__]
like most adulterants were were really
bad news back then
um so yeah like like by 1911
saccharin came from coal tar basically
the head of the FDA got fired over even
wanting to investigate it and then it
got labeled as an adulterant and so
people were like
extremely extremely skeptical of it yep
um
and then the next artificial sweetener
that hit the market was cyclamate uh it
was discovered in 1937 by a graduate
student at the University of Illinois
named Michael sveda and this was also a
discovery purely by chance so he was
working on a drug to help reduce fevers
and he was he sat his cigarette down on
the lab bench smoking in the lab yeah uh
and when and when he picked it back up
and and took another puff he noticed
that the butt of his cigarette tasted
sweet and
um yeah the the pile of dust that the
butt of his cigarette or like the little
bit of dust that the butt of his
cigarette had been sat down on yeah was
cyclamate
um and so that's that's how it was
discovered just putting your cigarette
and substances in the lab yeah so we're
we're already kind of like
two for two with artificial sweeteners
that wouldn't have been discovered if uh
like
ideas of either industrial or lab safety
back in the day were what they are now
yeah like dude so when I read about how
cyclamate was discovered I was like
that's crazy
um like when I had to do lab training
for UNC
um yeah it's like you have and you know
we weren't working with like any
anything that was like particularly
dangerous like it was a biosafety level
2 lab and it's like yeah no definitely
no outside foods and beverages like if
you're working with most things you have
to have gloves on you have to have your
coat you have to have Cloud closed-toed
shoes you have to have glasses to avoid
any like spills uh you definitely
couldn't have [__] cigarettes
um
so yeah not just the fact that he was
smoking in the lab but that the
chemicals he was working with were just
kind of like dusted around yeah in the
place that he'd be sitting his cigarette
down crazy stuff lab safety back in the
day was was wild uh another just good
example of this is is another little
historical anecdote is uh Marie Curie
who I mean discovered a lot of things
about like radiation like like nuclear
science and all of that
um
like when she was doing that research
there were no conceptions of how
dangerous that stuff was but also just
Lab Safety in general yeah so now
Marie Curie is entombed in a lead casket
because her body is so radioactive that
like the mausoleum that she's in if she
was just in a normal casket that was say
surrounded by Stone or whatever yeah and
people wanted to go to where she was
buried to pay their respects it would it
would give them a potentially uh
dangerous dose of radiation so they've
had they had to put her her whole ass
dead body in a lead casket because of
how [__] radioactive She was That's
metal um that's so cool it's uh it's
something I'll tell you that it's not
it's not it's cool that
yeah sounds cool it's not cool that she
uh died of cancer correct uh so yeah
we've come a long way in terms of lab
safety yes
but yeah so that that is how cyclamate
was discovered and the pattern for it
was purchased by uh just all-time
dirtbags Dupont chemical
um and sold to Abbott Laboratories and
then
um Abbott Laboratories were the folks
who did these studies to show that
cyclamate was safe and it was approved
for sale in 1958.
um
and then not too long thereafter 1969 uh
a study was done
um on a ten to one admixture of
cyclamate and saccharin uh testing its
effects in in lab rats and it caused a
shitload of bladder cancer oh no
um and by this point uh saccharin had
already been like approved for sale for
a long time like it was it was almost
like grandfathered in as far as like
chemical safety goes
um but yeah so the like the substance
tested was a 10 to 1 mixture of
cyclamate to saccharin but but kind of
like due to how long saccharin had been
on the market
um uh regulatory bodies looked at that
and said hey these these effects they're
probably due to the cyclamate so uh very
soon thereafter
um
uh cyclamate was banned for sale in the
U.S yeah in 1970.
um then not long after that so you know
the the 10 to 1 mixture of cyclamate and
saccharin causing bladder cancer and
rats that's what got cyclamate pulled
from the market but then in the 70s they
did studies just on saccharin and found
that saccharin also caused a shitload of
bladder cancer in rats uh and so the FDA
attempted to ban saccharin in 1977 but
it wasn't banned and the primary reason
it wasn't banned is because there was
just so much public opposition to
Banning it but the primary reason there
was so much public opposition to Banning
it was because of a very very effective
uh like advertising and public interest
campaign driven by Abbott Laboratories
uh or not Abbott Laboratories they were
they were the cycle made folks but the
the folks who are like manufacturing
saccharin and the Bev the beverage
industry more broadly ran like a very
effective kind of like public lobbying
campaign to say Hey you know write your
representatives and Senators tell them
don't ban Sacrament uh and it worked
um
but that you know very understandably
smelled funny to a lot of folks yeah
because
saccharin probably would have been
banned were it not for that campaign by
the beverage industry right and
by law it probably should have been
banned uh in 1977. so in 1958
um or in the 1958 food additives
Amendment to the 1938 food drugs and
cosmetic act
um
the What's called the Delaney Clause was
added named after the representative
from New York that introduced it and the
Delaney Clause reads the secretary of
the Food and Drug Administration shall
not approve for use in food any chemical
additive found to induce cancer in man
or after test found to induce cancer in
animals
and so pretty clearly saccharin had been
found to cause bladder cancer in rats
yeah so by the letter of the law like
under the Delaney Clause of the 1938
food drugs and cosmetic act it should
have been pulled from the market in
1977.
uh but it wasn't again just due to how
much public pressure there was against
Banning it so a compromise was struck
um where instead of banning saccharin
the FDA required all products with
saccharin to Bear a warning label that
read and I quote use of this product may
be hazardous to your health the product
contains saccharin which has been
determined to cause cancer in laboratory
animals so that that label was put on
all saccharin products in 1977 and
stayed there until 2000.
um so you had what two and two and a
half or one and a half two generations
of people where every time they consumed
a saccharin product that that label hit
them
um
so
yeah like I think that gives a lot of
context for why there's just kind of
like so much public trepidation uh about
artificial sweeteners just just because
like there have been so many things like
like even before aspartame and there are
a lot for aspartame too that we're gonna
get to yeah that that make people
uncomfortable yeah for very
understandable reasons but after I've
after I've said all of like after I've
gone through this history and given all
of the reasons that people were again
very understandably concerned about
saccharin and cyclamate
um I just want to note so the the
warning label was taken off of Sacrament
in the U.S in the year 2000 saccharin
and cyclamate are both allowed for sale
I think almost everywhere but the US
um saccharin I think is
legal like to put in food almost
globally and cyclamate I think the US
and South Korea are the only or two of
the only countries where it's banned
like it's it's fine just about
everywhere yeah
um and like the EU has generally
stronger consumer protections than the
US does uh and even the the current
scientific consensus in in the U.S
Europe elsewhere is that neither
saccharin or cyclamate cause cancer in
humans
um so yeah after kind of going through
why all of this sounds scary let me tell
you why it's not okay so
yes both saccharine and cyclamate give
give rats and mice uh a bunch of bladder
cancer but the mechanism by which they
do that is not relevant to humans
because human physiology is
way more similar to rodent physiology
than I think a lot of us would like to
think about but yeah it's not identical
right and the important discriminating
Factor here is the composition of our
urine so humans have
relative to a lot of other animals
fairly dilute urine
rats have very concentrated urine so
they have way higher concentrations of
protein and sodium in their urine than
humans do
and under the right circumstances you
can get spontaneous reactions between
chemicals in urine like saccharin or
cyclamate uh you can get spontaneous
reactions between those chemicals and
the high concentrations of protein and
sodium ions to form like little
microscopic crystals and those little
microscopic crystals irritate the the
lining of the bladder yeah
um and that leads to cell damage
elevated levels of inflammation and
eventually cancer okay so it works so
even in mice and rats uh saccharin and
cyclamate aren't directly carcinogenic
the way that they induce bladder cancer
is kind of similar to the way that like
cancer risks just go up with age so when
you irritate tissues it just it causes
inflammation it increases cell turnover
and kind of the more free radicals you
have bouncing around just due to General
inflammation not even due to the Direct
effects of the chemicals themselves that
can cause some DNA damage and just the
more often cells have to turn over and
replicate because they're getting
damaged
um like the risk of little transcription
errors and DNA like as it has to be
replicated every time the cell divides
um you know every time that
transcription happens there can be like
errors in Translation
um you know which can just like change
genes increase risk of cancer whatever
so basically like that's that is how the
cyclamate and saccharin calls bladder
cancer in rats
um it it just irritated it that
increases cell turnover and when cells
replicate enough they the the risk that
they become cancerous increases yeah
um
so yeah like saccharin and cyclamate
aren't even like directly carcinogenic
in rats and mice yeah and the way that
they cause bladder cancer in those
species is not relevant to us because
those spontaneous reactions that cause
the crystal formation to irritate the
bladder lining uh you need a
sufficiently high concentration of
protein and sodium in your urine for
those reactions to occur and humans just
have dilute enough urine that we just
don't have enough sodium or protein in
our urine for cyclamate and saccharin to
react in that way in the first place
nice
um and
also saccharin and cyclamate don't cause
bladder cancer in rats at the doses that
humans would consume them yeah so the
the dosages of saccharin and cyclamate
used in those studies were equivalent to
humans drinking about 800 12 ounce Diet
Cokes a day
um
so yeah
basically
what I wanted to do with kind of this
history of other artificial sweeteners
is to lay the groundwork for
why people may have been very
understandably skeptical about aspartame
or any other artificial sweetener
hitting the market yeah because you
basically had close to 100 Years of
history of two products that as as we
now know like all of the current
scientific evidence suggests like
they're fine like they're not going to
give you cancer
um
but you know I think a lot of people
kind of work with the Assumption of if
there's smoke there's fire right but
where there's smoke there is not always
fire which is the case here but there's
been a shitload of smoke yeah and so you
know you had uh saccharin being
discovered as a coal tar derivative you
had the head of the Bureau of chemistry
getting [__] canned because he wanted to
look into saccharin
um you had uh saccharin being labeled as
an adulterant in an era where something
being labeled as an adulterant means
you're gonna die yeah was like that was
very bad news back in the day
um you you have a Dupont tie-in which
like by the time saccharin is being
introduced in the 80s
um kind of the role of DuPont and like
chemical manufacturers in general with
like agent orange and all the [__] that
went down in Vietnam and and Korea like
people don't talk about Korea enough but
they [__] should yeah
um yeah so a Dupont tie-in automatically
makes everything else seem more
skeptical uh you had studies showing
bladder cancer and mice and rats you had
cyclamate getting pulled from the market
uh you had saccharine uh
probably should have been pulled from
the market and wasn't which again like
if you're somewhat conspiratorial like
they they were probably violating the
Delaney Clause by keeping it on the
market yeah
um
and the fact that it wasn't banned
because of a public pressure campaign
driven by the beverage industry and then
you had like by the time aspartame was
being introduced to scary warning label
on saccharin packets
um like you you have all of that context
for Why by the 80s people were were
again very understandably
skeptical of and concerned about
artificial sweeteners like even though
saccharin and cyclamate are fine I am
so so sympathetic to people who
would have assumed that they wouldn't be
you know like
um
I I I feel like this sounds like
somewhat judgmental to say and I don't
mean it in a judgmental way but like
there is a certain level of like
scientific literacy that is necessary to
be be able to take
scary sounding tidbits and circumstances
and
put them aside and look at and weigh
what the actual data says and if the
data says something's fine being able to
like realize and understand there's a
lot of smoke here but there's not a fire
yeah and a lot of people don't have that
skill set and
most people don't [__] need that
skill set almost ever in their lives
right and
um
I mean people are busy they have a lot
going on yeah like like looking into all
of this stuff took me a lot of time yes
and it is my job to disseminate
information about like health and
fitness related stuff were it not my job
I wouldn't look into it that much you
know
um so yeah like the like the the
artificial sweeteners to to the point
that aspartame enters our story we now
know them to be safe for human
consumption they they aren't
carcinogenic they don't cause cancer but
if people at the time
just kind of knew anything about their
history and thought and just like
operated on the Assumption like ah yeah
this is probably going to give me cancer
I would not begrudged them that
assumption at all like I I definitely
understand where that assumption and
that trepidation comes from
so uh yeah that continues yeah that
continues with ask for Dave yeah we've
now entered the 80s so Lindsay tell me
tell me a little bit about the approval
process of aspartame and why
why like skepticism of aspartame in
general was very understandably built
atop this Foundation of skepticism for
artificial sweeteners in general yeah so
just like a little bit of background or
like tying together
um our segments here there's also
obviously kind of a gap in the market
that somebody wants to try to take
advantage of because people don't want
to purchase saccharin products so and
they couldn't purchase cyclamate at
least at least in the US right so yeah I
think
um that also is is necessary context
just that
the company who comes up with the next
viable artificial sweetener is going to
have dollar signs in their eyes so
um aspartame was originally approved for
use in dry Foods by the FDA in 1974 and
the company that makes Aspartame is
called GD Cyril and Company so I'll just
call it cereal from now on but they
submitted 168 studies on aspartame for
the fda's review and pretty soon after
it was approved
people mostly like anti-food additive
type folks which had started cropping up
probably because of a lot of the
cyclamate and saccharine stuff started
raising concerns about issues with the
safety studies that had been submitted
to the FDA so those studies that Cyril
submitted people started being like well
we're not sure that these are actually
like representative this company has a
lot of vested interest in making sure
that this product gets approved so in
December of 1975 the FDA placed a stay
on aspartame approval
which prevented Saul from marketing it
and a task force began investigating the
report from the task force found that
the studies were quote poorly conceived
carelessly executed or inaccurately
analyzed or reported
hell yeah I mean I one I have every
reason to suspect that that's true but
two like this was the 1970s go going
back to what I was talking about with uh
like lab safety from from that and like
the like like not not too long before
that
a lot of a lot of science back in the
day did just suck like yeah of course I
I imagine those were bad studies and it
sounds like they were even worse than
like the typical study they're probably
comparing it against a typical study
yeah I I
have every reason to suspect that a lot
of a lot of those studies were just
stinkers yeah
and read more about that if you're
interested like there's a lot of uh
content out there about like what the
specific issues with the studies were
but
um not gonna get into that here because
we have so much else to get through but
in in response to the report from the
task force the FDA asked the justice
department and U.S attorney Samuel
Skinner to open a grand jury
investigation and here's where we get
one of our first little uh conspiracy
nuggets Skinner the attorney recused
himself from the case because he was
considering a job offer from Cyril's
chicago-based Law Firm so the company
that makes aspartame
is trying to hire the attorney who has
been hired to investigate aspartame and
a grand jury investigation hell yeah
that that rocks and he he took the job
that's that's a great move hell yeah so
the grand jury investigation was delayed
and eventually the statute of
limitations on the charges against Cyril
expired so a grand jury was never
convened hmm
yeah so it should have been investigated
they had every intention of
investigating it and the lawyer who was
tasked with pulling together the grand
jury to investigate it got hired Away by
the company he was supposed to be
investigating and then no one else
actually took up the mantle to
investigate it yeah yep so that that
definitely doesn't smell good
yeah so over the next couple years
conflicting information about aspartame
continued to come out
um it seems like the thing people were
most concerned about at the time was a
potential association between the use of
aspartame and increased incidence of
brain tumors and that's a claim that
we'll see Pop Up throughout like that's
one of the specific things that people
kind of associate with Aspartame is
brain tumors and brain damage so in
early 1980 the FDA convened a
three-member public Board of inquiry so
this is like another means that they
have chosen to do for investigation
since the grand jury investigation
didn't work out and that public inquiry
concluded that aspartame did not cause
brain damage but that there is not
sufficient evidence presented that
aspartame did not cause brain tumors in
rats so as a result they recommended
against approval of pertain and
concluded that further study was needed
so
then the FDA did another review this
time paid for by Cyril the company that
makes aspartame that's crazy
I it's it's as if they just really want
to push their product through I mean I
I'm like I'm not even thinking about
like aspartame specifically right now
just I didn't know that that process
could exist I thought that government
agencies were funded by tax money and
that was it uh a private company being
able to pay a government agency to
review their own product and then
theoretically that review to look like
it has the stamp of approval from an
independent taxpayer-funded government
agency to support it instead of
it being the result of a process paid
for by the industry funding source
itself like that
I don't is that still legal I have no
idea either way that's not good that's
that's not good at all like just in
terms of like the way that government
interacts with industry like I I don't I
don't think that should be allowed yeah
so this review which again paid for by
Cyril concluded that the study is paid
for by Cyril had demonstrated that
aspartame was safe
so that's another nice like you have the
review paid for by the company reviewing
the studies paid for by the company so
people don't love that and then there's
one more wrinkle here that causes some
raised eyebrows at the time the chief
executive president and chairman of
Searle was Donald Rumsfeld oh yeah oh
Rumsfeld was also at this time part of
the newly elected Ronald Reagan's
transition team
and as soon as Reagan was elected he
appointed a new FDA head named Arthur
Hayes and shortly after Hayes
appointment to the head of the FDA he
took a look at the results of the most
recent Cyril sponsored review on
aspartame and immediately granted
approval in 1981. so also not a great
look
easily interpretable as Reagan just
doing his buddy Rumsfeld a favor because
it's it's rumsfeld's company
and also not great Haze the FDA head
left about a year later and took a job
as a consultant at searle's public
relations agency oh yeah
so you can see why this story also
raises people tackles a bit and provides
quite a rocky start for aspartame's
scientific record and chance of being
accepted as safe by anyone
yeah yeah I mean
again like
much like the much like the sacrament
encyclomate stuff like I
I absolutely understand why uh someone
would look at that and just immediately
assume like hey if they're if they're
doing all of this stuff to avoid
investigations or get investigations
done that they're paying for
um and uh you know doing
uh like the the tie-in between like
Rumsfeld and the Reagan Administration
um to yeah try to try to keep things
like approved and rolling along like I
can understand how someone would look at
all of that and be like look they they
must know their product is dangerous
because if they
didn't why would they go through all of
these link all of these links to avoid
like independent review and oversight
right because if they would be able to
withstand independent review and
oversight
um because their product is actually
safe it would it would make their
product look good to to actually get a
an objective third-party stamp of
approval from a government agency
therefore it must not be safe because
that's that's the only explanation for
why they would do all of this stuff like
that like that that to me is a very
understandable thought process it's a
super Rocky start and it comes up
so often like even in a lot of the
reporting I saw about these new who
reports which we'll talk about later
people are still bringing up the FDA
approval process as kind of like
gesturing towards impropriety and
gesturing towards controversy so like
they really kind of shot themselves in
the foot by just how
hard they push to get this through by
any means necessary
um
just just really quick let me cut in
um I I accidentally slandered Dupont
chemical earlier uh because I didn't
slam he'll never recover because I
didn't slander them hard enough
um the the it was so it was Dow Chemical
that was the Asian orange folks okay
um the the kind of historical thing that
Dupont chemical took a lot of heat for
and very understandably so was
continuing to do business with the
[__] Nazis until 1943.
um so yes Dupont sucks
just as bad as I implied that they did
but foreign
much much worse reason yeah
you know what I stuff is not good in any
context yeah I feel like it's hard it's
hard to ring we shouldn't be ranking
Dupont and Dow Chemical both both rod
and hell yeah two thumbs down yeah not
great
okay sorry that's all right
just wanted to make that quick
correction of course we don't want
DuPont's lawyers coming after us though
Greg would be delighted by that uh I
would not
um and also
I am making no claims about ongoing
relationships between Dupont chemical
and any current Nazis just that they
were way too cozy with the the Nazis
from the 30s and 40s uh so yes don't
don't sue us but uh yeah not not a great
not a great chapter in your history
Dupont chemical not good not good
can I get back to aspartame you can
thank you I apologize that's all right
so
if you remember aspartame has just been
approved
in a sketchy way
so in the 80s and 90s uh as pertains so
the aspartame's initial introduction to
the market was in 1981 and then approval
wide into soft drinks and 83 in 1984 so
after it had been approved for soft
drinks Cyril sold 600 million dollars
worth of aspartame and held the
exclusive patent so they are just raking
in the books which is why they were so
um adamant about getting an approved
um however even as aspartame sweetened
sodas became increasingly popular and
the FDA and CDC the CDC had recently
confirmed aspartame safety as well they
both tried to reassure critics that
aspartame was safe
um but the roots of conspiracy and
distrust really had been planted with
that messy FDA approval process and
aspartame remained pretty controversial
but most of the controversy was playing
out in governmental and legal settings
in the 80s and early to mid 90s
like proposed bills from
um like senators and stuff who felt
really strongly about this and repeated
attempts by a group called the community
nutrition Institute to have judges
overrule the fda's ruling on the
aspartame issue
none of this amounted to any substantive
action and the sale of aspartame
sweetened products continued to just
Skyrocket like people were really loving
the new the new beverages sweetened with
aspartame
the public aspartame controversy
didn't spread widely into the mainstream
until the late 90s
which is around the time that people
started having an internet connection
and I think that that's not a
coincidence like a lot of the early
controversy
um was being spread on blogs and like
email chains and the early internet and
people just not really knowing kind of
how to navigate how to how to check
sources was the perfect breeding ground
for panic and misinformation about
aspartame
so I think the most representative
example of that was a hoax conspiracy
theory disseminated via chain email an
early blog websites in 1999. so just
perfect like perfect encapsulation of
how conspiracies
um used to be spread I think I mean
people probably still have like send and
receive chain emails but it really had a
moment oh I I still get some changes
that was from from some some older
members in my family yeah and uh they
they do take me back to the Halcyon Days
when I when I first got my first email
account and there there was a bunch of
just like wild chain emails going around
that's that's really died down so
instead of viewing it as something
that's like scary and dangerous I'm just
like ah this takes me back yeah happier
more innocent time yeah yeah also let me
just say one one thing real quick about
the approval process before we okay we
we get down to the email like get into
the email chain Rabbit Hole
um so
uh you you presented a lot of
information about how sketchy the
approval process was of aspartame yeah
um kind of the the revolving door
between government and Industry all of
that stuff
um and I put forth
kind of the the conspiratorial case for
what that might imply like they they
know their product is dangerous which is
why they're trying to avoid independent
oversight yeah
um
another very distinct possibility and
one that I think is probably the case
here and is is often the case when kind
of like government oversight and
revolving door between government and
Industry and all of that stuff comes up
um like a not great but much more benign
reason that stuff like that can happen
is just that like
independent oversight even if your
product is fine and safe is still
expensive and annoying and could be bad
for your business so if there was a
grand jury investigation that did clear
your product and say hey this is safe
yeah but it stretches out for three
years and it that it stays in the news
like like aspartame cancer aspartame
cancer aspartame cancer just like right
next to each other in headlines for two
or three years uh even even if the net
result is like hey it's all it's all
good
um that's not going to be good for
aspartame sales yeah or uh like you know
the original studies were sketchy yeah
maybe they they should have done more
higher quality studies
um but if that is what got ordered
um
one that's going to be a cost like the
the government does oversight work but
what what they essentially do is tell
you as a company like hey you need to do
more research on your product AKA you
need to pay to do more research on your
product like the FDA is not giving you
the money to do those studies right
um so it's a cost and it's also a Time
sync like if they said hey you need to
do more stuff before we'll approve this
or whatever
um then you know you could be making
like millions or billions of dollars for
two or three years but instead you're
just doing expensive research for two or
three years yeah and you know the the
net effect is like ah product still gets
approved still hits the market it's
still safe for humans it's fine whatever
but like there's a Time cost there's a
monetary cost and in the case of like
the grand jury thing like if that was a
process that like I feel like grand jury
stuff always just drags on for a long
time yeah
um you know there could be like a more
direct economic cost if your product is
already on the market because people are
just going to see aspartame and cancer
next to each other in headlines for
months or years
um so even if it is so
like the the way that a business would
behave
if they have a product that is safe but
they just don't want to have to jump
through a bunch of Hoops to keep it on
the market and the actions a company
would take if they have a dangerous
product that they don't want to get
pulled from the market are the same set
of actions yeah and I think that it is
very easy to look at that set of actions
and draw the most nefarious possible
assumptions about it of course and I I
certainly understand where that impulse
comes from because a lot of businesses
have done a lot of really sketchy stuff
and would take actions resembling those
to cover up yeah like actually dangerous
[__]
um but that's that's not always the case
um
and yeah like it's
a single pattern of behavior can come
from to to very different underlying
sets of facts and I think it's I think
it's important just to keep that in mind
definitely yeah
okay let's let's get back to uh to email
threads okay chain emails chain emails
yeah so
um
yeah the most representative hoax
conspiracy theory was spread by this
person who claimed to be an expert named
Nancy Markle who said she'd quote spent
several days lecturing at the world
environmental conference on aspartame
that's not a thing like if you try to
Google it it's just like everything that
comes up is about this conspiracy I
think she just straight up made it up
um that's awesome but the theory like
her theory that she presents was of
course rooted in and explained by the
circumstances surrounding the FDA
approval but she also just gets kind of
wild with like all of the things she
starts saying
aspartame causes so yeah this this email
is kind of like
created to make it seem like it comes
from an expert like somebody who is at
this prestigious conference giving
lectures about aspartame in reality it
was likely
um just this lady from Georgia named
Betty Martini which is a great name it
really is
um she wasn't a physician but she was a
prolific internet user and she was
really passionate about posting her
aspartame trutherism on Usenet groups
nice so
not a physician but you know she had
that going for her uh but she does Play
One online she does she
um
The hoax
snail and it's
website called asper
s.com great URL great URL yeah yeah
pretty unbiased uh alleged that
Aspartame is responsible for
deep breath
multiple sclerosis lupus and methanol
toxicity causing blindness spasms
shooting pains seizures headaches
depression anxiety memory loss birth
defects and death
nice it's a lot that that is a lot and
it's
you know that looks very scary but it's
it's also one of those things where like
I love a conspiracy theory that
can be disproven just by like looking at
the world a little bit because it's like
you know someone who drinks diet coke uh
have they gone blind or had a seizure
you know maybe they've had headaches you
know maybe it's mostly the the mild one
but if they keep if they keep at it
they're gonna like have memory loss and
depression and whatnot and die but yeah
I mean this this just feels like one of
those things where you could go to any
restaurant look at how many people order
Diet Coke and be like
they look fine like it's but uh but yeah
if something seems scary enough it seems
like there's
um
there a lot of people have the ability
to just like shut off kind of those
critical faculties of yes does this even
happen to the reality test yeah yeah
coming from somebody who's
credible yeah who's presenting about
this at a conference yeah called the
world environmental conference
um she even claims that the ambassador
of Uganda and I I don't know which which
Ambassador it is
um was an in attendance at one of her
lectures
and told her that the sugar industry in
Uganda had been adding aspartame and
that he knew someone whose son could no
longer walk due to aspartame consumption
so now she's just like straight up being
like I know the ambassador of Uganda and
he knows this person who can't walk
that's that's also
I think fourth hand information which
yeah which is awesome the someone told
the ambassador of Uganda who told this
person uh who was speaking at the
conference who told the person who who
was writing about it yes and you are you
are now being told by someone over email
that all of this occurred maybe that's
fifth hand information that's that's a
great uh that's a great game of
telephone there that uh yeah we should
all definitely take very seriously
yeah uh but so this like this email it
seems just like a silly story it seems
like oh well how many people did this
actually affect but it actually was
super widespread it spread like wildfire
on the early internet and it's still
like apparently it still is kind of in
circulation today so it could be one of
those hoax emails that you've gotten
forwarded in recent years but it was it
was a really popular one people loved it
um and it even spurred an official
response from the FDA debunking the
claims so like this poor man who works
at the FDA went through this letter
debunking just like these wild claims
that just have no basis in anything
um oh man but it got so popular that
that became required for there to be an
official response yeah you know I I
gotta say like I um um
I understand to some extent how
email like chain email conspiracy
theories got big before people became
more like internet Savvy especially
because like these days like there are
plenty of conspiracy theories that get
big online
and it's a kind of like
distributed depersonalized thing yeah
where you know maybe there's like a
social media user that you follow who
like you don't personally know but it's
like uh they seem to be on the same
general wavelength and like maybe you
see something from them and
you approach that as like they've vetted
this information it must be true or you
just like search something and like
stumble across a website but it's such
as aspartamekills.com such as
aspartamekills.com right sure yeah
um but but it is like
it is like a kind of abstracted thing
like you either you often either hear
about it from someone you know nothing
about
um or you just like stumble across and
it's just like ah someone said this on a
website is it true is it not who knows a
lot of people determine it is true like
in spite of all of that but with chain
emails
you're getting you're getting forwarded
something typically from someone you
know in real life like these days we
email with people that we've never met
but like back in 1999 yeah the only
people who had your email address were
like friends and family because email
wasn't a huge a huge thing and so like
you know if if your cousin or Aunt or
like mom or brother or whatever is
forwarding you some sort of like very
scary chain email it's it's coming from
someone that you know and probably trust
with kind of the the tacit uh assumption
that like they're forwarding me this
because they vetted this information and
they have my best interests at heart and
they're trying to keep me safe yeah
um and so you know a couple like if by a
few years later I think people better
understood the phenomenon of chain
emails and to not take them very
seriously but but early on like I I
understand why chain emails could catch
on like this and be so big because
before you know to be skeptical of it
and you kind of have those those
antibodies built up against against this
type of thing
um like I imagine a chain email driven
conspiracy theory probably just in terms
of its raw materials has the ability to
be more credible seeming than just
stumbling across the same conspiracy
theory from a website on your own
because it's mediated through someone
who you know and trust right yeah yeah
and I mean it's just like the internet
was new at the time too so it's not just
that you're getting stuff from from
somebody you trust but it's also that
like your understanding is like this is
where I find information that is true
this is where there's like
encyclopedia type information is what I
find on the internet there's not as much
kind of a literacy
um on misinformation as there is now so
it makes sense why this would spread
like it did and why it continued
freaking people out
um and it was kind of the backdrop
of the public discourse going into the
2000s and really kind of like
one of the earliest indications of the
public starting to really freak out
about aspartame
so I'm gonna go back just a little bit
to talk about what the Press coverage
has looked like
okay over the years
um
we're gonna go all the way back to the
80s and then I'm gonna go through each
decade then once we talk about the
actual who report I'll go through
similarly what the Press coverage has
looked like for this most recent news so
how I did this for the historical press
coverage is I just did like a media
content analysis of Articles from The
New York Times that covered aspartame
from 1980 to the present I chose New
York Times because I thought it'd be
relatively representative of media
coverage from like the prestige trusted
sources
and perhaps more importantly I have a
subscription so I didn't have to deal
with paywalls well in I mean it's it's
considered the paper of record and yeah
that's what they call themselves they
themselves their their tagline is all
the News That's fit to print so
uh yeah I mean I I feel like it's
probably a decent barometer for like
kind of kind of like mainstream right
thinking about this stuff especially
from kind of like more
theoretically like credible exactly and
and authoritative sources yeah yeah
so in the 80s after aspartame had been
approved overall we're actually not
seeing anything indicating reasons to
distrust aspartame in the media and
that's kind of like what I was talking
about earlier is like most of the
controversy surrounding aspartame at
first right after the approval was
mostly like legislature legislators and
um like just like Community nutrition
groups like or institutes that just
really kind of latched on to that as the
issue that they cared about but the
longest article about aspartame in the
New York Times was one from July 13 1983
and it really just emphasized the amount
of due diligence that the FDA performed
so it was it looked like it was kind of
trying to reassure people so the writer
said things like the approval of
aspartame as a soft drink additive
culminates a decade-long effort marked
by scientific uncertainty and
controversy over its potential risks and
Extreme Caution on the part of the Food
and Drug Administration
and they also draw attention to the
amount of evidence that was submitted
during the approval process saying
things like after 112 studies and with
aspartame already approved for use in
more than half a dozen other countries
the FDA approved it as a dry food
additive and they also mentioned Canada
and England and how both of those
countries have already deemed
aspartameus safe saying that after
experience in Canada and England helped
to convince the American agency of its
safety and Effectiveness and soft drinks
aspartame will be allowed to enter the
soft drink Market here
they also quote the director of the
Science Center for Science and the
public interest a man called Dr Michael
Jacobson who says Aspartame is quote a
far preferable alternative to saccharine
nice I do I do feel like the existence
of this article does does imply a lot of
like societal trepidation about it
though because like if there wasn't if
that didn't exist this wouldn't be
newsworthy yeah
um like you don't you don't get articles
in the New York Times about every new
food additive that is approved for the
market uh because most people don't even
know that most of them exist much less
have concerns about their safety
yeah that's a good point I wonder like
how much of it was
kind of directed at an individual
consumer
and how much of it was just kind of
explaining like because there had been
there probably had been headlines about
kind of just like the back and forth of
the approval process and this felt like
it was saying like look it's approved
it's safe they did their due diligence
everything is fine yeah and then the
rest of the 80s kind of
um it's it's kind of a similar situation
like there's just it's pretty quiet
um in 1986 later in 1986 and that that
first article
um there's a short article that reports
that some people are claiming to be
allergic to aspartame but the lead seems
to set some context and let people know
that it's a normal thing so like the
very first sentence of the article is
it's almost inevitable that when a new
substance comes into widespread use some
people have adverse reactions to it so
to me that's just kind of like
you know you might be hearing some
things about allergies to aspartame or
like some people having weird responses
but like this is all totally normal yeah
and then for the rest of the decade we
mostly see like run-of-the-mill news
articles
um there's a short article about the FDA
rejecting a petition to ban NutraSweet
there's an article about
um one of the reports that found the FDA
followed proper procedures and approving
the sale of aspartame and it kind of
um emphasizes that the FDA is conducting
adequate follow-up studies to monitor
the safety of aspartame and then there's
an article in 1989 about the patent
expiring that doesn't mention anything
about safety gotcha
yeah that that does like that that feels
very similar to the first article as
well though yeah it's kind of like in
conversation with the conversation
that's occurring it's like if if there's
not trepidation about some of this stuff
like why is this newsworthy because
there's there's a finite amount of space
in a prestigious paper so yeah that's
true yeah
uh the 90s were like completely quiet on
aspartame though
um all all coverage until 99
was just about formulations of different
sodas so the 90s were when sucralose was
introduced and so there were some
articles about like oh is Diet Coke and
every police aspartame with sucralose
like what are the what are the formulas
of the diet soda is going to be now that
this new one is on the market and then
um in 1999 we actually get a mention of
the Markle hoax the email the chain
email that we just talked about and this
article was like
I think one of the very first articles
about internet misinformation uh the
title of it is whales in the Minnesota
River which I guess was another just
like little conspiracy that spread on
the internet in the late 90s about how
people thought there were whales in the
Minnesota River and people were like
traveling hundreds of miles to go see
the whales oh no that's very sweet
but uh in that article
uh back to like the Markle stuff a
librarian from Pennsylvania said A
friend had sent her husband his name's
Ken an article about the health risks of
aspartame and that's that's the Markle
article and uh Ken was diabetic and had
recently suffered a mini stroke and
after reading the article was worried
that the numbness that he was feeling
was being caused by the aspartame and
diet sodas hmm you know I wonder if the
numbness may have been caused by the
stroke I think that's probably what it
was yeah
um yeah you know so so that and then
also the the article about
um
like people claiming allergies yeah
brings another thing to mind and that is
that like a lot of stuff happens that's
just like kind of random
um but I think there's like a natural
human urge to try to have a causal
explanation for everything that happens
to you yeah and so you're
um
there there there's a tendency to just
like attribute
something that happened to something
that has changed
that immediately comes to mind so it's
like yeah like you have a worse allergy
season than normal and like maybe you
recently switched from Coke to Diet Coke
so you're like damn it's the aspartame
doing it to me yeah like especially if
you hear other people talking about that
like it's kind of top of mind you're
looking around for a potential causal
explanation and that's where your brain
goes and
I I think that I
do that all the time yeah
um and it's you know they're just trying
to make meaning out of suffering yeah
yeah uh but yeah I think that that's a
normal like common thing people do and I
think that there's a tendency to be like
way way way overconfident about it yeah
um like for for another food related
thing something that comes to mind is
like people claiming they have some sort
of like uh like bad response to MSG
because they feel bad every time they
eat at a Chinese buffet and it's like
I mean one unless you regularly eat
Chinese buffet food
um there's like 30 uncontrolled
variables here like there's there's a
bunch of just different foods you're
eating that you don't typically eat uh
and two there's another potential
explanation that's just like you don't
feel good when you eat 17 plates of
Chinese food right food with a sweet
sauce yeah like that's maybe it's the
MSG maybe it's just a question of volume
you know
um yeah just as another example of like
how that sort of dynamic can and
frequently does play out like in in the
context of lifting I I see this a lot
too where like
um
like someone just gets some sort of like
minor injury yeah and they're
immediately very very confident that
it's caused by whatever the most recent
tweak they made to their training
program was
um like oh I started training a little
bit heavier or like oh I moved my back
training from like Tuesday to Thursday
or whatever
um like like it could be virtually
anything but it's like this thing
occurred
um this was the most recent change I
made to my program therefore that change
I made to my program is necessarily what
caused the injury yeah
um and yeah like I that's that's a
that's a p people don't like uncertainty
and I think that they have it they want
to jump to like any potential conclusion
confident conclusion versus just like
deal with uncertainty and be like hey
this bad thing happened why did it
happen I don't know yeah
um I think it's like a protective thing
because it's like if if you think you
can identify a cause then you can be
like oh well now I know how to avoid
this in the future like I yeah you you
see how they get there
um but yeah I think I think that there
is just like a tendency to uh like look
around for any potential cause of any
bad thing that ha that happens and
there's like a bit of security you feel
from like clinging to that cause very
confidently because then it gives you
like a sense of control over if I don't
do this thing then this bad thing won't
happen right even if the connection you
made was like complete spurious yeah
yeah
I mean if you go to the doctor they do
the same thing a lot of times too like
if you if you say you you have started
experiencing some
adverse
Health effect or impact they're going to
ask you like well what has changed like
have you have you changed anything in
your diet recently have you changed
anything in your habits
um and I think I don't know if that's
kind of a reflection of how our brains
work naturally or
uh if we learned that from the doctors
but either way
you're right that we certainly do that
I
um yeah I I think that that
looks similar but is often quite
different
um because like when a when a doctor is
doing it they have a
pseudo encyclopedic knowledge of one
based on the symptoms you're describing
what condition you could have yeah and
then two what sorts of things could
could cause those conditions not based
on Vibes but like based on science and
actual yeah I'm definitely not saying
like that doctor shouldn't do it no no
yeah it's just like are we trying to
just like diagnose ourselves right we're
just kind of we've learned how to do it
or think we know how to do it because
we've seen a doctor do it yeah yeah like
I I'm just saying that like for for
actually getting at the truth that is
like a logical place to start yeah or
it's like hey uh something changed
yeah maybe it's just random or maybe
that change was caused by something else
that changed
and so trying to look at the other
things that have changed is like a
logical place to start in that line of
inquiry but it's it's a difference
between like is it a line of inquiry
uh where there are a lot of
possibilities and you try to weed it
down
um or you know you you just have like
enough background knowledge about what
could cause something that like you it
it can help you like prune off a lot of
potentially bad options versus I think
kind of the more informal way of going
about it where it's just like you
experience this thing oh what has
changed let's make a short list and then
just pick one and be like yes that's
that's what caused this negative thing
yeah
um so yeah like it it presents as
similar but it's it's very different
yeah
yeah you're right I mean that it could
be something that we learned from
doctors but I I think it's more just
like a natural human thing yeah yeah
um
okay so just to kind of
summarized where where we've been so far
so in the 80s and 90s like I said
a lot of the actual coverage from The
New York Times we weren't seeing
skepticism in the Articles themselves I
I think you're right that they probably
were reacting to some skepticism either
in the public or just like some of these
more like intellectual groups that had
skepticism of aspartame but I don't know
I wasn't alive yeah if somebody was an
adult in the 80s and they want to tell
me what it was like I'd be interested to
know I don't know how to research that
though
um but in the 2000s this is where the
tide really starts to turn and the topic
of aspartame safety is really brought up
quite a bit in articles and you start
seeing journalists kind of
um gesturing at impropriety or like kind
of
citing sources quoting people who are
directly calling into question aspartame
safety there are about three times as
many articles mentioning aspartame in
the New York Times in the 2000s than
there were in the decades prior oh wow
that could be I don't know exactly how
their digitization
um process went like I don't know if
they have digitized everything that's
been published in the 80s and 90s
um so it could be that there's just not
as many articles that have been
digitized from that decade but in the
2000s they're a lot more like web native
articles being published but either way
it does seem like there are a lot more
articles
um
oh there's a lot more just like general
public interest and aspartame in the
2000s than there have been in decades
prior and a lot of that seems to be due
to a study on rats that was published in
2006 from the European ramazzini
Foundation of oncology and environmental
Sciences so this is the ramazzini study
I see I saw this everywhere in my
research yeah um and I asked you Greg to
look into this a little bit so that you
can explain this study to us before I
then tell you how the media was covering
it so can you go ahead and do that sure
yeah yeah so
um yeah we we've talked a lot about just
kind of like the history of kind of
skepticism around artificial sweeteners
in general but yeah the the ramazzini
studies were what what have probably
been more responsible than anything else
for the specific concerns that people
have about aspartame today yeah
um
so yeah uh so it wasn't just the
ramazzini study there have been I
believe four of them ah I had studies in
my notes and I was like oh I think it's
just one study and I went and changed it
but I was right the first time you
should have kept it
um yeah so they published three studies
in the mid-2000s I think 2005 2006 2007.
okay
um there was a lot of criticism of those
studies so
um they published another study I think
just earlier this year
um pushing back against like primarily
one of the specific criticisms yeah that
people raised they said they like
re-analyzed their data yeah yeah yeah so
um like not not to jump too far ahead
but one of the concerns that people had
with them was that they may have
misidentified some of the cancers that
they reported like essentially like ah
they maybe they just saw kind of like
generally inflamed tissue and just
assume assumed that it was cancer
so they reanalyzed a lot of the like
images and and
um
like procedures used to identify Cancers
and basically he said like ah there are
some other criticisms but the
misidentifying cancers thing like we
think we did a pretty good job about it
yeah
um
and okay so so yeah there have been four
studies okay three kind of like original
studies and then one one re-analysis for
that reason
um
so yeah there's uh a group called The
ramzini Institute based in Italy
um there's also uh something called the
ramazanium or the the ramp the ramazini
collegium that's based in Italy as well
that sounds fancy and I think they share
some membership but they're two separate
organizations confusing and um the the
folks at The ramazzini Institute want to
make sure that everyone knows that uh
but yes so they hate those other people
yes so just on the front end we're
talking Institute not collegium uh but
yeah it's a it's a group based in Italy
and
um they did a series of rodent studies
in the in the mid 2000s
um looking at the effects of aspartame
on cancer rates
and um
essentially they got groups of depending
on the study either rats or mice so some
like I think one study on mice two on
rats or the other way around
um and they gave them supplemental
aspartame primarily in their water
um for their whole lives and in one of
the studies at least they started giving
supplemental aspartame to the mothers of
the rats that they would then be
studying to kind of see if there were
effects on like the fetus or early life
yeah
um
and uh yeah I mean the the tltr is that
uh they found their conclusion was that
aspartame just like just absolutely
[__] these rats up oh no uh rats and
mice so here is a list of all of the
different types of cancer that oh my God
uh aspartame allegedly caused in these
in these lab rodents we got
hepatocellular carcinoma hepatocellular
adenoma bronchio alveolar carcinoma
bronchio alveolar adenoma lymphoblastic
leukemia monocytic leukemia uh
other myeloid tumors malignant
schwannoma mammary gland carcinoma
renal renal pelvis papilloma renal
pelvis and ureter carcinoma renal pelvis
and your and ureter papilloma mammary
gland carcinoma and histocystic sarcoma
oh my God uh so I'm so impressed that
you know how to pronounce those words
um I don't know that I do I well you
sounded confident
the one that I'm most skeptical about is
myeloid I think that's right though also
schwannoma that has to be the Schwann
cells yeah okay it's Gotta Be You know
what I feel I don't know I do feel
reasonably confident about my
pronunciations yeah but yeah if you saw
this list
in a paper or in an article
it looks scary yes
um
so like I said these studies were
published in the mid-2000s uh around the
same time actually slightly before the
national toxicology program which is
associated with one of the U.S federal
agencies maybe Health and Human Services
whatever doesn't matter
um but yeah like it's it's an official
government agency
um they had also done three studies on
uh the effects of aspartame on cancer
risk in mice and
they found that it doesn't increase
cancer rates so
you have
you have six total uh like rodent
studies yeah three of them finding
Aspartame is is
terrifying and three of them finding
like oh no it's it's chill actually
um
and both of these sets of Studies have
been criticized but the criticisms of
the ramzini studies are
uh considerably more substantial let's
say yeah so the the criticisms of the
studies from the the national toxicology
program were essentially that like they
may have just been a little bit
underpowered and like maybe not
sensitive enough to detect effects if
effects were present okay
um which like that's just kind of like
normal stuff I guess
um the criticisms of the ramazzini
studies were much more expansive so
um we're going to talk about the the
World Health Organization report uh
later on but I'm just gonna quote really
quickly from the Lancet article that
that summarized it
um for the ramzini studies the working
group considered the evidence for cancer
and experimental animals to be quote
limited because of questions about
adequacy of the design conduct
interpretation and reporting of each of
the studies damn that's the whole study
though yeah for example the lack of
adjustment for litter effects which may
have led to false positive results for
incidents and Trend yeah like you said
that's everything
I don't know it's almost worse to list
it out like that yeah I can't think of
any other parts of science really
so yeah so
um
in terms of like specific stuff
I will admit I know about human research
uh animal research is a completely
different thing I know the basics I
would not claim to be an expert on any
of this stuff
um like the the litter effects mentioned
here
um
I I read about it it makes a lot of
sense it's not something that would have
immediately come to mind for me as
someone who hasn't done animal research
and doesn't read a ton of animal
research uh but yeah so like that
specific criticism is that when you're
doing rodent research essentially you
use strains of mice that are
you want them to be genetically
identical but they're not like like some
degree of just genetic drift happens but
they're very very genetically similar
um and you use like a whole population
of them for whatever you're testing and
so they're they're going one of the
reasons they they work as a good test
animal
um like these these Mice from very
specific lineages that have very similar
genomes
is that if you're testing something in
humans for instance like a lot of us are
very different in a lot of different
ways yeah and so if you see an effect
maybe it's due to the actual substance
you're testing or maybe it's just due to
like randomization issues where you just
had a one group of people that through
pure sheer chance just intrinsic
characteristics about them we're more
likely to make them have some
deleterious outcome than the other group
of people
using mice
goes a long way towards alleviating that
concern but not entirely so like
different litters of rats or or mice uh
with different parents or potentially
successive litters from the same parents
will be slightly different and even if
you're you're not dealing with issues of
genetic drift over time even if you're
talking about successive livers from the
same uh parent yeah
um
you know the the uterine environment
will just be a little bit different
because hey the mice are a little bit
older now yeah
um or like the conditions in the lab
could be very slightly different for
litter one than litter two yeah so that
could have an effect and dependent of
whatever you're testing so so what
you're supposed to do is you know if
you're using four litters of mice you
kind of take half the litter and put
them in one group you take the other
half of the litters and put them in the
other group so basically in each litter
you you randomize the individual mice or
rats
um and they didn't do that it was
basically just like this litter will get
aspartame this letter won't get
aspartame so like a lot of the
criticisms are kind of along those lines
yeah um never think of that yeah yeah
we're at stuff that like oh like it
makes a lot of sense to me but it
wouldn't immediately come to mind uh so
all of that's to say I'm no I'm no
expert on kind of like the the details
of rodent research yeah um nor am I a
cancer researcher and and a lot of also
true and a lot of the other criticisms
were related to like how they
um how they actually identified tumors
yes where people are saying like ah the
the procedures you used you could have
been saying that some things were tumors
that were actually just kind of like
old and inflamed tissues because they
were old and inflamed so another critic
like another criticism of the ramsini
studies is they were whole life studies
where they would essentially
um like give them aspartame and let them
live a full mice or rat lifetime yeah
and either die of well quote unquote
natural causes most of them died of
cancer but just kind of like yeah go
when nature takes them or uh they would
like kill them very very late like right
before they were about to die
um
and that is apparently not what you want
to do just because like
you know there there's there's [__] that
happens that's attributable to the aging
process
um and when you're talking about
something that lives for a short of a
period of time as a mice or a rat
um when they die they go downhill very
quickly like before they do so there's a
lot of things that like you might
attribute to whatever you're testing
that are actually just that
um
another
another kind of like more substantive
criticism that people have raised of
these studies
is that
there is there was evidence in these
studies but then also other studies that
have come out of the ramzini Institute
that their rodents might just not be
particularly healthy in the first place
oh no so they're in the studies they do
there's like more evidence of chronic
infections affecting the animals than
you see in rodent research from other
labs
um there were like
there were much higher than average
rates of other Cancers and tumors in the
control group than you tend to see in
control groups and other studies
um so yeah like the other people that do
rodent research and know a lot more
about it looked looked at kind of some
of these details and they're just like
this this
just didn't look to them like well
conducted rodent research where the
General conditions of the labs and the
rodents were good enough that you could
confidently attribute the cancer
findings to the aspartame itself yeah
versus just
damn these rodents are in bad shape
they're just sick yeah yeah so
um
anyway there there were other kind of
like more granular criticisms of these
studies but just kind of in in Broad
Strokes that's that's what a lot of it
boils down to
um so yeah you have all of that stuff
with the ramsini studies versus the
studies from the national toxicology uh
project or it's just like eh they they
may have been underpowered which you
know that's uh not as big of a criticism
right
um so yeah that's that's I think what
you need to know about the ramzini
studies
um also another thing to note about them
I guess is that
um
it's so it's not just that criticisms of
them were from maybe like interested
parties potentially people getting money
from the national beverage Council
although there has been yeah um like
there there have been a lot of like
interviews given by folks who had a
vested interest in aspartame staying on
the market and a fair number of studies
that have been published from people uh
getting money from those folks saying
like ah these Ramsey and these studies
are bad
um but also like independent government
agencies have
have also looked at these studies and
been like yeah I know they they suck so
the the efsa which is the European Food
Safety Authority like kind of their
version of the FDA
um independently evaluated these studies
and said like yeah no they there there's
there's not enough meat on the bone here
for us to ban aspartame because like we
don't think your work was good and
reliable
um
so yeah I think I think that's about all
you need to know about them
um the kind of headline findings where
aspartame gives gives mice and rats all
of the cancers and then as people dug
into it they said like ah there's
there's some
there's some things about these studies
that don't quite smell right and some
reasons to suspect that maybe we
shouldn't take that at face value so
most kind of independent scientific
agencies don't take them itself out at
face value yeah yeah
so
none of those
um kind of criticisms or drawbacks of
the studies were really mentioned very
much in the media coverage and the media
response to this to these studies were
pretty seismic
um
probably because uh part of the
ramazzini group's strategy is to like
create a big media response so
um
they held five press conferences and
issued multiple press releases in the 11
months after their 2005 study came out
and this was before
the data had been submitted to any
um actual like Health authorities people
weren't able to like kind of dig into it
themselves but
the researchers were really like
going for the big media response
doing a lot of interviews and there was
a lot of Journalism about it I read an
article from a journal called risk
management called risk communication
media amplification and the aspartame
scare that talked a lot about kind of
the media response to the ramazzini
studies and how they could have done
better in terms of communicating
the findings without like really
freaking people out
of course that's the assumption that
they didn't want to freak people out but
freaking people out might be might be a
profitable business strategy exactly but
something that that journal article
noted is that
um
a lot of the at least the first
ramazzini paper the 2005 one was not
published in a peer-reviewed journal it
was published in there in-house Journal
and
um
yeah so they said journalists do not
generally distinguish between non-peer
review and real peer review although the
aspartame research findings were initial
initially speculative and published in
an in-house Journal they were reported
as more or less state-of-the-art peer
review science the ramazzini study May
thus have received more Credence than
warranted hmm
so they publish it in their own journal
they held like
conferences and like gave themselves
research awards for their research and
then they also were doing like all these
press releases and press conferences and
stuff talking about like how important
this research is and
you know how scary it is and how like it
should kind of be Paradigm shifting
while simultaneously not sharing their
data with the EFC efsa to be for them to
be able to evaluate it to potentially
change recommendations
um just just really quick
I think that it's
I think that it was published in a
peer-reviewed journal maybe not at first
yeah I think that this was during a
period when
um
yeah I think I think they may have just
been kind of like sitting on it yes they
did yeah yeah just just wanted to note
that like I I think the study has been
published now like when I searched the
main author on PubMed
um the the three studies that I had
tabbed in my mind as the the ramzini
studies on rodents from the mid-2000s
um
I I see where they're published and
they're all they're all like real
studies or they're they're all in real
journals right so yeah so this this
quote did say initially published okay
so yeah I did note that gotcha um so
yeah I think it was just like
I mean what it seems like is that they
they held all of their stuff for like a
year before then you know going through
a peer review process submitting their
data for
um the efsa to review
and but simultaneously they're really
kicking up a lot of dirt and getting
people to talk about this and freak out
about this but nothing can really happen
in the scientific Community or like for
regulations because they're really just
sitting on their data yeah yeah which
which then sets up a dynamic of just
like why aren't governmental agencies
taking these results seriously they seem
very scary exactly the governmental
agencies are just like we we can't
[__] do anything man because because
all we have is like what they've told us
right like we we need to see more right
before we exactly like evaluate this
yeah that's exactly what happened
um you know that that reminds me so much
of something that just happened uh that
we all experience for the last
three years or so that being covid and
Science and journalism yeah
revolving around covid yeah
um
James Heathers uh great guy also has a
podcast called everything hurts and if
it hurts like the the measure hurts like
h-e-r-t-z
um it's a fun podcast uh if you really
like really nerdy
um
kind of like research design and
statistics conversations and meta
science and all that fun stuff you
should check it out it's it's a it's a
fun show
um anyway one of one of his big hobby
horses over the last two years or so is
just like
um science by pre-print during the covet
era where if you have something that is
like a huge Public Health crisis where
like Fast action could save lives there
is an argument to be made that like yeah
maybe you don't want to take all the
time for peer review just like pre-print
your stuff uh get it out there whatever
but that's also a system that's very
exploitable by kind of Bad actors and
people who
um
their stuff probably wouldn't pass
muster yeah because like if
a lot of the folks doing good work are
putting their stuff on pre-print servers
and saying like hey like this hasn't
been peer reviewed yet but like you know
me I'm a legitimate scientist like media
Outlets go ahead and report on this like
it could be helpful in safe lives uh you
know governmental agencies who are
making decisions on uh like pandemic
responses here is some new relevant data
that you want to be able to review when
you're when you're making decisions
um when you have that alongside
uh more unscrupulous actors who aren't
doing good stuff but who are operating
via the same channels yeah putting their
stuff on pre-print servers uh putting it
out in the media and then you have like
not so much the governmental agencies
but just uh reporters who struggle to
tell the difference between the two yeah
you have a set of circumstances where a
lot of really bad information can get
disseminated did very quickly while
looking identical to Credible science
yeah
um so yeah he's been he's been writing
about this that General type of dynamic
for the last couple of years and uh
folks should check it out he has I think
a sub stack as well he used to write on
medium
um but if if you just search like James
Heather's articles I'm I'm sure stuff
will come up yeah that sounds really
interesting
um but yeah I mean like what you're what
you're describing here with the with the
ramzini studies like this
it is a a dynamic that can that can has
and does play out in other domains as
well where yeah journalists journalists
aren't researchers and like being able
to like discriminate between like a good
and bad science
is a skill set and it's a it's a hyper
specialized skill so like like I said
before like I I'm a lot more
scientifically literate than most people
um but I I don't
I don't have expertise in rodent studies
yeah like I think there's a a very high
likelihood that if I'm if I knew what I
know now
and the ramsini study was published in
2005 and I I read it not just like
listen to their press conference but
actually read the full text I think
there's a reasonable chance that I as a
journalist would be like oh this is good
[__] like this is scary this is relevant
to the public interest like I need to do
a story about this
um so yeah like this is like
and then when you compound that with the
real world where a lot of journalists
aren't scientists like don't don't have
much training in our own time crunch
like expected to turn out multiple
stories per day and are mostly just
responding to the Press reports exactly
yeah and just trying to like keep up
with whatever your whatever your
competition is doing yeah your editor is
giving you a story because they know
that the other newspaper is going to be
publishing an article on that topic and
you just gotta turn it out and and you
don't want readership thinking that the
folks you're competing against are the
ones that look out for Consumer safety
but you don't because then people might
shift to their subscribe to yeah yeah no
I definitely think the the issues are
much higher up than the journalists
themselves but then they are the people
who are disseminating the information
and that is what causes a lot of the
confusion yeah for sure
so let's talk about what that media
responds to ramazzini look like
specifically in the times the main
article they published was called the
lowdown on sweet and that has a question
mark at the end of it
um and the News angle about that was the
ramzini study but it goes pretty in
depth on the history of aspartame
including the sketchiness of its FDA
approval so I initially found this
article when I was working on the
earlier segment for this episode about
the FDA approval and then found it again
when I was doing this section of it and
like my understanding had kind of
evolved by that time but you can see how
like
in a situation when somebody is trying
to explain the importance of a the
ramzini study results that they're going
to bring up the sketchiness of the FDA
approval as kind of like oh well look at
this maybe this shouldn't have ever been
approved in the first place yeah
um and so it presents a fair bit of
skepticism about the safety of aspartame
and like I was saying earlier like these
articles in the 2000s are kind of the
first ones that you see the journalists
presenting skepticism about the safety
of aspartame rather than just kind of
like it seeming like a response to other
people being skeptical
so the article points out that a lot of
the research that says Aspartame is safe
is funded by groups that have vested
financial interest and it includes a
quote that just straight up says the
results of aspartame studies tend to
depend on who paid for them
just straight up
that quote is is not from the journalist
but it's from um Dr Ralph Walton a
professor of Psychiatry who published an
analysis of 166 aspartame articles and
those articles had been published in
medical journals in a five-year span
from 1980 to 1985 so that's around the
time that the FDA approval was kind of
going back and forth he found that all
74 studies that were financed by the
industry attested to aspartame safety
um so that's kind of what the the quote
about the results tending to depend on
who paid for them come comes from
um but then there's just one line that's
he has an analyze studies performed
since 1985. so you know this is this is
21 years later
um and he also says whenever you have
studies that were not funded by the
industry some sort of problem is
identified saying some problem with
aspartame it's far too much for it to be
a coincidence
um let's let's go a step deeper on this
uh
that that in and of itself is an
interesting source for the times to use
um
so I like I was just curious like hey
let's let's look up this study like see
what they found because the this quote
here
um basically just says that like oh yeah
all of the all of the studies
um that industry had funded attested to
its safety the the quote doesn't include
what percentage of like non-industry
funded studies were safe so so as you
were talking I was just like hey I'm
just going to Google this real quick
yeah let's just see what the other half
of these studies look like
um
here's from here's from Wikipedia uh
Ralph G Walton a psychiatrist at
northeastern Ohio University School of
Medicine stated in a self-published 1996
analysis of aspartame research that
industry-funded studies found no safety
concerns while 84 of 92 independent
studies did identify safety concerns
this analysis by Walton was submitted to
the television show 60 minutes and has
been extensively discussed on the
internet an analysis of Walton's claims
showed that Walton left out at least 50
peer-reviewed safety studies in his
review of the literature and that most
of the research he cites as non-industry
funded were actually letters to the
editor case reports review articles or
book chapters rather than published
articles Jesus um
so yeah it's basically a bunch of
Industry funded actual studies saying
it's safe and a bunch of just letters to
the editor and like not primary research
saying we think it's bad though yeah um
and he's he seems to be treating both of
those things equally yeah which they're
not
um and as far as I can tell this wasn't
actually published in a journal anywhere
he just did it and uh just sold it to 60
minutes and said hey aspartame's scary
do do a do a segment on this and they
did they did do a whole episode on it
yeah so that's not I mean like they're
I'm sure that by the mid-2000s there
were actually like systematic reviews
and stuff which if you did a little bit
of leg work you could look you could
look at the uh the the citation list
um look at funding sources and kind of
like redo that analysis in a kind of
objective way but but bringing a guy on
who won his analysis was a decade old by
this point yep and two it wasn't
actually published anywhere yeah and
three by the time that this article in
the times came out
like Walton's analysis had already been
heavily criticized for like missing at
least 50 studies that should have been
included yeah um that makes me think
that he probably wasn't the best source
for the journalists to lean on yeah and
this is what for the article yeah this
is what drives me crazy that I saw so
often is like
if you don't know these things if you
don't know about the person that a
journalist is citing for a quote and
they just kind of have these like
words that seem impressive you know this
guy's a professor of Psychiatry he
published this analysis of 166 articles
like the average reader is going to see
that and be like oh this is a
trustworthy credible Source who's giving
an unbiased opinion about aspartame but
it's like of course it's not like the
person that is being that is throwing
themself at a journalist to get quoted
in an article they have an opinion they
have a point that they're trying to make
and like this guy doesn't seem like a
credible source to be like
saying things as bold as the results of
aspartame studies tend to depend on who
paid for them in an article in the New
York Times yeah that's
yeah yeah I mean that um
one that's not good too
uh like I mean I I myself as you were
reading that my my first thought wasn't
uh this this guy seems like a crank my
thought was like oh there's another half
of this analysis this journalist is
reporting on the industry funded studies
and all of them seem safe What
proportion of the non-industry funded
studies
made aspartame seem either safe or
dangerous like like I was purely just on
a fact-finding mission I just wanted to
know what does the other half of this
analysis look like
um
but yeah like the way it was presented
it it raised no red flags about this
person himself yeah uh but maybe I
should have been more skeptical because
here here's a here's a tip for both both
you and all of the listeners out there
um there are plenty of good scientists
who are who do great work and they're
they're public intellectuals and they
give quotes to journalism or to
journalists and all of that stuff like
like I don't want to paint with two bro
too broad of a brush here but
if you know the name of a specific
researcher
uh the probability that they're a little
bit sketchy is way way higher because
the thing is most scientists you're
never going to hear their names yeah
because they're in a lab somewhere doing
good [__] research and Publishing it
in journals that no one outside of their
field actually reads and if a journalist
does want to do a story on whatever they
do research on like yeah maybe they'll
give like one quote and then you just
never hear from them ever again
um or much more likely they're [__]
busy because they're a full-time
researcher and they probably also have
like students they're mentoring they
might also have classes they're teaching
someone contacts them for comment they
just say I talked to the university
press office yeah
um so like
yeah folks folks who are giving quotes
to the New York Times and especially
folks who are kind of like
out there in the media a lot yeah
um
there still I I think I think most of
them are still good rather than bad but
that that is a big bit of a red flag
yeah it's a red it's a red flag for sure
like if if you know the name of a like
like 99.9 of researchers are like legit
and they do good work
um but I think that once you start
talking about folks who's who who flirt
more with the media and you're more
likely to know their name I think then
instead of like a 99 thing you're
talking more like a 70 person thing like
the the number of stinkers goes way up
yeah
let me tell you a little bit more about
this article
um it also contains just a fair bit of
fanfare Over The credibility of the
ramazzini cancer lab uh so they say
quote while doctors salfridi I think
that's how you say his name that's like
the lead researcher well his methods
have drawn some criticism which that's
as far as they go in terms of criticism
if I remember correctly nice the ramzini
cancer lab has earned considerable
credibility since it was founded in 1971
for its pioneering research on chemicals
so it's like you know it's drawn some
criticism but
you know they've earned considerable
credibility
and the net result of this article
is to plant many many seeds of doubt
about aspartame safety and the
intentions of the regulatory board and
the scientists who have said it safe
all on the back of this study that
at the time may have not even been
published in a peer-reviewed journal yet
and it's just completely propped up
without criticism yeah uh the sentiment
that the article leaves the reader with
is an ending quotation from Dr Michael
Jacobson who is the same guy I mentioned
um a minute well several minutes ago
from cspi uh yeah yeah
um who said that Aspartame is far
preferable to saccharine in the 80s so
he said and like I said this is this is
the ending quote of the article for a
chemical that is used by hundreds of
millions of people around the world it
should be absolutely safe there should
be no doubt
and that's true technically
but I mean can we ever truly have zero
doubt about something like this like
proving a negative isn't really a thing
yeah no and I don't think the ramsini
paper was strong enough to justify the
kind of doubt that the average reader is
going to walk away from this article
with yeah
no for for sure I mean I I agree with
that wholeheartedly
um yeah that that is not a reasonable
bar to hold anything to
[Music]
um
yeah I'll I'll Circle back when we talk
a little bit about when we talk more
about how aspartame's like new
classification by the World Health
Organization Works
um but but yeah there there are
currently that that statement for a
chemical that is used by hundreds of
millions of people around the world it
should be absolutely safe there should
be no doubt
um nothing reaches that bar yep
um the the ah whatever I'll just go
ahead and do this the the I Arc the
actual arm of the World Health
Organization that has recently
classified aspartame as possibly
carcinogenic
um they used to have
uh
five levels that they could classify
things at
um one two A to B three and four with
one being
uh like
like almost certainly carcinogenic or
very likely carcinogenic or whatever
um and and to be being possibly
carcinogenic like that's where Aspartame
is now uh and then
three is basically just like yeah we
can't say like there's there's not
enough to say either way and then four
used to be probably not carcinogenic so
probably not doesn't mean no doubt yeah
uh it means probably not and uh
the amount of
Safety Research that you need to
establish something as probably not
carcinogenic is such a high bar that
during the entire time that they had
been classifying chemicals like on on
their little rubric only one thing had
ever made it into group four as probably
not carcinogenic
um so they got rid of group four like
they no longer classify things as
probably not carcinogenic because
they're like it's a waste of time to
even have this classification because
like
we've been doing this for like decades
only we only found one thing that was
probably not carcinogenics like [__] it
we're just getting rid of it yeah so
according to folks that like actually
assess
carcinogenicity oh wow that is a word
carcinogenicity carcinogenicity
carcinogenesis yeah uh for the people
who actually assess that and that's what
they do
um to them uh there should be no doubt
is not something that even exists yeah
they never even considered having
something other than probably not
carcinogenic and then after Decades of
experience they decided ah probably not
carcinogenic is still too high of a bar
to clear like we only found one thing
that cleared it's like we're just
getting rid of that because yeah like
like probably not carcinogenic is also
like so difficult to establish that that
it just doesn't apply to hardly anything
so yeah that's that is a wild quote to
leave the reader with
it it gives people a very unrealistic
understanding of
the ability of science to establish
something is like definitely safe like
that's that's that's not a realistic
thing for people to expect yeah
all right I'm gonna try to Breeze
through rest of 2010s
um
in 2009 we get an article in the
personal health section about the use of
artificial sweeteners for appetite and
weight control
uh it includes the following quote
aspartame was charged with causing
headaches and other neurological
problems including seizures and brain
tumors although some consumers may be
sensitive to this sweetener in 25 years
of widespread use no human evidence of a
link to cancer has emerged from
prospective studies of diet and health
so that's good you get we get a little
um
little reality check there
and then in 2009 an article in the
dining section about different types of
artificial sweeteners and which ones
consumers prefer
um there's a line saying the biggest
cloud of Doubt hangs over aspartame
which is the target of vigorous concern
among holistic health practitioners and
many Health bloggers
nice yeah which is like okay like is
that our standard for when we're saying
something is unsafe uh you know what as
a health blogger I sorry I approve of
this uh I definitely think that my my
concerns and opinions should be more
heavily reflected in the New York Times
and so I salute them for this article
okay
2010s
um
in April of 2015 we get a syndicated AP
article published in the time saying
that Pepsi is changing the artificial
sweetener and Diet Pepsi to sucralose
because of quote customer worries about
the safety of aspartame and I just
wanted to mention this briefly because I
think there's kind of an interesting
um little note to make here uh Pepsi
Pepsi removed aspartame from sodas in
2015 which is what this article is about
but then it brought it back a year later
and then there are conflicting reports
they may be removed it again in 2020 I
saw some articles that said that they
did some articles that said that they
did not
um but in another article that I found
from The Washington Post I could easily
get the answer to that question by going
out and buying a Pepsi but who's going
to do that I'm not gonna drink a Pepsi
one of the lowest here soft drinks in
existence I'm not gonna do that to
myself
um but a Washington Post article points
out that um when Pepsi was kind of
making the announcement about changing
the formula they said removing Aspartame
is the number one request we get from
customers but they also acknowledge that
there's no scientific basis for the
formula rework so like
they're kind of giving in to customer
demands here and by doing that
making it seem like there's something
wrong with aspartame because then you
just get the headlines that are you know
Pepsi is removing aspartame
for for custom because customers are
concerned about the health effects or
whatever yeah so companies doing things
like this likely just further confuses
people
um and lends credibility to the
unfounded fears but you know you got to
sell Pepsi yeah I mean ultimately
they're responding to what they expect
to be the most profitable decision yeah
um yeah just the the Dynamics of it do
do look like they're validating those
concerns yeah yeah
um
also in 2015 there's like an opinion
style article published in their section
the upshot and the title of the article
is the evidence supports artificial
sweeteners over sugar the author is a
pediatrician and a professor of
Pediatrics named Aaron E Carroll
um and so the article is about what the
title makes it seem like he's talking
about artificial sweeteners still being
better than sugar so he says the
available evidence points to the fact
that there appears to be a correlation
between sugar consumption and health
problems none can be detected with
artificial sweeteners he points out that
the rat studies are highly contested and
that rats and humans are actually quite
different and he also gives a quick
criticism of a 1996 only study that I
saw
um like talked about in a lot of these
articles which was about brain tumor
rates that freaked a lot of people out
so he says the paper stated that one
brain cancer had become more common from
1975 to 1992 and two that more people
had started consuming aspartame recently
he responded there are any number of
problems with this logic most of the
increase in cancer was in people 70
years and older who are not the main
consumers of aspartame and because
aspartame was approved in 1981 blaming
it for a rise in tumors in the 1970s
seems impossible finally much more
comprehensive studies couldn't find
links these included a case control
study from the Journal of the National
Cancer Institute of children and a
cohort study of more than 450 000 adults
in cancer epidemiology biomarkers and
prevention
so I liked this article a lot but then I
found that pretty soon after it was
published oh no he he had to publish
another article answering questions that
people had sent in response to his
article yeah yeah people were [__]
mad
um I'm I'll link all of these um
articles that I've talked about but this
one is is particularly amusing slash
depressing but I think this one line
sums it up he says I don't think that
letting my children drink diet soda once
in a while makes me a monster but
apparently some of you think it does oh
man so he got [__] roasted God I I
feel for the guy that's that's rough and
also I mean
uh so one as as we record this episode I
am already like bracing for
some of the feedback we're gonna get to
it like my people will have to listen to
it to get feedback and I mean oh no no
no no no you're right you're what am I
thinking people don't listen or read
something before they give feedback well
it's that and also the the people who
get the maddest are going to be the
people who are most likely to get all
the way to the end
um
and yeah so I I am just bracing for what
my inbox is going to look like for a
couple days after we post this episode
yeah which is
like that that's that's a dynamic that
plays out
um
kind of kind of a lot like if if there's
a particular topic where the people who
are who are either on the pro or
anti-side
are particularly vocal and particularly
vitriolic that can have the effect of
kind of like styming public discourse
about it
um because like you know I I imagine
this guy
um like it sounds like he wrote a really
good column about it
um
I wouldn't be surprised if he stopped
talking about aspartame after this it's
just like yeah I'm gonna write this
article yeah I'm gonna do a follow-up to
address some of the concerns people have
which they voiced very quickly the first
article was published the 27th of July
the second one was published the 31st so
like yeah people [__] let him have it
in the first day or two
um it it wouldn't surprise me if he just
looked at that and he's just like you
know what there are plenty of things to
write about
um I think Aspartame is safe and fine
but I'm just not going to write about
this anymore because it's not worth it
and I think a lot of other people like
especially on social media can see what
topics you discuss that get you dogpiled
and just kind of learn like I don't want
to get dogpiled yeah
um
and so
yeah like I I don't know like it's um
like the the safety of aspartame is a
topic where
people who are anti-aspartame and like
anti-artificial sweeteners are very
anti-artificial sweeteners and and it
makes sense that they would be
um like if if you think that it's going
to kill people and give them brain
tumors and all of this [__] like yeah
like you're gonna get worked up about it
if someone says I think this is safe and
fine yeah
um or if you're like me and you have
asked for Splenda on a plane in a flight
attendant has shamed you saying do you
want sugar or do you want cancer oh my
God yeah I've I had forgotten about that
that's crazy
Jesus Christ
um
yeah yeah and then like on the opposite
side of of the topic people like I don't
know that many people who consider
themselves like a pro aspartame like
yeah I like artificial artificially
sweetened beverages but you know like I
I wouldn't say I'm like pro-artificial
sweeteners like I think they're safe and
fine and I enjoy plenty of products that
have them but it's it's not it's not
something I'm gonna get that worked up
about like like when I see people say
artificial sweeteners are dangerous the
thought never occurs to me that like I
should write them a 300 word angry email
to say no [__] you they're fine yeah
they're fine
um like so I I think they're I think
that there are a lot of topics where
just kind of like due to those Dynamics
yeah a a vocal minority can do a lot to
stymie the more popular but more weekly
held position that doesn't radicalize as
many people
um
and yeah I you know what I have plenty
of examples of that in mind and I'm not
even going to bring them up because
people don't want people to say that to
you yeah this this Dynamic exists and uh
you know for all of the examples I would
bring up I I know the vocal minority
would assume that I have the kind of
more mainstream view that they would get
mad about and then they'll [__] get
mad at me and uh just just make my inbox
a [__] for a while and you know one
of these days on some of those topics I
might be like ah you know what I'm I'm
fine I can take the heat but what I'm
already gonna be taking a bunch of heat
for this aspartame episode I don't wanna
I don't want to catch Strays for other
[__] as well that makes sense yeah but
yeah like I do think that this is like a
a pretty common Dynamic where a a
radicalized minority that feels strongly
about something can very easily uh
create the set of conditions that make
the majority that has a much more like
a position they feel much less
emotionally invested in uh not want to
discuss it because they don't want to
pay the price that would come along with
discussing it
hmm
so after that
there's an article
um in 2019 so we're jumping a couple
years ahead here but a 2019 article with
the title death by diet soda question
mark
um so just that title alone
not great not good likely to cost a bit
of panic
um so this article is talking about a
new study that apparently found
consumers or artificially sweetened
drinks were 26 percent more likely to
die prematurely than those who rarely
drank sugar-free beverages so they say
that
um and then they also say this study is
not a one-off so implying that like
this has been found other places and
like you you are gonna die actually if
you drink diet soda like everyone say it
yet yeah
um
and they say the problem experts say is
that these and other Studies have been
unable to resolve a key question does
consuming drinks sweeten with aspartame
or saccharin harm your health
yeah
that's that's that's the problem and
then it ends with the sentiment the
deleterious effects of artificial
sweeteners can't be ruled out so once
again we're getting we're getting that
no doubt thing yeah yeah that that is
the same sentiment of like there should
be no doubt that it's completely safe
but yeah that that's that's not a bar
anything can can be held to
and I mean I guess another thing that
some of these some of these articles
like the the one the one that you liked
from uh from aaroni Carroll brought up
is that like there's there's a question
of like
compared to what I guess where
um in like even if you're someone who
does think that like ah there there
might be something wrong with aspartame
like it may be it may be not the best
um you know there's the question of like
what's the alternative and if it's like
sugar sweetened beverages instead
uh the
negative effects of excess sugar
consumption
are
much more handily established yeah and
so it's like why
why are you going to get up in arms
about something that may potentially
have some negative effects although
that's controversial and like yeah we
see some associations but it's hard to
find a causal link
uh when the alternative is something
that is like much more like obviously
deleterious where the evidence
supporting its harms is like much more
robust
um I mean like the the third option is
just like don't drink anything that's
sweet which like honestly probably is
the best option but like yeah people
like their sweet fizzy drinks yeah and
so of those two like artificially
sweetened or sugar sweetened
you know we we know one is bad and then
people have concerns that the other
might be bad as well but it's like
it's kind of like bird in the hand is
worth two in the bush like like you you
avoid the known and established harm
I would think
yeah I mean I I know we'll talk about
like the naturalistic fallacy later but
it really feels like it's just that like
it's like well people have been eating
sugar for years
um and
they're not getting
crazy brain tumors from it whereas with
aspartame drug who knows yeah and I feel
like that just kind of
can you prove that they don't give you
crazy yeah YouTubers that's just like
the default and people don't kind of dig
into that any further yeah
yeah
all right in the 2020s
we have an article in 2021 that's a
first person narrative about the
author's quote addiction to Diet Coke
which apparently a lot of people think
that they're addicted to aspartame I
didn't get into this in my research here
because it's there's a whole nother
rabbit hole but
um this article included a bunch of
anecdotes about health issues that folks
attributed to drinking diet coke and
included this line which made me
uncomfortable previous Studies have
linked diet sodas to strokes and
dementia diabetes and metabolic syndrome
and tooth decay as well as abdominal
cramps diarrhea hallucinations headaches
joint pain and nausea hmm the the word
that's doing a lot of heavy lifting
there is linked
uh
because
that almost always means
an observational study has found an
association
um which like in the case of uh
um
in the case of tooth decay like I buy it
because a lot of tooth decay is just
about like acidity yeah and most
artificially sweetened beverages are
somewhat acidic so like I I buy that
there might be a causal a causal link
with tooth decay
um but like a lot of the rest are just
like
they were probably mere associations
um and the the diabetes and metabolic
syndrome in there in particular
um
brings up I think one of the go-to
examples of like inverse causation that
a lot of especially like sciencey
fitnessy people talk about which is like
the association between
um diet soda consumption and obesity
which is that like a larger proportion
of individuals with obesity consume diet
soda than people in the general
population or people with a BMI like
below 30 right
um
and a lot of scaremongering would say
like oh well that's because it causes
obesity but it's it's no like that's not
what it is
um and like they're
you you can get that in studies where
there's like a Time based component
where it's like when people switch what
they consume how does that affect their
weight trajectory
um but just on a much more basic level
it's like folks gain weight and then
they decide they want to lose weight and
so then they switch from sugar sweetened
beverages to diet beverages
um and so yeah like like
for a lot of these like I suspect that's
what's going on and especially the
diabetes and metabolic syndrome it's
like you you have issues with regulating
your blood glucose so your doctor says
stop eating and drinking as much sugar
yeah and so you do and you switch to
diet beverages yeah and then that shows
up in some epidemiological study and
then some [__] [__] says oh and
and now now aspartame has been linked to
diabetes and metabolic syndrome yeah you
know yeah um the thing that I don't like
about sentences like this is it I mean
it really seems so similar to like the
Markle hoax like the email conspiracy
like it's just listing all of these
things that you're scared of and the the
thing that you're going to walk away
from is like damn Aspartame is going to
cause all of these issues or like if
aspartame can cause all of this stuff
like chances are one of these things
will happen to me if I assume aspartame
yeah that's a that's a really good point
even if you are more skeptical it's just
like hey we got a list of a dozen things
here right one of those some of them are
a mere associations uh yeah at least one
or two of them have to be causal right
yeah
okay and then in uh May of this year so
we're we're caught up the New York Times
publishes an article that reports um the
continued consumption of non-nutritive
sweeteners doesn't reduce weight and
could increase the risk of type 2
diabetes cardiovascular diseases and
mortality in adults and I think this was
kind of the first
section of the who reports this didn't
get as much attention as the possibly
carcinogenic but that was reporting on
kind of the first wave of this
um
I I think I think it was separate I
think it was like a separate arm of the
World Health Organization and that it's
I saw it mentioned in a lot of the
articles
uh about the the most recent reports
yeah so I don't have a New York Times
subscription
um can you just like send me
uh do they do they link to the the World
Health Organization report in in the
actual article
um yes I can send this to you though
because I can gift it to you cool
hell yeah I like being gifted news
articles yeah so in in your nine left in
in your next segment I'll just skim it
really quick because yeah it could just
be that the World Health Organization
just said let's do a general sweep of
aspartame and see what's up with it
um I I think that I think that it was a
separate thing though because I I
remember
um when this report came out and I don't
think that it related to irk or jeffka
at all okay I kind of think just like
some other like organization within the
World Health Organization was also
looking at aspartame kind of
independently
I think a lot of the reporting on this
was basically like the takeaway was that
there's not any benefit to consuming
diet soda versus just regular full sugar
soda
yeah I mean I think
I think that's true for the most part
um
so yeah yeah okay this is this is the
report that came out I I don't think
that this was related to
um the the current I Arc report
um
but it could have been who knows uh but
yeah like
I do think the the World Health
Organization report
that this news article was talking about
that was
um
where that quote came from continued
assumption consumption of non-nutritive
sweeteners doesn't reduce weight and
could increase risk of type 2 diabetes
like I think the
could could increase risk of type 2
diabetes cardiovascular disease and
mortality in adults part I think that
they were maybe a little a little bit
too far out over their skis there but
this was also if memory serves
um
one of the parts of the World Health
Organization that kind of
is responsible for making
recommendations that are
kind of relevant to Public Health advice
and
so like the the most recent
meta-analysis on artificial sweeteners
and their effects on on weight and BMI
and obesity and all of that
um a meta-analysis of rcts if memory
serves
I know that we've talked about it on the
podcast previously if folks want to go
back through the archives or if not
maybe we did a research Spotlight on it
whatever but yeah the most recent meta
on it that actually looked at like
interventions where like some folks are
given artificially sweetened beverages
others are given full sugar soda and
some are given water like they did all
of those comparisons tends to find that
certainly compared to Sugar sweetened
beverages uh
consuming artificially sweetened
beverages tends to have uh a negative
effect on weight trajectory like you're
you either gain less weight or lose more
weight
um and if memory serves there was even a
small effect compared to water like
people consuming artificially sweetened
beverages either gained a little less
weight or lost a little more weight Than
People consuming water instead but in
all cases the effect sizes were very
very small yeah and so if you're
generating Public Health advice it's
just like hey uh we we perceive there to
be an obesity epidemic and we're looking
for interventions to recommend that are
going to like right move the needle
considerably and like the evidence on
artificial sweeteners
does indicate that like ah maybe they'll
help you lose a little bit of weight or
slow down your rate of weight gain but
like the effect isn't
isn't large enough to like meaningfully
change those trajectories like in a big
way long term
um
and so yeah if if memory serves for this
particular World Health Organization
report like that's that's basically what
it came down to it's just like hey when
we look at this stuff we're not seeing
evidence that it is going to like
dramatically reduce rates of obesity or
like probability of weight gain which
like does comport with the research
really well
um and I think people interpreted that
instead as it does nothing or will make
you gain weight yeah which is not an
accurate interpretation
anyway sorry for derailing us a little
bit that's okay
um I think before we move on completely
from what the media landscape looked
like leading up to
the these new reports
um we should briefly touch on the
nutrient Sante study which was published
last year and this is kind of one of the
main studies that I saw cited in a lot
of the Articles talking about the new
reports so that's why I think it's
important to talk about a little bit
here so Greg if you could give us a
brief overview
yeah so until this recent round of news
coverage in the last month
um this study was the the last big thing
coming out of the scientific community
that put aspartame uh in in the mouths
and on the fingers of journalists and
got a lot of people talking yeah so like
you said it was published last year uh
the title of the paper
was artificial sweeteners and cancer
risks colon results from the nutrient
Sante population-based cohort study
um was published in uh plus medicine
Public Library of science medicine
um and it's an Open Access Journal it's
an Open Access paper you can check it
out for yourself if you would like
um but yeah I mean it was a
observational cohort study which means
that they had a a group of adults uh
approximately a hundred thousand of them
and between 2009 and 2021 basically from
time to time the researchers would hit
up the participants and be like hey uh
write down everything that you ate in
the last 24 hours like the their method
of uh ascertaining intake data was
24-hour dietary recall records
um or just 24-hour dietary records and
um
the median follow-up was eight years so
the study took place over a 13-year
period but then the median time that
each individual subject was involved in
the study was about eight years and
um so yeah they they looked at what
people were eating kind of on random
days at a time over about an eight year
period And they also compared that
against those those folks medical
records
um like this was this so okay
just to back up a little bit more okay
this was not a St like this was a
individual paper on aspartame but this
is a more extensive like longitudinal
cohort study yeah where they're
collecting data on these folks
um
for yeah like like eight to ten years
and it's a lot of [__] so it's like
health records how like how you're
exercising like employment status uh do
you smoke do you drink
um if you exercise what kind how much uh
like like all of that stuff nice so
essentially it's just one of those
things where
they started analyzing their data and
they realized like hey there are some
there are some associations between
aspartame and cancer but it wasn't like
they were just looking at artificial
sweetener intake and cancer it was
basically just like an expansive series
of snapshots about these people's lives
for this period and just then on the
back end they're going to be able to
look to see like what sorts of General
associations exist there like so the the
nutranet Sante cohort
um anticip just anticipate to see a lot
more research published from this over
time because
uh yeah it like it wasn't just like
looking at us at uh aspartame or
artificial sweeteners
um like they're uh uh popular or like a
a big example of this in the US is like
there's something called the nurses
health study that started I think in the
70s or 80s and I think it's still
running where it's basically exactly
that
um they just had a group of I think like
30 40 000 nurses and it's just like
we're going to follow you and collect
all of the data about you that you're
willing to give us for the next like 30
or 40 years like until all of you die
and then and then we can use that to
kind of like see what sorts of behaviors
or risks are associated with with
different outcomes
um so yeah like that that's the research
approach uh taken here
and um
so yeah just to just to talk about the
results yeah they stratified people by
artificial sweetener intake where most
of the people in the cohort
um like
I think close to 70 consumed no
artificial sweeteners uh or at least
there weren't any products with
artificial sweeteners in them that were
included in any of their dietary records
in in the database
um and then of
of the other approximately 30 of people
they just split them into low consumers
and high consumers of artificial
sweeteners and they looked at cancer
rates and um so
compared to non-consumers
um consumers of artificial sweeteners in
general and aspartame and esulfame
potassium in particular
did have higher rates of cancer than the
non-consumers did
um
so they found that association with
cancer generally breast cancer and
obesity related cancers they also looked
at prostate cancer but didn't really
find associations there
um
but yeah so and the the magnitude of the
like different rates of of cancer
incidents were like in the 10 to 20
range so they weren't finding that
people who consumed artificial
sweeteners had three times the the
cancer risk of people that didn't but
yeah so like kind of moderate
differences in around the 10 to 20
percent range depending on the sweetener
they looked at the specific type of
cancer High consumers versus low
consumers uh Etc just so you have a
general lay of the land and I'll note
like I don't have anything bad to say
about this the study itself
um this seems to be a very high quality
population cohort study
um they collected data on most of the
easily collectible variables that you
could collect data on that might
influence cancer risk uh in their
statistical analysis they adjusted for
all of the appropriate covariates that
you would would want them to adjust for
and they also did plenty of sensitivity
analyzes to make sure their results were
robust they reported all of those
clearly there's a very very extensive
supplemental material section that you
can download and look at all of those uh
like secondary analyzes yourself to see
all of the stuff that they kind of like
prodded around with which like there
there are two different reasons you
might want to kind of like prod around
in your data one is to try to find
spurious associations to find just like
false positives to report on yeah and
the other is if you're like pre-planned
analysis does find significant stuff you
want to poke around on that to see if
it's robust
um to like avoid false positives and
this is like the second good good type
of prodding your data
um so yeah like the the study was was as
far as I can tell very very well done
um but there are still reasons to be
skeptical of the results themselves
and like in I think that's like a common
disconnect like oftentimes good studies
can still get like dodgy results yeah
especially in in epidemiological work
um
so like I I do I do have skepticism of
the results of the study but I just
wanted to say like I it is not owing to
the fact that I think the study was
poorly done or poorly analyzed right
um so yeah the the biggest issue and
like my my biggest calls for skepticism
is that there was a general lack of a
dose response relationship so most
things that that actually like cause
cancer
tend to have a positive dose response
relationship and it's it's the the basic
principle of like uh exposure increasing
risk so if uh so I I hope everyone
listening to this can agree that like
smoking cigarettes
causes or at least like massively
increases your risk of lung cancer but
if you smoke one cigarette
ever in your life
is that going to increase your lung
cancer risk
theoretically probably but like to Ace
to such an imperceptibly small degree
yeah that for all intents and purposes
no it doesn't right but if you smoke a
pack a day for a decade is your risk of
lung cancer a lot higher yes absolutely
so typically in things that actually are
like causally related to cancer you tend
to see that that positive dose response
relationship where increased exposure
increases risk and that is not what we
see in this study so the the
non-consumers obviously consumed no
aspartame uh the low consumers consumed
an average of 3.24 milligrams per day
which is like almost nothing yeah like I
think there's like 30 milligrams in a
Diet Coke so like 3.24 milligrams per
day like that's [__] incidental it's
like maybe you had one cough drop yeah
um
and then the higher consumers uh
consumed an average of close to 50
milligrams per day which also still
isn't that much aspartame but it's like
more than 10 times as much as the low
consumers and so
you're seeing a if if aspartame caused
cancer you would be looking at a large
difference in exposure like 10 times
more exposure for the high consumers and
the low consumers so if it was a causal
relationship you would expect to see an
increase in risk with increased
consumption
um but you don't really like in terms of
raw numbers
the high consumers actually had lower
cancer rates than the low consumers did
so
um
like yeah like 3.1 percent of the
non-consumers got cancer at some point
in the study about 3.9 percent of the
low consumers got cancer and about 3.3
percent of the high consumers got cancer
so just in terms of like raw numbers the
high consumers had lower cancer rates
than the low consumers did which is the
opposite of that positive dose response
relationship
um and then they reported two sets of
analyzes they they had a minimally
adjusted model and a fully adjusted
model and that's basically just a
question of like how many covariates you
put in there like how many things you
account for that might also influence
cancer risk and basically in the fully
adjusted model you did see a a positive
relationship between aspartame
consumption and cancer risk but like
it was it was like a 12 higher risk than
the non-consumers in the low consumers
and a 15 higher risk in the high
consumers and so we're talking about a
three percent difference in folks
consuming 10 like more than 10 times
more aspartame and then in the minimally
adjusted model you see kind of like that
that reverse relationship again where
the the low consumers had uh 21 higher
risk versus 18 percent higher in the
high consumers so like basically the the
raw numbers indicate like definitely not
a positive dose response relationship as
you add more variables into the model if
there is a sort of dose response
relationship here it's very weak like
you're seeing a very minimal increase in
risk with a relatively large difference
in exposure
um and that's
for all intents and purposes like we're
not seeing a dose response relationship
here which
is not what you tend to see for for
things that are actually causal
um
and then the second and like this this
is again not a criticism of the
researchers here
um this this would apply to any single
observational study uh you don't want to
put that many eggs in the basket of a
single art of a single observational
study like the the quote it's a it's
just a single study criticism applies to
just about any paper in just about any
field
um but it especially applies when you're
dealing with epidemiological studies so
in 2013 there was a fun paper titled is
everything we eat associated with cancer
a systematic cookbook review
um and what the authors of this study
did was basically just look at the most
common ingredients in cookbooks and then
just search them in PubMed uh with like
cancer appended to it yeah
um to just see like
what research has been published on each
of these individual foods and their
association with cancer rates
um just to kind of illustrate how much
uh estimates can vary between studies
even for the same ingredient so for
instance
um I think probably the the one of the
wildest ones here or like one of the
ones with the biggest spread is coffee
where
um there were one two three four uh
close to ten studies done on coffee with
the the most extremely positive one
finding that coffee intake decreased
cancer risk by more than 50 percent and
the most negative one uh indicating that
coffee intake like roughly tripled
cancer risk
um
for onions uh the most extremely
positive study found that they decreased
cancer rates by like close to 90 percent
and the most negative study found that
they roughly tripled cancer risk like
like basically oh my gosh basically this
[__] is incredibly noisy yeah where a
single food multiple research groups can
can look at it like in a nutritional
epidemiology study all do good work and
just due to like random chance basically
um just find very very different
estimates
and the the same article uh noted that
like when you have multiple studies uh
and can meta-analyze them those
estimates tend to not be as like
drastically varying as individual
studies but yeah basically like through
just a a variety of different effects
individual studies can have effect
estimates that can differ enormously
from the true effect
um that is true for most types of
research and that is especially true for
these types of observational studies
looking at cancer risk
um so yeah even even if the dose
response thing like even if that
criticism wasn't present it's basically
just you don't want to freak out too
much about any single study that says Ah
X Y and Z was linked to cancer because
like
the study yeah very well may have found
that whatever was linked to cancer but
how much stock do you want to put in
that not much because another study
could come out next year finding that
like oh no it actually doesn't increase
risk it decreases risk and there very
well could be nothing wrong with either
of those studies it's just that like
this is a type of research that is
inherently very noisy yeah and so you
don't want to put too much Credence in
in any single study yeah
yeah no problem so what what did the
news have to say about it yeah there are
a couple that I that I really think did
a great job including the Reuters
article that broke the news about the I
Arc report so
um I'm just kind of looking through this
now again after you just explain stuff
and I like that they say people who
consumed larger amounts of artificial
sweeteners including aspartame had a
slightly higher cancer risk but then
they say it could not prove that
aspartame caused the increased cancer
risk however I think that's a very fair
assessment
um The Guardian Australia also published
an opinion piece by an epidemiologist
that kind of broke it down
um
and this was also an article that was
published in response to the I Arc
report and just kind of adding stuff
about the nutrient Sante for context but
um they tried to put some of those
numbers in terms of the increase for
cancer risk into perspective and so he
says going from having absolutely no
aspartame to drinking a can of Coke Zero
a day for a decade would raise your risk
of cancer from 3.1 percent to 3.3
percent he knows that that risk is
Meaningful at a population level of
course but says for individuals the risk
from aspartame really isn't something
that is likely to impact your life so I
think that that's really good context
but looking at these numbers now aren't
those like
it's it's leaving out the the low
consumer number that was actually higher
um so like this this is great that he
writes this but there's actually even
like a wrinkle further that you just
explained about it being 3.1 and then
3.9 for low consumers and then 3.3 again
for high consumers and I mean like that
that is those were the raw numbers like
I I I I don't fault him for doing this
I'm just saying like I do think it's
interesting like even the worst case
saying you're you go from 3.1 to 3.3
which is like not a straight line yeah
yeah
um
yeah I mean another thing I didn't even
mention is just that like
the association with low consumers like
almost
strains credulity
because like
3.24 milligrams of of aspartame is a
hideously small amount of aspartame like
and that was associated with a 12
increase in cancer risk like that's
if if that if that were a causal
relationship yeah if 3.24 milligrams of
aspartame caused your risk of cancer to
increase by 12 percent it would be one
of the most toxic substances on the
planet like it's like that that like I
said that's um
that's almost nothing so like yeah
between between that fact the like
the fact that the dose response
relationship just just isn't there like
right yeah like the the lack of dose
response relationship I think is
something that probably should should
have been noted but that
um I suspect most journalists wouldn't
know to look for
and then just to kind of highlight the
difference in like what number you
decide there is a medical news today
article
um that was titled artificial sweeteners
linked with a 13 higher risk of cancer
which like you had that number in your
notes like you mentioned that but
stripped of context that sounds way
scarier than it actually is the old
classic relative versus absolute risk
yeah yeah that'll that'll come back to
bite you
Greg we are all caught up on the history
and the environment that these who
reports landed in finally all right so
it's it's finally time to actually talk
about the subject of this episode
all right let's let's get into it so
earlier this week I Arc which stands for
the international Agency for research on
cancer uh published a report uh
suggesting that they believe that
Aspartame is a possible carcinogen or
they they're classifying it as a
possible carcinogen
um and we are going to discuss that
report but before doing so I want to
First lay out the case for why
just our Baseline assumption should be
that Aspartame is probably not
carcinogenic or if it is it would not be
more carcinogenic than just any other
food or thing you consume uh and so that
broadly relates to just biological
plausibility
um it's it sounds like a scary chemical
but it is actually like what your body
produces when you digest Aspartame is
just normal [__] that is in everybody's
diet so aspartame the the name of it it
sounds like it's going to be some sort
of like big scary chemical some sort of
like weird structure some weird [__]
going on with it but it's actually very
very simple so it's it's a dipeptide
it's two amino acids bonded together the
same types of amino acids found in all
of the protein of all of the foods you
eat and those amino acids are
phenylalanine and aspartate and there is
also an additional methyl group bonded
to this to the phenylalanine that when
Aspartame is digested it kind of splits
off it links up with a hydroxyl group
and it becomes methanol
um
so let's let's just briefly talk about
those things first so phenylalanine
completely normal amino acid you consume
plenty of it in your diet
um
based on kind of the normal protein
intakes that people consume and the
typical amino acid profiles of the foods
providing those proteins uh folks with a
normal level of protein intake about 80
grams per day consume about three three
and a half Milli or three three and a
half grams of phenylalanine per day if
you're listening to this and you're like
a bodybuilder strength athlete fitnessy
person aiming for much higher protein
intakes than that you might be consuming
six seven eight grams of phenylalanine a
day aspartate same type of deal it's
another totally normal amino acid that
folks consume in their diets and
reasonably High quantities just as a
constituent of protein so folks
consuming normal protein intakes get in
about six seven grams of aspartate per
day again if you're a fitnessy person
you're eating a lot of protein you might
be consuming like 12 15 maybe 20 grams
of aspartate a day so those are just
completely normal parts of the human
diet
and then methanol like that is that is
uh some methanol is generated from the
methyl group that is split off of the
phenylalanine
and methanol itself can definitely be
dangerous
um so I I mentioned this before when we
were talking about adulterants
approximately five hours ago where
um it's it's structurally very similar
to ethanol but uh an ethanol itself is
toxic but methanol is way more toxic it
can kill you in much lower quantities
than ethanol can
um
lower intakes than that can cause
blindness like it'll it'll uh just like
deteriorate or Optic your optic nerve
it's it's it's nasty stuff if consumed
in adequate quantities but the the human
diet does contain just like some normal
amount of ethanol so I found a study
that looked at
um just like food intake in the German
and Turkish diet and uh or
um like just just grabbed a bunch of
foods off the shelf in Germany and also
Turkey
um and just lab tested them for methanol
content
and
[Music]
um
looking at those foods which were like
kind of Representative of what people
might eat in a day the like rough amount
of methanol one would be expected to
consume in those foods and kind of like
a normal amount of calories was about
like 127 milligrams of methanol per day
give or take and that's not including
alcoholic beverages so like alcoholic
beverages also have a little methanol in
them because when you're fermenting
stuff you're trying to produce mostly
ethanol and especially if you're
distilling you try to get rid of most of
the methanol but like ah stuff's in
solution a little bit of methanol gets
in so not not counting alcoholic
beverages some somewhere around like 100
150 milligrams per day of methanol is
like a normal intake of methanol but
that's actually not where most methanol
in your body comes from so as you're
digesting food
there's gonna be other stuff that just
has methyl groups attached to it that
are also split off and become methanol
as you're digesting it
um
and also certain like soluble fibers
when they make it to your large
intestine and they're fermented and
broken down by the bacteria in your gut
they'll release some methanol from that
as well
and so in total
um it seems like the normal human amount
of methanol produced in the body is
about a gram a day about a thousand
milligrams
mostly from like the fermentation of the
fruits and vegetables you eat nice so
yeah about a gram of methanol per day
about a thousand milligrams is just kind
of like the normal
uh like endogenous production of
methanol and then you add another 100
150 milligrams from just other Foods you
consume and maybe another 100 150
milligrams from alcoholic beverages if
you consume alcohol so like somewhere in
the range of like half a gram to like
one and a half grams of methanol per day
like that's that seems to be roughly the
the normal methanol intake slash
production in the human body
so
if you consumed the maximum amount of
aspartame
that the current guidelines allow for
which is 40 milligrams per kilogram of
aspartame
how much of each one of those products
would you end up consuming and actually
absorbing from the aspartame
um what it turns out to be is about 1.68
grams of phenylalanine about 1.36 grams
of aspartate and about 163 milligrams of
methanol so that is you know less than
half of the phenylalanine that most
people just typically consume in a
normal diet
less than a quarter of the amount of
aspartate that you would consume from
like protein sources and approximately
the same amount of methanol that you
would get in a normal diet as well in a
much much smaller amount of methanol
than your body produces itself just from
digesting fruits and vegetables yeah so
like basically if aspartate or if
Aspartame is carcinogenic uh just the
human diet is carcinogenic because
because when aspartame enters your body
like before it actually enters any of
your cells enters your bloodstream
anything like that it it is broken down
entirely to phenylalanine aspartate
methanol yeah and so the the degree to
which it is carcinogenic is constrained
by by the degree to which those three
things are carcinogenic right and the
amount that you would get from aspartame
if you consumed 40 milligrams per
kilogram which again is the the maximum
allowable amount
um
is less than than what you get just from
the other foods you eat and
um
also like that that was using the 40
milligrams per kilogram as kind of the
point of comparison
which I should have
Lindsay can you just Google really quick
like roughly how many soft drinks the
maximum amount of aspartame corresponds
to I think it's I think it's like 20
like 20 diet sodas or something like
it's it's kind of a lot but uh the
typical uh aspartame consumption in
aspartame consumers is only about a
tenth of the maximum allowable amount
it's about four milligrams per kilogram
give or take
um so the the breakdown products of that
would be like 16 milligrams of methanol
which is nothing about 136 milligrams of
aspartate which is nothing and about 168
milligrams of phenylalanine which is
once again nothing
um like that is uh five percent of the
normal intake of phenylalanine about two
percent of the normal intake of
aspartate and only about 1.6 percent as
much methanol as your body produces
every day anyways
um do you have that number yeah so this
says an adult weighing 70 kilograms or
154 pounds would have to drink nine to
14 cans okay of um aspartame containing
soda yeah okay so yeah that's that's
kind of a lot it's yeah it's a lot yeah
so even even at the maximum aspartame
consumption you're you're still dealing
with less phenylalanine aspartate and
methanol than people consume in a normal
diet
um
and of those three like really methanol
is the only one that's scary in
isolation yeah
um I saw something that said that orange
juice has like twice as much methanol as
like a can of Diet Coke yeah yeah so
fruit juices have kind of a lot of
methanol in them like again not enough
to be scared of like not like I'm not
scared of orange juice but uh part of a
balanced breakfast tomato juice is I
think the commonly the somewhat commonly
consumed product commonly consumed on a
plane if you are over 60. yeah or like
is a hangover cure type of deal like I I
know yeah
who like to have some tomato juice in
the morning I've never had tomato juice
it's
not terrible that's what a ringing
that's all I can say
um you know some of the some of the V8s
that are like like half tomato juice
yeah you got some like apple juice yeah
yeah hell yeah V8 splash is not bad it's
really good I drink that a con as a kid
well anyways tomato juice has uh like a
six times greater methanol concentration
than what you would derive from
aspartame from diet sodas so yeah uh
basically just just when we consider
biological plausibility of like should
we expect this thing to be carcinogenic
we shouldn't expect it to be more
carcinogenic than any other protein
because the amount of the two amino
acids it's composed of we consume higher
amounts of those every day come
comfortably more and methanol it's it's
a dose makes the poison type of deal if
you consume like kind of a lot of
methanol it'll [__] your [__] up but the
amount of methanol that you would derive
from aspartame consumption
even at the maximum Amounts is less than
what you would consume in a normal diet
and with typical uh aspartame intake
you're looking at you're looking at like
basically none uh like 16 milligrams of
methanol that is nothing so
just kind of on the front end we should
not anticipate that Aspartame is
particularly carcinogenic or again if it
is it shouldn't be more carcinogenic
than just food writ large because when
you absorb it you are absorbing normal
food products yeah
um okay so let's let's talk about uh the
I Arc report itself so first we need to
talk a little bit about their
classification system
so um
uh Aspartame is being classified as a
group 2B substance which means that it
is possibly car or possibly carcinogenic
to humans so what does that actually
mean so it's based on irk's methodology
and uh the two things you need to know
about uh about that methodology are what
iarc is actually assessing and what the
2B classification actually means
so what iarc is actually assessing is
the possibility or probability that
something is a hazard not necessarily
something is a risk and that is a very
important distinction and one that is
not particularly intuitive to people
so an easy way to think about it is a
hazard is something that can do
something bad and a risk is the
potential outcome of the hazard given
appropriate circumstances and levels of
exposure so that also might sound kind
of like word salad so let's let's just
give a little example
all right so
uh traffic the the the mere existence of
traffic presents a hazard for death due
to getting run over by a truck okay I
think we can all agree agree that that
is true if trucks weren't whizzing down
the road a truck couldn't kill you by
running you over so it's a mere
existence is the hazard it is yeah so
what is your risk of getting run over by
a truck
well it depends on a lot of things uh
how do you behave in traffic do you look
both ways before you cross the road or
do you play a kickball game in traffic
with with your friends every day
um every day do you uh consistently use
pedestrian crosswalks or do you uh
jaywalk constantly uh do you live in a
place with a lot of drivers or drivers
that are driving fast enough to
potentially kill you if you got struck
or do you live in a city where traffic
is very slow or uh away from
civilization where there's not any
traffic in the first place like those
are all relevant questions when
assessing risk no matter how you
answered any of those questions the
hazard is the same a truck can kill you
if it runs you over and it's driving
fast enough but how much risk that
presents to you is very contextually
dependent
and so what the I Arc report what IRC
does is it assesses hazards yeah it is
basically asking
can something potentially cause cancer
is it potentially carcinogenic it is
fundamentally not assessing risk that is
not what it does
um
so a hazard tells you that something
might present a risk but it doesn't tell
you the circumstances that allow the
risk to manifest and it doesn't tell you
what the magnitude of the risk is like
that's that's an a very important thing
to understand
um and next the classification system is
based on the likelihood that something
is a hazard
which is very different than the degree
of risk so it's basically an assessment
of the strength of the evidence that
something can cause cancer not the
probability that something will cause
cancer for you
um so basically if you have really
really really good scientific evidence
that something
does definitely cause cancer but it only
causes cancer
two percent of the time but the evidence
is is strong enough to detect that
minuscule effect it would be classified
as a group one substance like a
substance that is carcinogenic to humans
uh versus like it very well could be
that something is extremely carcinogenic
but the evidence on it is really weak
and it might be classified as a group
three substance like ah like it like 50
years down the line we will know that
this gives you cancer but the strength
of the evidence currently is just
insufficient to classify it as such yeah
um
so yeah uh there there were previously
five classifications as I mentioned
previously one to a uh three and four
four uh was the one that was this agent
is probably not carcinogenic in humans
uh but like I mentioned over over
Decades of doing this research they had
only identified one group for substance
which was something called caprolactum
which is apparently a chemical that's
used for manufacturing synthetic fibers
in particular nylon
um so yeah caprolactum uh doesn't give
probably doesn't give you cancer all
right I was concerned yes uh everything
else they've looked at it was put in one
of the other four groups yeah
um so yeah in in 20 in 2020 they just
scrapped group four altogether they're
like we we set a group if it only has
one thing in it right they're like we so
rarely find that something probably
doesn't cause cancer that like ah just
[__] it we're getting riddle group four
so now they're uh there are only four
groups which are one two a two B and
three did they move that other thing
into another group or is it just it just
doesn't have a group I think it's just
just saying hanging out with every other
substance yeah we'll call it like group
four Emeritus
yeah yeah it was once in group four
yeah I think it's just not classified
yeah that makes sense
um
so yeah group one is the agent is
carcinogenic in humans and so to get in
group one a substance either needs uh it
most of the time you need strong
evidence that something causes cancer in
humans
um less often a substance can be
classified in group one if there's
strong evidence that it causes cancer in
animals if there's a weaker evidence in
humans but there's also like strong
mechanistic evidence that the substance
acts through directly carcinogenic
mechanisms in humans so like if if
something has just hit the product or it
has just hit the shelves two years ago
or whatever and like maybe it causes
cancer but it's going to take 10 years
to actually cause cancer in humans but
we know it causes cancer in animals we
know exactly how it causes cancer in
animals and you can do research on
humans to see like oh like
mechanistically it's doing the same
stuff in humans yeah you can be pretty
damn confident that it causes humans so
like that that's kind of the secondary
way that something can get in group one
makes sense but for the most part
something is labeled as carcinogenic in
humans if there's sufficient direct
evidence in humans
uh group 2A
um that is the agent is probably
carcinogenic in humans
so most of the time if something's put
in group a
that means that there's strong evidence
in animals but there's weaker evidence
in humans so for example you might have
rcts and animals showing that something
does cause cancer but in humans you
might just have some limited
epidemiological evidence so it's like
yeah like this this does look like it
probably causes cancer but like we can't
be
super confident about it yet in humans
um less often something can be put into
a if there's strong evidence in animals
uh strong evidence that it acts through
a similar carcinogenic mechanism in
humans but no direct evidence in humans
um but yeah most of the time it's just
like strong evidence in animals weaker
evidence in humans like that's 2A
2B this is where Aspartame is being
classified right that is the agent is
possibly carcinogenic in humans
and
basically group 2B is The Dumping Ground
for uh any substance where there's any
evidence that it's carcinogenic in any
Sub in in any circumstances yeah
um so yeah if there's uh quote limited
evidence of Carson carcinogenicity in
humans and quote less than sufficient
evidence and experimental animals uh
that's usually how something winds up
into a which like those are those are
two very guarded statements
um if there is inadequate evidence in
humans but sufficient evidence and
experimental animals but not direct
evidence that it works through similar
personage carcinogenic means in humans
yeah I'm I'm just throwing myself it's a
hard word I don't want to say it
carcinogenic and carcinogenicity okay I
got that's a tongue twist the the fact
that you you say the middle syllable is
different like that's the thing that's
really that's really [__] me up
um but yeah uh occasionally something
can be placed in group 2B if there's
inadequate evidence in humans less than
sufficient evidence in animals but there
is uh supporting evidence of
carcinogenicity from mechanistic and
other relevant data so like basically we
we know that it does cancer like things
in a Petri dish but like do we have good
evidence in anything that's actually
alive not really like that's another way
something can wind up in 2B
um and finally if there is strong
evidence purely from like mechanistic
data but there's no evidence at all in
any living things uh something could
still be put in group 2B like if you
expose a cell to it and like it it
switches on like certain oncogenes or
whatever causes like DNA damage in a way
that would tend to predispose something
to cancer it's like ah it's it's
possibly car
carcinogenic like yeah
um but yeah like the the possibly there
allows you to cast a very wide yeah it
feels like there's so many subgroups in
there yeah like to end it saying
strong evidence from mechanistic and
other relevant data that's just like it
could be like you said petri dish and
then for that to also be limited
evidence in humans in less than
sufficient evidence and experimental
animals like for those to both be in the
same group yeah is kind of wild that
feels like extremely different right
yeah like like substances can get in
group 2B for a wide variety of different
reasons yeah like I said it's just kind
of The Dumping Ground that like if
something is potentially cart
carcinogenic I keep wanting to say the
go with the pronunciation of like
carcino
God damn it I'm just confusing myself
now we've been recording for so long
um but yeah if there's like any any like
inkling of evidence that something might
be carcinogenic in humans it's it's in
2B and then group three is like the true
Dumping Ground round
um so that is the agent is not
classifiable as to its carcinogenicity
in humans
um and so yeah basically like if
there's just like not good evidence on
something period
um it just winds up in in group three so
some ways that something could wind up
in group three the evidence is
inadequate in humans and inadequate or
limited and experimental animals uh so
like
you don't have good evidence in humans
you don't have good evidence in animals
but like there's there's an inkling uh
like uh it's it's hard to say like
um yeah there's there's nothing that
would make anyone particularly nervous
but we also can't really rule it out
um
or if something has inadequate evidence
in humans but sufficient evidence and
experimental animals which would
typically be enough for 2B yeah but
there is strong evidence that the
mechanism of carcinogenicity and
experimental animals doesn't operate in
humans something could be in group three
so that's kind of like the sacrament
thing
um where it does it yeah it causes
cancer in animals but the way it causes
cancer in animals isn't relevant to
humans
um like that that sort of thing
could land something in group three so
uh yeah like those those are the groups
um and group four used to be probably
not carcinogenic in humans but as of
2020 get rid of it group four no longer
exists
um so yeah those those are the groups
and now I would just like to give some
illustrations of things that are in
these different groups yeah so uh group
three I'm not even gonna try because
there seems like it'd just be literally
everything yeah so let's just start with
group 2B possibly car carcinogenic
um so this is where we have our
aspartame yes okay this is now where
Aspartame is other things in group 2p
are ginkgo biloba extract which is
something that's used in a lot of Health
supplements for for cognitive function
uh kava which is also used in a lot of
Health supplements for purported
anti-anxiety effects uh low frequency
magnetic fields including those
generated by cell phones uh progestins
which you would find in hormonal
contraceptives
um radio frequency Fields uh oh wait
those are those are the ones generated
by cell phones the low frequency
magnetic fields other other type of deal
okay um but yeah low frequency or
um
yeah low frequency or radio frequency
magnetic fields like in cell phones
safaril which is uh the major scent or
flavor compound and Sassafras but it's
also found in cinnamon nutmeg black
pepper and basil and fun fact is also a
precursor you can use to synthesize MDMA
uh AKA Molly it is a group 2B substance
aloe vera extract uh engine exhaust
which like yeah I can see that one yeah
just assume that engine exhaust is great
for you uh Asian style pickled
vegetables and uh occupational exposures
associated with carpentry dry cleaning
and being a firefighter and finally this
is my favorite one putting talcum-based
baby powder on your perineum AKA your
Gooch is possibly carcinogenic
um okay
I don't know how they determine that but
uh yeah whatever I'm thinking and it it
wasn't
talcum-based baby powder in general
which which now that I think about it I
do think that I saw some articles about
just talcum powder potentially being
carcinogenic or yeah we're doing
something bad I remember some folks Sue
Johnson and Johnson a couple years ago I
forget the details but anyway on on the
list itself it's like the application of
talcum-based powders to the perineum
okay uh which is very fun
group
2A now we have probably carcinogenic
um so this is allegedly a fitness
podcast so we're gonna lead off with a
heavy hitter which is anabolic steroids
probably carcinogenic
uh nitrates and nitrites like for for
curing Foods yeah
um emissions from high temperature
frying red meat uh just period uh and
hot mate which is a traditional South
American herbal beverage
night shift work which uh
that's not great for me sometimes
um and this is probably my favorite one
in group 2A hot beverages above 65
degrees Celsius or 149 Fahrenheit so if
you like particularly hot coffee in the
morning can you break it to you yes
coffee is going to be hotter than that
and not mine well you are a freak I like
room temperature coffee that is the best
coffee temperature disgusting uh let's
get into group one so uh uh what was the
exact wording for that again uh group
one the the agent is carcinogenic in
humans like strong evidence that is that
it is carcinogenic number one the
Epstein-Barr virus
um which is what causes mono but also
like 95 percent of people have it most
people are exposed during infancy uh and
then it just kind of like stays dormant
for most of the rest of your life spooky
um anyway yeah 95 percent of us have it
and it is carcinogenic
[Music]
um
acetaldehyde is carcinogenic which that
might not mean much to you but that is
what your body produces when you
metabolize ethanol AKA normal ass
alcohol
and guess what else is carcinogenic
that's right ethanol itself will also uh
well
does also have carcinogenic activity
nice
um arsenic which seems bad yeah it's a
it's a poison but also kind of going
back to the dose makes the poison type
of deal
um there's Arsenic and like a lot of
foods you eat like there's a little bit
in leafy vegetables a little bit in rice
a little bit in apples grape Seafoods a
bunch of other [__]
um but that it is carcinogenic which
again like kind of going into the hazard
versus risk distinction yeah arsenic is
a hazard arsenic uh in the amounts
present in rice doesn't really present a
risk uh nice nice example thank you
silica which is the primary constituent
in sand go into the beach that gives you
cancer
ah don't say that it's like eating sand
or just like being around it
I mean uh also Hazard it's a hazard
Hazard doesn't uh consider a mode of
ingestion or type of exposure I gotta
know oh so the silica itself just this
is carcinogenic sand
um so yeah just just be careful when you
go to the beach just watch out for the
sand yeah uh also while you're at the
beach watch out for the sun UV rays oh
man carcinogenic in humans uh diesel
exhaust which like okay yeah I buy that
but also if you live around people you
probably inhale some diesel exhaust
every day
um estrogen uh either in Combined oral
contraceptives or in menopausal or
post-menopausal estrogen therapy that is
carcinogenic uh processed meat
Chinese style salted fish
soot and this is the one that hurt my
soul the most with dust
and so some of my some of my most
positive childhood memories were going
down in the basement when my dad was in
his little workshop and he was using
using his table saw and sawing wood and
building stuff and the the they're just
huffing wood dust I mean basically like
the the scent of wood beans I think it's
objectively nice but it's I just have
such I have so many strong positive
associations with it but
it's going to give me cancer
um
but yeah so like
I I think slash hope that just these
lists themselves should do a pretty good
job of illustrating the distinction
between Hazard and risk so even even if
stuff in group one the worst of them all
things that are carcinogenic in humans
like UV rays
um if you're if you're a jackass and you
spend a bunch of time outdoors in direct
sunlight without sunscreen and just get
like sunburns all the time like yeah
you're probably gonna like there's a
pretty good chance you're gonna get
cancer from that but just like going
outside sometimes like is that going to
give you skin cancer no probably not
um
you know uh like processed meat
you know if you um if you if you have a
diet that's heavily based on processed
meat yeah there's a there's a decent
chance that's going to give you like
stomach cancer colon cancer if you have
uh
if you have like a little bit of
charcuterie once a month like it's
[__] fine you know
um
so yeah uh just arsenic uh in any
quantity carcinogenic in humans like
that like most fruits and vegetables
have a little bit of arsenic in it and
eating fruits and vegetables is not
going to give you cancer so
um
so yeah just that that should just give
you a better idea of what sorts of
things are on this are on this list and
in each category
so the the basic takeaway uh is that in
IR classification means something very
specific uh it is just about Hazard
um but oftentimes like press sources and
folks in the general population are
pretty likely to misinterpret it
um it does tell you about potential
hazards but it doesn't tell you anything
about risk plenty of things in even in
group one are known hazards that present
you personally with very very lit very
very little risk especially in
moderation
um so that's just something to keep in
mind as we move forward here so now
let's talk a little bit about uh the
evidence that the decision and
classification is based on so why was
aspartame uh put put amongst the 2B
substances
and unfortunately I can't go into all of
the details because the full monograph
isn't published yet which which annoys
me a little bit like they um yeah we
wanted to make this episode 12 hours
long uh I mean no it's not just I mean
maybe kind of I don't know a bunch of
sick [__] listen to this podcast to
like really long episodes and I'll just
say this dear listener if you are still
listening yes I'm talking about you
right now
um
oh
God I'm kind of losing it uh
but yeah but yeah so
um it seems like there there's a time
lag for when they publish their
monographs versus when they announce
their decisions which which does annoy
me because I kind of feel like if you're
gonna be saying hey aspartame which a
lot like a shitload of people consume is
possibly carcinogenic
you should probably make available to
the public the full reasoning for that
yeah um but yeah they act like it's not
for a public consumption in any way even
though they have to know that like well
no these articles are going to be
published even if it's just for other
scientists like yeah is it is it to
build hype are they trying to get a hype
train going
um they're teasing us yeah but but the
um
the I Arc monograph that will go through
like all of their evidence and all of
their reasoning for this classification
will be irk monograph number 134 and
when I checked on the website they've
only published up to 131 currently so
they're like three issues behind
embarrassing so whatever whatever [__]
they said was maybe or possibly or
definitely carcinogenic in issues 132
and 130. those also aren't published
um so there there's at least a bit of a
time lag on these uh but the uh the
summary of their decision and their
reasoning for their decision uh was
published day of in Lancet oncology and
that summary is available for free to
anyone who wants to read it but and this
was weird you have to log in uh that's
not a model I'd seen before generally
either stuff is just fully paywalled uh
where you either need a university uh
access or you need the paper article or
it's just completely open access but
this was kind of like
I don't know like a like a social media
platform almost yeah we're like I've
seen some Publications start to do that
like news Publications yeah they're just
gonna start sending you pitches to sign
up maybe I don't know but anyway you so
you you need to create a free account
with the Lancet oncology but that's good
to know though you can't you can't
access it for free yeah if you're
willing to provide your email right so
if if you hit the page and you think
it's paywalled it's not actually
paywalled but you do need to create an
account
um so yeah the uh basically it was
classified as a 2A substance because at
all three levels they identified limited
evidence so limited evidence for a
specific type of cancer in humans
limited evidence from animal studies and
limited evidence of a mechanistic link
to carcinogenicity
um
so let's start by very briefly talking
about the animal studies because I've
already talked about the animal studies
um they primarily were considering the
ramazzini studies and the national
toxicology program studies
[Music]
um
so yeah they they basically said like ah
look the the ramzini studies like they
have these like pretty serious drawbacks
um but the national toxicology program
studies were probably not adequately
powered to be sensitive enough to detect
things if an effect was there so they
they rated that as limited evidence of
carcinogenicity in animals
for humans
um
there were three studies that they were
drawing upon in particular
um and they were they were also
primarily looking at a particular type
of liver cancer
um so like I I uh
kind of assumed that they'd be looking
at the nutranet Sante study and that
that was going to be part of the reason
for their classification but they they
viewed like base as far as human
evidence goes they rated it as like
insufficient for basically all cancer
types including these specific cancers
that uh the nutrientsante study looked
at that just like breast and prostate
yeah
um but they did find three studies in
particular on a particular type of liver
cancer called hepatocellular carcinoma
um so that is the specific type of
cancer that they said that there was
enough human research on to provide
limited evidence with all other cancer
types are being insufficient evidence
um
so I'll just uh briefly briefly read
from the report here about
um about the human studies and liver
cancer the working group identified
three studies comprising four
prospective cohorts that assess the
association of artificially sweetened
beverage consumption with liver cancer
risk these included a large cohort study
conducted with 10 European countries
that assessed the association of
artificially sweetened beverages with
incidents of hepatocellular cellular
carcinoma
a second study pooling data from two
large U.S cohorts that investigated the
association between artificially
sweetened beverage consumption and liver
cancer incidents by diabetes status and
another large U.S prospective cohort
study that evaluated the association
between artificially sweetened Beverages
and liver cancer mortality
among all three studies positive
associations between artificially
sweetened beverage consumption and
cancer incidence or mortality were
reported in the overall study population
or in relevant subgroups all three
studies were of high quality and
controlled for many potential
confounders however the working group
concluded that chance bias or
confounding could not be ruled out with
reasonable confidence in this set of
studies thus the evidence for cancer in
humans was deemed limited for
hepatocellular carcinoma and inadequate
for other cancer types
so
uh uh a couple things to note about that
first is that this is I think worth
taking very seriously because
hepatocellular carcinoma is a very
serious cancer like cancers exist along
a spectrum
um you know it's it's always worth worth
treating cancers with respect but like
some of them have a 90 plus percent
survival rate some of them have like a
90 plus percent mortality rate yeah and
hepatocellular carcinoma is definitely
on the very scary side of things so it's
it's five year survival rate is below 20
percent
um so this is definitely a specific type
of cancer that uh yeah is is worth
taking very seriously
but it's also a very rare cancer
um so in in one of the studies that they
referred to uh the lead author was
stepian there were about half a million
participants in the study and a total of
191 cases of hepatocellular carcinoma
with a mean with a median follow-up of
11.4 years
so that means that 0.04 percent of the
subjects in their study got
hepatocellular carcinoma over the 11
years that the study took place
um and the study reported a six percent
increase in risk of hepatocellular
carcinoma among the people consuming
artificially sweetened soda
so a six percent increase in Risk takes
you from 0.04 percent to
0.042 percent
um
and a like if you consumed uh like 10
artificially like like 10 servings of
artificially sweetened beverages that
would get you up to
0.064
so we're talking about very very small
uh absolute risks here so like basically
in people consuming no artificially
sweetened beverages it's like a one in
2500 risk of this and uh like if if we
were to assume that it was a causal
relationship yeah consuming like 10
servings per week would take you up to a
one in 1500 risk so we're talking about
something that's very very rare yeah
um
so yeah
and there were also some some
significant confounders in these studies
one is that as with most observational
research they're dealing with
self-reported data
um and also Mutual associations
so uh for example major risk factors of
hepatocellular carcinoma include
metabolic syndrome obesity type 2
diabetes and non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease
and as mentioned previously like people
with metabolic syndrome obesity and type
2 diabetes
are more likely to consume artificially
sweetened beverages yeah not because the
artificially sweetened beverages calls
to those things right but because they
have those things they switched from
sugar sweetened beverages to
artificially sweetened beverages
um so the the associations observe there
could just be inverse Association where
the people who consumed artificially
sweetened beverages were also just more
likely to have metabolic syndrome or
type 2 diabetes and it was the metabolic
syndrome or type 2 diabetes that was
actually increasing their risk of
hepatocellular carcinoma
um
let's see
as further evidence of that uh like one
of in one of the studies like that
Association was only seen in diabetics
in the first place and like interesting
I don't think it's that crazy to assume
that people with like worse managed
diabetes probably consume more
artificial like are like more heavily
avoid sugar yeah
um
and then in one of the other Studies by
McCullough the associations between
sugar sweet and beverage consumption uh
artificially sweetened beverage
consumption and most cancers went away
after adjusting for BMI uh though one
association with pancreatic cancer
remained although that wasn't the type
of cancer that they were specifically
interested in in this report so that
that's like further evidence for inverse
causation basically like artificially
sweetened beverage consumption was
associated with BMI BMI may have been
like closer to a causal factor for
actually developing those cancers right
so then when you control for BMI and
like remove that from the equation it
didn't look like artificially sweetened
beverage consumption itself was still
associated with with cancer rates
um
so yeah like that's
that's kind of the lay of the land of of
the human research
um and
even just like in general I think that
I think that what we might be looking at
is
um like like for for the things that do
still find associations after adjusting
for Relic for Relevant covariates like
like the nutranet Sante study I talked
about previously
um I think we might be looking at a case
of something called residual confounding
and uh
so basically what that is
is when you have something that is
associated with a bunch of other [__]
that is associated with a particular
negative outcome but you don't have data
on all of the other [__] once you
account for the stuff that you do have
data on the thing that is still only
merely associated with everything will
still look like it is independently
related to the bad thing that you're
worried about
um
and I realized that might sound like a
bunch of word salad but let's
I'm going to give an example that might
still sound like word salad but will be
like a little bit more explicit okay so
um let's just say that uh liver cancer
is is caused by exactly two things that
being activity levels and obesity status
like like that's not true but like we're
we're using a simplified uh uh
illustration so you know it's not just
associated with but it is caused by
those two things and if you know the
product of those two things for an
individual you can you can perfectly
predict their liver cancer risk
um
and
let's assume that artificially sweetened
beverage consumption is associated with
obesity status obesity status is
negatively associated with activity
levels and therefore there's a negative
association as well between artificially
artificially sweetened beverage
consumption and activity levels
and let's say you're doing a study and
you're looking to see if there is an
association between artificially
sweetened beverage consumption and liver
cancer rates
and so you have data on liver cancer
artificially sweetened beverage
consumption and subject bmis but you
don't have data on their activity levels
okay so first you might just look at
associations with with the raw data like
just artificially sweetened beverage
consumption and liver cancer rates and
you might find that in that just like
completely naive like two variable model
artificially sweetened beverage
consumption is associated with a 10
increase in liver cancer risk
but then you also have BMI and you you
think that that's causally related so
you say I'm going to put this in my
model as a covariate we're going to
account for BMI status
and then when you include that in your
model you might find that artificially
sweetened beverage consumption is now
only associated with a five percent
increase in liver cancer risk
and if that's all of the data you have
that's where you'd leave it you'd say we
see this Association even after
controlling for this relevant covariate
but
if it's also causally related to
activity and you don't have activity
data to also include in your model
it still looks like that associ that
Association exists for artificially
sweetened beverages when it would go
away if you could include activity data
like in this example if you could
include both BMI status and activity
levels as covariates there would no
longer be any association between
artificially sweetened beverage
consumption and liver cancer
I hope that kind of made sense like it's
it's much easier to to
illustrate visually but yeah so that
that's essentially what what residual
confounding is like in that example the
residual confounder is just the fact
that you don't have data on activity
levels and the fact that all of the
variables of Interest artificially
sweetened beverage consumption activity
levels and uh BMI status are all
mutually associated
when you have a situation like that you
are always vulnerable to residual
confounding
um because you simply don't have data on
everything all the time
um and so yeah like I think that's sort
of what's going on here so like by and
large like a lot of people switch from
sugar sweetened beverages to
artificially sweetened beverages because
they develop obesity or metabolic
syndrome or type 2 diabetes yeah
um but the development of things like
obesity and type 2 diabetes uh are
associated with or caused by a number of
other behaviors or lifestyle factors or
even genetic factors that are generally
associated with or causal of cancer risk
um but in in an epidemiology study
you'll have data on a lot of those
behaviors and lifestyle factors but not
all of them so when you appropriately
adjust for all of the relevant factors
that you do have data on there are still
hidden residual confounders that you
don't have data on and can't account for
and so it's still very very common and
likely that you'll wind up with spurious
associations right and so since
I mean since like obesity and type 2
diabetes are
related to a lot of behaviors that
increase cancer risk
they themselves also kind of like
causally increase risks of various
cancers through a variety of mechanisms
and
all of that stuff ends up being
associated with artificially sweetened
beverage consumption
I think that's kind of the dynamic in
play where like most of the time if you
did an observational study on like the
association between artificially
sweetened beverage consumption and
cancer like you'll probably find a
positive Association and I
like even even if none existed purely
due to residual confounding
and so yeah I I think that's what's
going on here
um and I'll there I I have a good paper
on just the the principle of residual
confounding that I'll that I'll link in
the show notes for anyone who wants to
get into this further
um but it's like it's it's kind of hard
to wrap your head around but it's a very
important concept to be familiar with if
you read epidemiology studies
um and it's it's one of those things
that is rarely mentioned in studies yeah
or if it's mentioned it's just kind of
like a passing mention in the limitation
sections like oh this may be affected by
residual confounding but like but
they're like we can't get into that here
well well why the [__] would you get
into it because you're writing to other
epidemiologists who know about residual
confounding so like yeah why why write a
long paragraph about something that that
your presumed readership is already very
comfortable with
um but then when that when people who
aren't epidemiologists yeah pull up that
paper they'll be like yeah residual
confounding what's that or it won't even
be mentioned in the first place and so
like yeah like like this is a dynamic
that you definitely need to keep in mind
all the time when you are are reading
epidemiology research that like most
non-scientists just wouldn't be aware of
um and that is that is why mechanisms
are so important because like residual
confounding can make just about anything
look like it's associated with cancer or
any number of deleterious outcomes uh
like like that uh that 2013 paper I
talked about before which is which
showed that like oh hey every food is
associated with cancer risk yeah um
like
you you can find associations with just
about anything which is why mechanisms
are so important
um like if you
see an association and there is also a
direct
mechanistic link as well then you have
pretty decent evidence that like oh okay
this this may not just be a mere
Association it might actually be causal
whereas if it is just a mere Association
or if it is just an association without
good evidence of mechanisms there's a
decent chance that you're just dealing
with residual confounding or some other
[__] along those lines
um so let's talk about evidence of
carcinogenicity because that was the
last thing
limited evidence in animals humans and
limited evidence of direct
carcinogenicity
so um
yeah to to talk about this and this will
be quick I need to briefly talk about
like what causes cancer in the first
place
um and I mean very briefly because
getting into it is one way above my pay
grade and two would take like hours or
days
um but just very briefly there are by
and large three kind of broad categories
of things that cause cancer one is uh
things that directly damage DNA so
uh you you accumulate mutations in your
DNA and like some of them are going to
predispose you to developing cancer so
like that's why that's why UV rays are
carcinogenic they cause DNA damage most
of that damage is just like kind of
benign but when you have
thousands of little errors uh
accumulating over years and years and
years
um some of them will be bad and you wind
up with like melanoma
um so that's one of the things that
causes cancer
um another
is things that directly affect the
expression of genes that either cause
cancer or suppress the development of
cancer
so
um yeah like like cancer cells are are
weird little guys in a variety of
different ways
um like they I mean it's uh if you've
watched The Matrix like agent Smith's
speech of like humans or like a cancer
like is
kind of related to this yeah um but yeah
like like most of the time your cells
aren't kind of autonomous they don't
have their own their their own ways to
like preserve their own life
um like they they aren't by and large in
control of their own blood supply their
own supply of nutrients stuff like that
um and they're also not fully in control
of Their Own Death like there are genes
that if activated will like tell the
cell to basically commit suicide or if
it gets damaged in a particular way
they're like
um little things that will be activated
to like tag the cell to to tell your own
immune cells like hey this cell is
damaged like you should you should kill
it now
um and so for a cancer to start uh and
like really get going like a lot of the
stuff that happens is just like changes
in gene expression that get it to like
send out signals to say hey let's let's
make some more capillaries so I can
provide myself with blood or uh like
blood and nutrients or changes to the
genes that would like program it for
cell death
um so it becomes like a functionally
Immortal it it basically it or uh like
changes to genes that would otherwise
like
um cause it to put the little proteins
on its membrane that would like tell
white blood cells like hey come kill me
now uh so yeah like certain genes either
need to get turned on or turned off for
tumors to form and so some things that
cause cancer directly affect the
expression of those genes like either
turn on genes that are kind of a step
down the road towards cancer or turn off
genes that would like be associated with
like program cell death or whatever
so yeah things that directly damage DNA
things that directly influence
expression of those genes
or things that like
like do stuff to cause big changes and
sell turnover so this this is like the
sacrament stuff with bladder cancer and
rats yeah uh because basically the more
time your cells have to replicate the
more like you you every time your your
DNA replicates because one cell is
splitting into another
um there is a risk that there might be
small little transcription errors in the
DNA and the more times your cells have
to replicate the more of those little
errors will occur over time so so this
is very similar to the first one of like
direct damage to DNA like things could
could damage the DNA itself but just
kind of like thousands and thousands and
thousands of cellular replications also
in a way damage your DNA just due to
those little transcription errors that
accumulate
um so yeah those are in I could
certainly make like a much longer list
of things that cause cancer but like
most of the causes kind of fall under
one of those three umbrellas
um
and so yeah
going back to aspartame there's not
really
there's not really good evidence for
those direct mechanisms of
carcinogenicity it doesn't seem to cause
DNA damage and it doesn't seem to affect
the expression of those genes that kind
of lead you down the road or lead a cell
down the road to becoming cancerous
um
however uh in some animal studies high
doses of aspartame have been noted to
increase inflammatory biomarkers which
is generally going to cause increases in
cell turnover
um which and so that's kind of like that
third potential mechanism
um but yeah so that that's what they've
got as far as mechanisms go so it's
again they termed it as limited evidence
because there's not much of it
uh so yeah that's that's
basically it
um you now know what a 2B classification
means and you now know the evidence on
aspartame supporting that 2B
classification
um basically it's a measure of Hazard
not risk it's the the grouping is based
on the strength of the evidence not the
amount of risk uh to be means
um
there's a possibility and the
possibility for Aspartame is associated
with very limited evidence across the
board uh on a human level animal level
and mechanistic level so that's
that is what the decision is based on
and that's what the decision means
um and then the next question is does
that mean you should actually stop
consuming aspartame or change your
intake habits and another arm of the
World Health Organization jekfa which
stands for joint expert committee on
food additives their answer was no so
they've released a report uh in
conjunction with and on the same day as
the I Arc report
um basically just reiterating their
prior recommendation of saying hey up to
40 milligrams per kilogram is still fine
like we're not changing our
recommendation on the basis of this
classification
um and like that that is what you should
pay attention to more than the IR
classification because jackfa like their
mandate is to actually make
recommendations based on weighing risk
and dosage not just Discerning whether
something is a hazard
um so yeah they they looked at the same
evidence as I Arc and I Arc said this is
a possible carcinogen and jefa said we
believe you and also you're not really
showing us
uh evidence of greater risk than we
assumed there was already so are we
changing our recommendations no
absolutely not 40 milligrams per
kilogram is still fine uh probably don't
go over that but
not because there's clear evidence that
bad things happen when you go over that
but just like we don't really know what
happens when you go higher than that so
yeah just just keep a cap at 40
milligrams per kilogram and and you
should be okay so the actual
recommendations for how much you could
consume also from the World Health
Organization have not changed yeah and I
feel like that hasn't gotten nearly the
degree of
press and just no hype because the I Arc
report and like the the decision and
what they were going to say was leaked a
month ago and then you know the actual
report didn't come out till July 14th
and that's when the jackfo report came
out and
you know people don't understand which
very understandably like what the
difference between these two uh groups
is like that I Arc is just for
assessing Hazard and it's mainly for
scientists to see and then do additional
research and jackfa is the one that
actual it's more like public facing yeah
it's the one that actual like consumers
should pay attention to in terms of
recommendations but that's just gotten
completely lost and caused a lot of
confusion I think well which one makes a
better headline uh yeah Aspartame is a
possible carcinogen or World Health
Organization doesn't change its
aspartame recommendations
um because those are the two things that
happened yep one is going to generate
more clicks yes definitely so yeah we
can get into the media coverage now
let's do it so since I used the New York
Times as my representative media Source
earlier we can start by talking about
how they covered this and then I have a
couple other news organizations that I
just wanted to point out and go through
like a couple other ways that people uh
covered this story but we'll start with
the New York Times so their article was
Aspartame is a possible cause of cancer
in humans a who agency says and then the
print versions headline was aspartame
could cause cancer hell yeah which I
mean
yeah that's pretty rough it's shorter
I'm sure because they needed it to be
shorter to fit in the space that they
had in the in the layout for the print
version but
that's that could be scary yeah um and
I'll just say like if I read this
article cold not as the freak that I am
who spent like 12 to 14 hours reading
about aspartame over the last week I'd
come away from this article pretty
pretty spooked by aspartame pretty
convinced so they they here's a quote
from the article the irf said it based
its conclusion that aspartame was a
possible carcinogen on evidence from
studies that linked consumption of
artificially sweetened beverages to an
increase in cases of liver cancer at
levels far below a dozen cans a day so
kind of up to this point if you had been
reading the coverage of aspartame
and kind of trying to maintain like a
reasonable position on it you might say
like oh yeah I think aspartame probably
has a chance of causing cancer but only
if you drink like a ton of cans of Diet
Coke per day or something like that so
starting off this article just by saying
like
linked to cancer
at levels far below a dozen cans a day
then it starts to kind of like
freak out just like you know your normal
consumer yeah who's like oh I drink a
can of coke with my lunch every day like
is that me like am I going to get liver
cancer and there's very little about the
different levels of classifications in
this article and what they actually mean
we talked about how important that was
like just to kind of take some of the
scariness out of it to kind of to kind
of say like okay well Aspartame is on
the same level as the
apples like apples that have arsenic in
them or
um pickled vegetables you know what I
mean yeah and there's nothing about them
those are higher arsenic is group one
Aspartame is 2b you're right yes
yes I'm sorry I already forgot what was
in the different levels the pickled
vegetables that that was to be though
okay that's a good example okay pickled
vegetables
there's nothing about that
um and it seems to imply
that all the research points toward
cancer and that any arguments to the
contrary are just due to the influence
of Industry pressures so that's pretty
similar to the 2006 article from the
times that I talked a lot about earlier
after the ramazzini studies but why I
say that is is this quote from the
article Aspartame is only the latest
Battleground for multinational companies
to push back against new studies or
potential links to health risks
so it just sounds like it's saying like
the only reason it's it sounds like it's
saying all the science is against these
multinational companies and
multinational companies are the ones
pushing back against it yeah
um
there's much much more about the IRG
assessment
than the jekfa assessment like we were
talking about just a second ago so you
know a lot more about it being a
possible carcinogen than the guidelines
for consumption being completely
unaffected and when they do bring up
more on the jackfoot committee they do
so by citing the interim president of
the American Beverage Association
um like
they downplay it by by talking about the
jackfoot committee's ruling by putting
it in the mouth of a guy who obviously
has a vested interest yeah that that's
brutal like yeah if if they say hey the
the head of this independent committee
from the World Health Organization said
our intake guidelines haven't changed or
if the head of the [__] American
Beverage Association says this World
Health Organization committee didn't
change their guidelines the content of
those two statements would be identical
yeah um but yeah by making it the
American Beverage Association guy the
exact same information is going to be
viewed much more skeptically by the
reader than if you got one of the people
on the committee to say the exact same
thing yeah yeah
and then they they briefly talk about a
couple of the
um studies that you talked about Greg
the three that I Arc kind of cited as
the ones that they were assessing about
liver cancer so about the stepian paper
um they said quote each additional
serving of diet soft drink a week was
associated with a six percent increased
risk of liver cancer which again
technically true based on that study but
like
framing the the number and the
percentage in that way makes it sound a
lot scarier
and similarly for the McCullough paper
they say
a third study led by the American Cancer
Society quote found a 44 increase in
liver cancer among men who never smoked
and drank two or more artificially
sweetened drinks a day so that is kind
of like
to me that's kind of like oh look these
guys who never smoked they're the
picture of Health
and they drank two or more artificially
sweetened drinks a day and that and that
caused a 44 increase in liver cancer
yeah and and the thing is among people
who like I haven't looked this data up
but among people who never smoke
I'm sure that liver cancer rates are
hideously low and so then then you're
almost
um you're you're dealing so okay
I think folks who read a lot of like
exercise science research tend to get
blown away by like big sample sizes
um because a lot of studies in our field
have like 12 subjects per group so so
you read an Epi study with like 500 000
people and you're just like oh my God
that's insane they must have so much so
much statistical power or whatever but
in an epidemiology study this the sample
size is important but the number of
people who For Whom the outcome of
Interest was observed is much more
important so if you have uh a million
people in a study and uh you see you
know you split them on some [__]
variable and uh the outcome of Interest
like it happens with like 14 people in
one group and like 19 in the other it
doesn't matter that you started with a
big population like you still don't have
that like that many observations of the
outcome of Interest so like I sometimes
feel like a sick [__] when I'm reading
Epi studies especially things looking at
mortality yeah because like the first
thing I do I open it up and I just
scroll down to see how many people died
because like
for it to be reliable and for the
estimates to be like sufficiently
precise you want a lot of people to die
or in this case you want a lot of people
to get liver cancer
and since it's a relatively rare cancer
you're not going to be able to get great
Precision in your estimates
um so yeah like the the the number of
times the outcome of Interest was
observed is way more important than the
actual like
study size itself yeah and in this case
since hepatocellular carcinoma is such a
rare cancer
um
the the confidence you can have in like
any precise effect estimate is
necessarily going to have to be very
very low unless you just have an
enormous population like enough to where
you would be observing like a few
thousand cases of cancer
yeah yeah
that also that section about
the mccullo city after the thing about
smoking it said even adjusting for high
body mass in itself a cancer risk factor
the men had a 22 increase in Risk
so once again
the same thing just like big numbers and
then also adding the
adding those qualifiers that make it
seem like this is something that's
totally on its own aspartame risk is not
like you're not you're not getting stray
risk from high body mass or smoking or
anything like that like it's just the
aspartame that's causing these huge
increases in risk of getting this really
scary cancer
so that was the main that was the main
New York Times article about this but it
was a great
uh and then they had another one
um that's that was about the the
jackfoot thing that said despite
aspartame warning beverage companies
likely to stick with it that was the
headline
um so there's just kind of some
assumptions kind of baked in that
headline too yeah there's an implication
of malfeasance yes
so the there's a quote from that that
says a health agency warned the
artificial sweetener may be a carcinogen
but others say that risk is overblown
and consumers flock to The Taste again
this just seems to me like they're
breezing over the fact that the actual
guidelines haven't changed and that this
must be yeah some some sort of
conspiracy
um by the beverage industry and it just
seems like it's going to frighten people
unnecessarily yeah for sure
so I want to talk briefly about how
other outlets did
uh to report on this fairly I think it's
important for the article to at least
bring up the different levels of
classifications just for some context so
that's how I've sorted things I talked
about the Reuters article that broke the
story on June 29th earlier and I think
that that was a really measured one it
was called who's cancer research agency
to say aspartame sweetener a possible
carcinogen
and it it notes that
um that I Arc intended to assess whether
something is a potential Hazard or not
based on the published evidence it does
not take into account how much of a
product a person can safely consume and
that the advice for individuals comes
from a separate who expert committee
jackfa so it noted all of that even in
its earlier story and noted when the new
findings would come out the actual
report and the jackfo recommendations on
July 14th and also noted that the levels
are based on the strength of evidence
rather than how dangerous a substance is
um and then like there is the one line
about how
listing aspartame as a parse possible
carcinogen is intended to motivate more
research and that's something that I
didn't really understand until reading
about this quite a bit more that the
that the IR guidelines really are
not the guidelines the iarc reports
really are for researchers yes it's not
for public consumption it's not for
writing articles for public consumption
and that's why like when you read this
it is so confusing to just like a normal
person is because it's not for me it's
for other scientists to look at and and
note kind of like what the evidence is
right now and design future studies yeah
and the jekwa thing is the one that's
actually supposed to be public facing
and actually supposed to be giving the
recommendations that then the media can
report on but that that distinction just
is really important but just
doesn't really get brought up yeah no no
I mean it's um
like uh one of the things that I came
across a lot when reading about the IRC
reports in general is uh folks saying
like they've
um like irk has attracted criticism for
not like adequately spelling out what
their guidelines mean and like the
distinction between Hazard and risk and
whatnot and I mean like my response to
that is just like why the [__] should
they have to do that like their their
scientists writing to other scientists
who all know what that means
um like it's it's kind of it's kind of
like your fault for reading stuff that
you weren't meant to read or not making
sure you did like the adequate
background reading to understand what
the [__] you're reading before you then
went and told your like lay audience
some [__] because you misinterpreted
something that wasn't intended for you I
wonder how this would have been
different if like the report had come
out and there wasn't kind of a leak of
what it was going to say
I did see something that indicated that
like they decided based on the response
to that
to release the jackfa recommendations on
the same day that maybe they weren't
intending to do that before so if that's
the case it probably would have been
exactly the same but I do Wonder like if
those two things would have come out
together without any sort of leak if
there would have been any difference in
reporting hmm
that's a good that's a good question
um or if just like jackfo leaked as well
it's just like yeah people are getting
out of pocket about the I Arc report
leaks why don't we just leak our own
stuff yeah yeah I don't know I don't
know
so the next one I want to talk about is
from the BBC and this was probably
um this is the one that made me smile
the most I thought it was just kind of
fun
um so they they do start out like heavy
with putting this into context so I'm
just gonna read this for you
they can be found in the most unexpected
of places nonchalantly unfurling their
fronds at the side of a road so that's
referring to ferns
resting innocently on the shelves of a
health food store referring to aloe vera
extract
languishing among ancient condiments in
the fridge referring to pickled
vegetables in ambition for weekend hobby
at the back of your mind referring to
carpentry
these are the contents of the World
Health organization's watch list of the
dubious and questionable things they
consider to be quote possibly
carcinogenic to humans otherwise known
as group 2B
so I just love that they start out by
just listing the things that nobody is
actually afraid of
and then being like yeah chill the [__]
out like you don't care about these
things you shouldn't care that much
about aspartame yeah it also includes a
really great explanation of the
different groups and the fact that the
guidelines do not quantify the risk but
rather indicate the strength of the
evidence yeah
there's also a really excellent piece
from The Verge that was a little bit
more like in the weeds
but they same thing they they talk about
how IRC only assesses the hazard not the
risk and then they give the example of a
meteor destroying the Earth as a hazard
saying but that's not what matters to
the average person what matters is the
actual risk of a hazard happening there
are thousands of meteors in space but
only the one ones hurtling toward Earth
pose a risk so I just like that they
they gave like a the specific example
like you did with traffic
and they also gave a really great
explanation of the difference between I
Arc and jackfa and that's like kind of
what helped me understand the difference
in what these
um
what these groups are meant to be doing
because I didn't quite understand it
throughout a lot of This research
because it is so opaque but
um that article ends with the bottom
line is a leaked report from a non-food
safety agency is not what you should
base your decision to consume aspartame
on it's one of the most studied
sweeteners and it undergoes periodic
rigorous review by food safety agencies
until those agencies say otherwise
there's no need to panic and obviously
this was published before the jackfa
guidelines came out so that agency did
not say otherwise there is no need to
panic nice yeah good good for them that
that does sound like a very very
measured article yeah and the title of
that article was you don't have to freak
out about aspartame in your diet soda so
like didn't even didn't even put the
cancer word in there just saying like
chill out guys so I really liked that
nice shout out to Victoria song who was
the author of of that article yeah very
good stuff
um and then I I talked about the
guardian article
um the opinion piece from the
epidemiologist earlier when we were
talking about nutrient Sante but
um that article also was pretty good
um talking about that Aspartame is now
in the lowest possible risk category for
cancer-causing substances that the iarc
produces because a Class III carcinogen
technically just means that it can't be
assessed due to lack of evidence he says
class 2B means there's vague and
unproven risk that something might cause
cancer not that it does or is likely to
yeah that that I think sums it up pretty
well
um so it seems it seems like one of the
themes here is that with the exception
of the [__] New York Times a lot of
these Outlets have done a pretty good
job of reporting on this I do still have
some ones that I'm gonna [__] on in just
a second no that's fair yeah that's fair
but it like
it seems like a decent number of outlets
have done a pretty good job I was
surprised actually by how many like
measured reports there were yeah so I
have a hypothesis for why that might be
um and that is from the last time uh new
a new I Arc classification really made a
bunch of headlines and I think I I think
that basically [__] just went a bridge
too far and finally got a bunch of
people to look into something that they
wouldn't have looked into otherwise
um so in 2015 there was an i Arc
monograph classifying red meat and
processed meat they put processed meat
in group one as carcinogenic to humans
and red meat in group two as probably
carcinogenic to humans and there were
initially a bunch of just absolutely
breathless headlines about how the World
Health Organization said bacon is just
as bad as smoking or like sausages yeah
and I think I I think I think that like
a lot of journalists one saw what other
journalists were writing in their
headlines and be like that that has to
be [__] yeah and two just like
looked at the report itself and they
were just like wait a second yeah they
these these people classified uh
processed meat in the same category as
smoking
those have to mean different things like
I I can buy that processed meat is
carcinogenic I do not buy that it that
the risk of cancer is is great as it
would be with smoking and so I wouldn't
be surprised if uh that was just kind of
like a kick in the pants that
um that motivated people to look into
some more of these details of just like
hey what what do these classifications
actually mean like what does it mean
that something is a hazard versus a risk
yeah I just clicked on this Guardian
article that you have linked and the
headline is process meets rank alongside
smoking as cancer causes and then the
um like the little log line at the top
says un Health body says bacon sausages
and ham among most carcinogenic
substances along with cigarettes alcohol
Asbestos and arsenic yeah I'm like
that's a [__] rule dude uh and that
that was the tenor of a lot of the the
initial coverage back in 2015 and so I I
think a lot of journalists who had like
a shred of skepticism saw that and
they're like no [__] way like there
there's no way that that is what the
World Health Organization is actually
saying yeah and so then you kind of look
into what I Arc is actually saying and
what they mean
um so I I went on the the Wayback
machine to see what the original uh the
original headline was and it was
actually even slightly worse it was
bacon sausages and ham rank alongside
smoking as cancer causes it says World
Health Organization like come on like
that's but yeah so
um the that was really the last time
like in irk port or in I Arc report
really made splashy news headlines and I
think I think a lot of people learned
from that and have done a lot better
this time around that's good
so yeah it is time to bring up some more
of the articles that did not bring up
the classifications and because of that
I think could be misleading so there's a
Vox piece that kind of like the tenor of
it is just questioning the funding
sources behind studies that found
aspartame to be safe so kind of similar
to that 2006 New York Times article I
talked about but the author of this is a
physician researcher and epidemiologist
so I feel like that
kind of just like lend some Credence to
whatever they're saying
um so the headline of that article was
the who is about to declare aspartame
can cause cancer here's why you should
listen so it starts by or it goes
through the sketchiness of the FDA
approval process so here we are once
again talking about
the FDA approval process and how that
kind of has laid the groundwork for
people to be skeptical of this all along
um
and you know I whenever I was talking
about this stuff earlier like I agree
the FDA approval process sounded like a
mess and I found this article really
helpful when I was researching about the
FDA approval process but I'm like
how much longer are we going to keep
bringing this up like in terms of
assessing the safety of aspartame now
yeah I mean there have been so many
studies since then yeah the approval
process in the early 80s was sketchy as
[__] but it's 40 years later and there's
a lot of research on this like let's
look at the research yeah and also I
mean another thing to note is yeah maybe
there was like some weird collusion
between the the folks making it and like
Rumsfeld and the Reagan Administration
and all of that [__] but like
there wasn't the same sort of like
self-dealing and back scratching and
revolving door [__] going on in Europe
or like any of the other places that
have approved it
um
so yeah I mean that that that is both a
very valid criticism of how our like
uh legislative and like political
processes and Regulatory processes work
but also isn't as much of a slam dunk as
people might want to initially believe
that it is because there's not the same
collusion all the way down with every
health agency that has evaluated it yeah
um but they also mentioned the the
ramazzini study studies and call
the I guess they're talking about the
2005 one particularly high quality
oh no which uh from what we've learned
that's not true
and then we have again some gesturing
toward impropriety because of funding
sources saying many of the scientists
who disputed the ramzini institute's
findings were funded by industry
interests that profit from aspartame's
consumption which is true it is true yes
which which kind of goes back to
something I mentioned before about like
four hours ago which is that oftentimes
the same set of behaviors could either
come from like really nefarious uh
interests or just like much more benign
stuff and in this case like yeah so a
lot of the published research
pushing back against the the ramazzini
studies do come from people who are
funded by the American Beverage
Association or like other industry
groups
um but it's also like one they aren't
the only people who have criticized the
ramzini studies so like the the esfa
like Europe's version of the of the FDA
also independently evaluated them and
came to the same basic conclusion of
like ah this seems kind of sketchy and I
Arc also evaluated them in their report
and said ah these these seem kind of
sketchy like that's why we're saying
that the evidence in animals is limited
because like we don't take these like
super super seriously
um
so so yeah one it's not just industry
sources that take exception with the
ramzini Institute studies uh and two
let's say you're the American Beverage
Association and some dodgy ass studies
get published saying that your product
causes cancer and let's say your product
doesn't cause cancer
um
I I think it's very reasonable that you
might go out to people that that produce
uh like scientific articles and say hey
these studies are [__] uh can we
just like pay you a few thousand dollars
and you can just write about how these
studies are [__]
um and like that that is what you would
do if your product calls caused cancer
and you wanted to rebuff legitimate
findings and it's also what you do if
your product didn't cause cancer and you
wanted to rebuff sketchy findings yeah
so like it looks the same yeah and if
you're just like wired to be skeptical I
can understand why you would why you
would draw the the much more uh uh
serious inferences from that uh but yeah
like a single Behavior could
could be due to like very different
causes and I I very much think that's
what's Happening Here
I also thought it was interesting in
this Vox piece that the author's
conclusion is that the I Arc findings
are actually better and should be paid
attention to more than the Jackal ones
and should be the gold standard because
quote their assessment is not subject to
the kinds of Industry conflicts of
interest that pose challenges to the FDA
or efsa and they say that iarc is more
selective in its use of unpublished
confidential commercial data and it
takes greater care to exclude people
with conflicts of interest from
contributing to the evaluations whereas
jackfed just uses like a larger net and
they'll use
um like commercial data as well
but the author of this fox piece says
that
that means the I Arc
I don't want to call them guidelines
because they're not guidelines it's just
a report the classification the IR
classification is what the consumers
should be paying attention to whereas
like everything we've talked about here
and that this is also something that's
noted in The Verge article that I really
enjoyed that I talked about just a
second ago frame the larger net
objectfa as more as better as positive
and like the fact that that is actually
the group that makes recommendations
rather than the group that's just
assessing things for research purposes
yeah
yeah so I I can understand why
um like unpublished safety data from
industry sources that's like submitted
to regulatory bodies like I can
understand why people would be skeptical
of that yeah
um
but
it's so it's one of those things where
like from a pure risk assessment
perspective
it wouldn't make a ton of sense for them
to fudge that data
um because like basically if you have if
you have a product that causes cancer
that you by law have to do ongoing
monitoring for
um
to like assess it safety and especially
if you're dealing with artificial
sweeteners where if it turns out
aspartame causes cancer guess what you
can just swap it out for something else
um in a situation like that
uh one you you probably have the most
and highest quality data of anyone
because you have to do ongoing safety
monitoring uh to keep your food additive
on the market
um two
if you fabricated that [__]
um that's going to get found out like if
if it does actually cause cancer and you
know you might know before anyone else
but people are going to find out and
then
um
it it will be like a a Sackler family an
oxycontin situation like like when
companies are aware of risks and sit on
them for too long
um
it's it's [__] bad like oftentimes
there's class action lawsuits the
government itself might impose fines
um that's that's one of the few ways
that like corporate bigwigs might get
sent to jail for corporate malfeasance
yeah
um and also like in this case
the the like you have Alternatives you
know like like the actual manufacturers
of aspartame
like I I can see the incentives there
but like beverage industry sources
um if aspartame causes cancer they want
to know because
you you don't if you're Pepsi if you're
PepsiCo you don't want headlines saying
Pepsi causes cancer you want to [__]
know that aspartame causes cancer and
swap it out for something else before
those headlines hit so then like
when the headlines hit that oh we now
know aspartame causes cancer you can be
like hey [__] I got sucralose you
know what I mean yeah
um so yeah like
I I definitely think that uh being
cognizant of and skeptical of funding
sources like I I definitely think that's
good to do but it's also
worth keeping incentives in mind yeah
and in this situation most interested
industry parties would have reason to to
have good data not bad data yeah
and and the the
costs of
um
of like submitting fabricated data to to
regulatory bodies far out seeds the
benefits they would derive from it
because again you you could you could
just sub it out for any other artificial
sweetener like it's it's not a situation
where like you get upside by keeping
aspartame and specifically aspartame in
your product and nothing else
um it's it's a situation where like
yeah you you have you have uh like clear
and obvious substitutions that consumers
also like
so yeah like I I I understand the
skepticism but I think that the
concern should largely be mitigated like
once once you kind of prod at it a
little bit
yeah I think that this article it does
have like Fair critiques kind of on the
surface but then just doesn't
necessarily present those in a way
that's even
um
and the result is just I think
a lot of distrust in people probably
walking away from this
more scared than they need to be yeah
and also just confused about what what
who
um
agency like they should be taking their
recommendations from yeah for sure
I mean
I I don't know I would be interested in
writing the author of this article and
just being like hey when it comes to
um
when it comes to pickled vegetable
consumption are you looking at the jekfa
guidelines or do you just like say oh
pickles on my burger no things I don't
want [__] cancer anytime yeah pickles
are presented to you I I take irk so
much more seriously like no like I I
would I would almost guarantee that
because yeah if you're like I don't know
the IR guidelines for aspartame or 2B
can't have that anyone that says
otherwise is an industry shill what do
you do never leave your house because
this UV rays are in group one like no
like I I
I question whether they even believe
that or would believe that if they
thought about it a little bit more yeah
yeah
all right moving on from the Vox piece
uh The Washington Post published two
articles that I saw
um the first one was the main one about
the news
um and it was called aspartame one of
the world's most common sweeteners under
scrutiny from who no mention of the
classifications in that one there are
some like a there's a brief mention of
the classifications in their second one
but that article is called cancer risk
or no diet soda is bad for you hell yeah
and so like they mentioned the
classifications but then the rest of the
Articles just tell about how diet soda
is bad for you and it includes the the
rats getting brain cancer thing without
any context so not great from wapo there
no
uh several articles also took this as a
chance to just list out popular foods
and beverages that contain aspartame
which like I understand people are going
to be seeing the other reporting and
being like Oh God what do I eat that has
aspartame in it and so CBS News article
no mentions of the classification
um and then they have they have a
section of the article at the headline
is aspartame dangerous
and uh
they basically answer yes
while several studies have determined
aspartame to be safe in moderation some
research has linked aspartame
consumption to cancer one observational
study of more than a hundred thousand
adults in France that's nutrient Sante
that we talked about earlier concluded
that individuals who consume larger
amounts of artificial sweeteners
especially aspartame had a slightly
elevated risk of cancer aspartame may
also cause headache seizures and
depression some Studies have shown
solid stuff and then they just yeah they
just list out foods and beverages with
the sweetener which kind of indicates
that readers should begin avoiding them
um if you're if you're going to list
stuff out like that the guardian and
Fortune also had similar articles
then the last one I'll talk about
was a little bit different as a people
article
the title was who to announce artificial
sweetener aspartame may cause cancer and
they went the whole formaldehyde
methanol route oh no
they quoted from a
newsmedical.net article which I don't
know if that website is at all
trustworthy but yeah give me two seconds
to look at them yeah
uh
it's a lot of noises
no so there's
[Music]
um
there there is kind of like this brand
of medical sites that
um
that kind of like it's it's like medical
click bait almost it's it's kind of like
the I [__] love science of medicine
no no where it's just like we're going
to
start start with raw materials of things
that are true but then just kind of like
amp them up a little bit and like strip
them of enough context that they'll be a
little bit more clickable and perform a
little bit better on the social media
algorithms
um
and that that looks like the kind of
sight that this is like
I'm not immediately
seen things that look completely
divorced from reality but it's it's it
looks like a science clickbait site
yeah well that's what this people
article used as their main source so
they say the problem with Aspartame is
how the chemical is metabolized in the
body
and then just general fear-mongering
over how aspartame leads to release of
methanol which is converted to
formaldehyde and then they say quote in
addition to the direct damage methanol
causes to the liver formaldehyde is also
directly toxic to liver cells and
associated with cancer-causing
properties but how much so there how
much do you need they're like doing like
proposing an entire mechanism here
oh God we're just stripping a lot of
context that's bad that's really bad
yeah if you can if you could just to
reiterate because I realized I said this
initially like three hours ago but if
you consume the maximum like recommended
amount of aspartame the amount of
methanol you get from that is like 1 6
as much as your body produces just from
eating [__] fruits and vegetables
every day like the dough the dose makes
the poison like uh this is this is
simultaneously true and hideously
misleading yeah Aspartame is metabolized
to methanol which is converted to
formaldehyde methanol does damage the
liver formaldehyde is also toxic to
liver cells uh and none of that is
relevant because the amounts we're
dealing with are
irrelevantly small yep God that makes me
so mad so sorry to sorry to end and
there I do
um as we move into our concluding
remarks
um cheers all around I I really enjoyed
this article from the Atlantic that
title was just being alive is bad for
your health and I wanted to quote that
to kind of end my
foray through the media
over the past few decades a growing
number of foods and behaviors have
become the regular subject of vague
ever-changing Health warnings fake
sweeteners real sugar wine butter milk
carbohydrates coffee fat chocolate eggs
meat veganism vegetarianism weight
lifting drinking a lot of water and
scores of others the more warnings there
are the less actionable any particular
one of them feels what exactly is anyone
supposed to do with any of this
information except feel bad about the
things they enjoy
yeah I think I think that sums it up
pretty well
um
yeah I don't I don't have much to add to
that yeah how do you think about the
risks of consuming aspartame or like red
meat or using a cell phone it's
impossible to avoid
everything that could possibly have any
link yeah to cancer or something a
negative a negative Health outcome
um how do you and maybe how do you
recommend if you're comfortable doing
that
um
people kind of think about things like
this without driving themselves crazy
sure yeah so I think that
um
I think that
one of the things that's like kind of
instructive for me is the difference
between
uh like good coaching and bad coaching
in the gym so if if You observe a very
bright Young new uh personal trainer
right out of college that knows a bunch
of stuff but hasn't trained that many
people and you give them an untrained
lifter and tell them to squat and uh
have them coach a squat what you often
see
is a lot of very good and very useless
advice because the person who's never
squatted before is gonna have a terrible
squat they don't know what they're doing
and this this Bright Young trainer is
competent and identifies 30 problems
with their squad and then they make the
mistake of telling that person all 30 of
those problems and how to try to fix
them and then guess what their next
squat is going to look even worse
because they're focusing on 30 things
whereas the the good coach like the one
that actually knows what they're doing
will see the squat and maybe identify 40
problems because they've been doing it
for a while they've they've seen more
they know more
and the advice they're going to give the
new lifter is they're going to tell them
one thing because they don't just know
all of the things wrong they know what
the worst thing wrong is uh and
oftentimes you fix that one thing and a
lot of other stuff falls into place so
on the second rep you just give them one
cue they execute it pretty well and now
instead of 50 things wrong with their
squat now maybe you're down to ten and
it's like okay let's not rush into the
next one let's do a few more reps and
then I'll give you one more cue
like the the second biggest thing that
was wrong with your squad before and now
we got something looking pretty good and
so we can work with this we can train it
there are still some things you could do
better
and maybe next week I'll give you one
one new thing to work on and maybe it'll
be next month like it's already looking
decent enough
um and I I view a lot of
a lot of stuff kind of along those lines
where
I mean ultimately
ultimately like [__] everything will
kill you and we're all gonna die yeah
like that I realize that's kind of dark
um I mean I feel like that's necessary
to remember and like to just State like
we are living in bodies that are
designed to die yeah we're we're all
slowly deteriorating every day
um
and I think ultimately it makes the most
sense to focus on the big rocks like
what is actually going to move the
needle in a big way
and
um
I mean
like don't smoke that one's obvious
uh don't drink in excess
um
try to maintain a close enough to
healthy body weight where like even like
there's a fair bit of of wiggle room in
that like people people talk about the
risks associated with obesity but like
real really like we're talk we're
talking about things kind of going up in
a big way once you clear like a BMI of
like 35 or so but like
any anywhere from like uh BMI like 20 to
35 like it's pretty it's pretty decent
like maybe 25 is a little better than 35
but we're not talking about like a Mac
in order of magnitude of difference
there uh so yeah like maintain a healthy
weight don't don't smoke don't drink
exercise regularly
get enough sleep eat your fruits and
vegetables
you do those things you're you're in
pretty good shape yeah
um you know that's enough to focus on
yeah and and that's that's a hard amount
of things for like somebody kind of just
starting to think about how to improve
their health to focus on yeah we don't
need to throw in like
you know this huge list of other things
that
no can't eat any of these either yeah
and and once once you have all of that
on lock then maybe you can start
thinking about other stuff but like you
know if if you never exercise but you're
like oh oh you know what I'm gonna do
I really want to improve my my health
I'm gonna stop drinking diet soda yeah
I mean it's the your your return on
investment there is just not going to be
great especially when there's other
stuff that you can do that's going to
give you a much larger return on
investment so that's that's the big one
like focus on the big stuff and uh if
you find yourself maybe thinking about
wanting to major in a minor make sure
you've majored in the majors first yeah
and then you you might have a little
more license to major in the minors a
little more uh the second
is that ultimately we are
here to live we're not just here to
avoid dying
um
and so like
I don't know like there there are any
number of things that are bad for me
that I still do because I want to right
um like you know I alcohol consumption
of any quantity is bad for you uh
processed meat consumption of any
quantity is bad for you but like
if I'm out with friends like I'm gonna
get a beer and like if a nice
charcuterie board is in front of me I am
going to eat some charcuterie you know
what I mean yeah
um
because like at the end of the day if I
lived in a way to like fully minimize
risk uh in all regards
who knows maybe I live an extra five
years and the the years that I lived in
aggregate would just be like so much
less fulfilling um it's just stressful
yeah trying to avoid all that all the
time yeah like if you were stressing out
about everything that POS that was
possibly a risk of anything
just being under that constant stress
might actually like present you with a
larger risk than all of the other [__]
you are mitigating
um so yeah that's the second thing uh
the third thing is like
and I don't this this is kind of
predicated on like a willingness to look
into things a willingness and ability to
look into things a little bit more
deeply and like weigh things more
explicitly
where like if someone tells me that
something is a potential risk for
whatever
that means nothing to me and I don't
care what I want to know is why it's a
risk uh to to what extent does it
increase risk and what does kind of the
the dose response curve look like if
that's known
um
and
if if I don't know those three things
I'm just not going to think about it and
if I do know those three things then
instead of viewing something as a binary
I can moderate my behavior appropriately
um so like uh I think like alcohol is
another is is a good example of this as
well like it's it is a risk factor like
alcohol consumption is a risk factor for
like so many things but
um
you know the the increase in Risk is
non-linear and like moderate alcohol
consumption is associated with like
slightly worse outcomes
in a lot of different domains
but like the effect size is Tiny and the
really bad [__] doesn't really start
ticking up until you're drinking like
kind of a lot most days and so like my
alcohol consumption is once a week I
have like two or three drinks and would
I maybe be a little bit healthier and
live a little bit longer if I didn't do
that like yeah sure maybe
um but also like the extent to which
that increases my risk is small enough
and the pleasure that I derive from that
is large enough that the benefits
outweigh the risks and the risks
themselves are so small
um
so yeah I mean those are those are the
the general principles I'm working with
[Music]
um
yeah
how about you
I mean I think that you are a much less
anxious person than I am
so I kind of try to
like I like hearing your perspective
because I feel like it is it is the
perspective that I strive toward
um I don't really have issues with
uh freaking out about diet soda or
alcohol
um
with the with the alcohol example like
it is something that I understand is not
optimal
but similarly I also understand that
like
it it Dr I derive pleasure from it that
I think is worth whatever risk and
I'm just trying generally to not be as
freaked out by things and realizing that
you're not going to be perfect yeah
you're gonna do things that aren't quote
optimal
and that will make life less stressful
if you just stop worrying so much about
that and do your best and realize like
I'm gonna die either way yeah and I'm
just
that's fine
yeah like what I would I rather have
like
75 great years or like 80 miserable
years like I'm I'm going with the 75
yeah and who knows when I'm like 73 I
may say God I did all of this wrong I
should have I should have been a little
more miserable so I would have another
seven years left but
um
I don't I don't think that that's
I mean like there are interviews with
like people at end of life and most of
the regrets people have are like uh
I wish I would have like spent more time
with my family right not like damn I I
really regret that I consumed a average
of 2.4 alcoholic beverages per week
because if I didn't my uh average Health
span would have been an additional four
months you know like that's no
come on
people who die of lung cancer like I
shouldn't have smoked
the when when people when it's the bad
stuff that like the really bad stuff
that really increases your risk like
people look back on yeah stuff like that
and you're really suffering like from a
specific thing like yeah you're dying of
lung cancer or something
yeah I guess I'll also say about diet
soda is like
also if you don't want to drink it don't
drink it yeah like that's fine
um I personally don't drink a lot of
diet soda because it makes me feel like
I have like acid reflux and so I don't
drink diet soda that often but like
that's fine and so like if you want to
drink it drink it if you don't like how
it makes you feel
don't drink it
for sure
um no I I agree with that wholeheartedly
and um
yeah yeah uh
yeah don't don't really have too much to
add
um
also
I will just I I want to note before we
get into our like
couple of like broader little
discussions that we definitely need to
keep them short because we've been we've
been rolling uh for a long time yeah but
one thing I just want to note is like I
I am slightly concerned that in this
episode it may sound like I am just an
industry shill for the beverage company
or for the beverage companies because
I by and large don't actually think
they've they've behaved particularly
poorly when it comes to aspartame or at
least like especially with like the
sketchy stuff with like the aspartame
approval process like I think that was
mostly motivated by just like trying to
save time and money not necessarily
because they were trying to get a
dangerous product on the market
um anyway so yeah like I I am slightly
concerned that it sounds like I like big
corporations more than I actually do
yeah you hate this so immigration let me
just say like [__] the American Beverage
industry in general they suck okay
um they were
responsible for
um
like a lot of public
public like quote-unquote information
work to shift to the focus uh towards
dietary fat and away from sugar when it
came to a lot of health risks
um and yeah like they they just suck in
general
um
they
exploit a lot of foreign workers
um they yeah they just suck like I I I
have I have no love for those guys
um yeah I think they're I think they're
terrible but also
I do think Aspartame is generally fine
and so I'm not going to rank them over
the coals for that specifically because
I think they're just way more valid
reasons to criticize them yeah
um so yes I just wanted to get that out
there like right they suck this is just
not the particular thing they suck for
very important to distinguish yes uh
okay so let's very briefly
um touch on a couple little things that
are like related to the things we've
talked about here uh one of the things
on our list was talking about kind of
like funding sources and just
immediately assuming that stuff with
industry funding is bad uh We've I think
we've talked about that enough I think
we can skip over it
um
next thing on the list is just like the
naturalistic fallacy and
why and like how that might play into a
lot of the fear that people have about
aspartame and also like
going back to kind of the Alternatives
the alternative to artificial sweeteners
is sugar yeah and sugar like the the
evidence on like sugar affecting all all
sorts of numbers of disease risk is like
way stronger than it is for artificial
sweeteners but since it's natural yeah
yeah
um
so yeah what what are your what are your
thoughts on kind of that General line of
thinking and like the the naturalistic
fallacy in general
it's really easy to kind of fall into it
um to to view things as
as more credible or more trustworthy
um or safer to consume in terms of food
if like it's something that is can be
found in nature and I think that's like
a huge part of the sugar versus
artificial sweetener thing but also just
like why it doesn't affect us that much
when we see other things in those cancer
or in those carcinogen categories
um
like the ferns being in one of the
categories like obviously people well
actually people do eat ferns or like
pickled vegetables
um it's just like Well it can't be that
bad for me because it's natural like
it's something that grew from the Earth
um
and I wish that people would just
uh
have that same
kind of Grace with other things as well
um but I guess it kind of makes sense
that
over the span of human history a lot of
these kind of artificially created
products are relatively new to us
and
having some degree of skepticism is
understandable yeah
no I I agree with that my my general
take on it is that
I'm I'm very sympathetic to it
um like I think a lot of I think a lot
of sciency folks have a tendency to be
just like really really condescending
about the naturalistic fallacy and
appeal to Nature
um
yeah we're where they'll just be like
well arsenic's natural and it'll kill
you and like I I don't know uh like
yeah I I I think that
I can understand why people fall into
that line of thinking because
I mean we did kind of make it as a
species yeah it feels proven yeah like
the the natural way
wasn't good for a lot of individuals
like the the
um
typical life of the average person for
most of human history like kind of
sucked ass but uh the natural way was at
least sufficient for our species to make
it this this long
um
and also like
especially
especially like over the last couple of
centuries or so there have been a lot of
uh
uh like artificial like industrial
things that either like directly caused
a lot of problems that that
um
like like shouldn't have been consumed
by humans in the first place like like
in here I'm talking about like stuff in
the 1800s
um but then like even more recently
there there have been a lot of things
that where there have just been like
unintended consequences from like you
know quote-unquote like artificial stuff
that maybe aren't found out about until
like years or decades later yeah
um
like uh I I don't know like I think I
think like air pollution is a good
example of that like people used to kind
of think like ah car exhaust was kind of
fine or at least like not that bad but
like no it gives you cancer and causes
asthma and is uh associated with like
large increases in heart disease risk
and just like a bunch of other [__]
um so like I I I
get it and my perspective is
less that like the the hard version of
the naturalistic fallacy of just like
what is artificial is good and what is
or what is natural is good and what is
artificial is bad and more like kind of
viewing it in kind of like a Bayesian
probabilistic way where it's like
classic Greg yeah where where if if
something is natural I'm I'm not like
super confident that it's good but in
the absence of other evidence my kind of
Baseline assumption is like yeah it's
probably okay and yeah things that are
artificial if I don't have access to any
other information or like in the absence
of any other data my kind of like a
baseline assumption is like ah maybe I
should be a little skeptical of this
right but it's it's less of like a
100 zero zero hundred thing where like
everything natural is good everything
artificial is bad and more of like a
like a 60 40 thing in either direction
like I'm I think I think I am like
for like quote unquote Natural Things
I my Baseline assumption is it's
probably okay and I need to see evidence
against that and for like more quote
unquote artificial things my Baseline
assumption is like I'm not so sure about
this and like I I need to see a little
evidence that it's okay yeah but then
when I see that evidence yeah my my
opinion is very malleable
um
and also like I I'm not like hyper
skeptical of of a lot of artificial
things that have actually gone through
appropriate approval processes
um because like
I also don't want to sound like a shill
for for governments but like you hate
governments too the public health
agencies are generally pretty good like
stuff that the FDA I was what you're
afraid of saying yeah yeah I mean I
don't know like there are there are good
parts of the government and I think the
FDA is a good part of the government
okay uh like congrats to the FDA yeah
like stuff stuff they approve is
generally pretty good stuff that like
the efsa approves in Europe is is
generally pretty good like
um yeah like a like chemicals and
additives and artificial food additives
and whatnot that have gone through the
appropriate like regulatory approval
processes
um
like they tend to have a pretty good
track record and like there there are
certainly instances of that process like
breaking down and stuff slipping through
that probably shouldn't but uh those
those instances are rare
um
so yeah I don't know yeah I think with
most fallacies it's just useful to keep
in mind to just kind of check your own
assumptions against
um like once you learn about it
it's just helpful as kind of a filter
for sure
um and it's also really helpful to kind
of
have your eyes open to how much
marketing is trying to sell you on
things being natural and just being able
to kind of tune that out as like a
selling point to be helpful for folks oh
for sure for sure I you know I also
think I also think people should think a
little bit more about the
about about what would happen if
everyone was as into like quote unquote
natural stuff as they were
um and one of my go-to examples for that
is like uh organic farming and chemical
fertilizers
um
like the world couldn't support its
current population without chemical
fertilizers like
given the amount of arable land there is
and given the number of humans on the
planet and how many calories humans need
to consume the math just doesn't work
out
um so it's it's one of those things
where like if if everyone went that
route
uh you know you you may think that there
are marginal benefits to you of like
consuming organic products that are made
without chemical fertilizers and all of
that stuff and like
I'm generally skeptical that organic
food is better than conventionally grown
food but like you know let's suffer
blueberries
yes oh my God the Driscoll's organic
blueberries are I don't I don't even
give a [__] that they're organic and I
kind of taste better I kind of wish they
weren't because
the organic label just adds like two two
dollars per per carton uh just right off
the top but yeah man they are so much
better than the other ones yeah but
usually I don't notice any difference
yes there's just a select mostly produce
yes
um but but yeah so I don't know it's one
of those things where it's like if if
you believe this strongly in it an
implication of that is like if
like if everyone went that route there
would like be Mass starvation yeah bad
so it's like maybe you should be a
little bit accepting of it yeah uh a lot
a lot of like artificial things and like
industrial processes are necessary for
the general standard of living in the
world that exists today to continue and
if we if we returned to tradition uh to
too large of an extent yeah there would
be billions of people who died as a
result so
the to some extent you just need to get
used to it unless you're comfortable
with like Mass death
um which I'm not
uh
that's that's my bold moral stance here
I am not particularly comfortable with
mass death that's so great
um
one other thing that I wanted to bring
up I guess uh especially as it relates
to like skepticism not just for like
unnatural things but like artificial
sweeteners in particular is I think a
a just kind of like a bit of like a
cultural code that a lot of us have is
the idea that uh if if something's too
good to be true it probably is like the
the idea that like there's no such thing
as a free lunch or there's always a
catch yeah
um that's like that's a decent heuristic
because a lot of things that seem too
good to be true are probably not true
um but it's like that's
like it's a good Baseline assumption but
it's not a hard and fast rule yeah and I
think when it comes to artificial
sweeteners I think I think the the
promise of like this tastes like sugar
but it's it's not sugar it's not going
to have the deleterious health effects
uh it doesn't contain the empty calories
um like it definitely sounds too good to
be true yeah and I think you encounter
that and you run that little bit of like
cultural programming of if it seems too
good to be true it probably is
um and and I think a lot of people have
a tendency to treat that as a hard and
fast rule instead of just like an
initial assumption that can certainly be
disproven if something
is in fact not too good to be true like
it's good and it's also true like
sometimes things are both good and true
um
so yeah what are what are your takeaways
uh what are your takeaways from all of
this oh my gosh there's so much
there's so much we've gotten through
I haven't had a chance to kind of sit
back and think what my what my takeaways
are
um
I mean I
I don't think that this changed my view
of aspartame all that much I thought it
was fine I still think it's fine
but I do think that
what changed is like my understanding of
why
there's like such a cultural assumption
that there's go there has to be
something wrong with aspartame and
like just these Decades of history of
people saying that there's this link
between aspartame and cancer I didn't
realize how much history was there
going all the way back to
how much people distrusted saccharin and
cyclomate like you talked about
to like
the really strange FDA approval process
to like you know the labels on the
saccharine being there for 30 years so
like you have
so many people who just associate
artificial sweetener with cancer because
they literally saw it on a label on
those products for so long
and then
all the recent stuff just kind of has
built upon that and I think before I was
really annoyed
with people who had tried to tell me
like
that Aspartame is bad for you or that
artificial sweeteners are bad for you
like I mentioned that flight attendant
which she was out of pocket but
I guess I have a bit more empathy for
her and older people in general I think
who just have kind of grown who grew up
in a world and have lived their entire
adult lives in a world in which it's
like oh yeah that stuff is not safe
and so
I think that would be my takeaway
generally
um
I learned a lot
kind of looking through all of the media
coverage
and I think I got a little bit better at
kind of being able to pick out the the
types of things that journalists do that
aren't
quite representative of the scientific
findings they're trying to report and I
definitely don't hold that against
journalists for all the reasons we
talked about previously but it's useful
just as kind of a filter especially as
we go forward with this show this was
kind of a trial by fire for me I think I
probably read
between 50 and 75 articles
um and like kind of analyze them for
this
so I'm excited to kind of dig into this
style of research even more and kind of
looking at how things are reported and
how they could be better and hopefully
also having an opportunity to call out
some of the journalists and Outlets that
are doing a really great job along the
way
sounds great yeah what about you
um
yeah I mean I I agree with everything
you said for sure awesome
um
yeah I mean my my assumption coming in
was that Aspartame is probably fine my
assumption on the back end is that
Aspartame is probably fine
um
I I definitely learned a lot about the
history of artificial sweeteners like
you said to kind of understand better
the the level of just kind of like low
simmering cultural anxiety there is
around them like I now have a much
better idea of where that came from
[Music]
um
let's see
yeah I mean I I think I think also just
a general takeaway is that evaluating
scientific findings is tough yeah and
that
I
don't necessarily hold individual
scientists accountable for not
communicating their findings that well
with the public because like that's
quite literally that is not their job
right like science is a hard enough job
uh without you needing to like be media
trained on top of it but I do kind of
think that when you're the literal World
Health Organization you
I think it's probably incumbent upon you
to be a bit more proactive to make sure
that like the kind of like constituent
bodies working under your umbrella that
their research and findings is
appropriately reported yeah um
like when when the World Health
Organization puts out a press release
saying I Arc is going to classify or has
classified aspartame as a possible
carcinogen that should include what the
classifications mean the distinction
between Hazard and risk and say hey I
Arc did this jackfa also evaluated the
same [__] evidence and their
recommendations haven't changed so like
if you're going to print something about
this print that print this this is the
bit that's meant for human consumption
you know because like they they do have
a press arm like they they do have folks
that specialize in communication and it
really seemed like they printed it like
they didn't think anybody was gonna look
at it yeah like just clueless correct uh
and then I mean yeah so yeah that's I
don't know I I think that I think that
that
uh
uh I'm I'm sympathetic to scientists who
have their own stuff kind of put out and
misinterpreted and they they feel like
it kind of gets away from them because
like like I said that's not there's that
that's not their job but like stuff like
the World Health Organization things
like governments things like University
press departments yeah um
which university press departments
didn't show up in the story but they'll
they'll show up in a future episode I'm
sure and they uh often suck
um anyway when when folks like that
um are the ones contributing to how
stuff can be misinterpreted
um
I think that that's kind of egregious
and I think that that has that that has
happened here to a large extent yeah
um
which is unfortunate but
uh at the end of the day
it is what it is I've been talking for a
long time I'm about to go drink a Dr
Pepper zero sugar which is sweetened
with Aspirin I'm gonna have a beer
sounds good uh all right let's wrap it
up uh thank you guys for listening to
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast if you liked this
episode please like rate and subscribe
share this episode with your friends
um also like yeah like share it with
your friends because if you made it to
the end of this episode it's like five
and a half hours long uh you've been
forming a deep parasocial relationship
with us for too far too long of a period
of time you should you should talk with
this with like other people in your life
in the real world
um you should force other people to do
this yeah yeah you know what maybe share
the podcast in general with friends but
like don't share this episode with them
uh because they no one should listen to
episodes so what should make episodes
this isn't an episode I feel like I'm
losing my mind I do too this was not a
podcast episode this was our aspartame
audiobook so you've got bought that for
free just do that little switch in your
mind of the framing
it was a free book this was this was a
literal Herculean ordeal like Hercules
may have been able to wrestle a lion but
he has never recorded a five and a half
hour long podcast episode and quite
frankly I think one is more impressive
than the other
anyways uh so thanks for listening
um and uh we'll be back in two weeks we
we love you and appreciate you and and
we hope the next Fortnight is is one of
joy and and wonder and uh if you like
aspartame hopefully plenty of aspartame
for you and if not uh still still not
any aspartame for you uh okay goodbye